This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Cailin. Today we're covering part four of the end of the section called The Use of Power. That's chapters 21 through 24, and in my book those are pages 402 to 495. Later on, our guest for this episode will be Brandi Zdrosny. She's a senior reporter for NBC News who covers misinformation, conspiracy theories, and the internet. She recently finished The Power Broker and she's got a great perspective on what the book says about the press and its relationship to power,
这是《99%隐形》对《权力经纪人》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·凯林。今天我们要讲的是题为“权力的使用”这一部分结束时的第四部分。也就是第21到第24章，在我的书里，这些是第402到495页。稍后，我们这期的嘉宾将是布兰迪·兹德罗斯尼。她是美国全国广播公司新闻网的资深记者，负责报道虚假信息、阴谋论和互联网。她最近读完了《权力经纪人》，对于这本书关于新闻界及其与权力关系的的观点，她有着非常独到的视角，
what has changed in journalism, and what remains the same. So when we last left The Power Broker, the Depression is dawning, Robert Moses keeps opening state park projects and to great public acclaim, he's just a hero. Moses gets Governor Lehman and Mayor LaGuardia to give him total control over anything remotely park related in New York City and passes a new law where a state person and a city person can do all this stuff at once. He immediately refurbishes New York City's major parks. He's unveiled this massive plan for building expressways and bridges through and around the cities that people don't have to go through Manhattan
以及新闻业发生了什么变化，又有什么保持不变。所以，当我们上次合上《权力经纪人》时，大萧条正在来临，罗伯特·摩西不断启动州立公园项目，并赢得公众的极大赞誉，他简直是个英雄。摩西让雷曼州长和拉瓜迪亚市长授予他对纽约市任何与公园沾边的事物的绝对控制权，并通过了一项新法律，让一个州级官员和一个市级官员可以同时处理所有这些事情。他立即翻新了纽约市的主要公园。他公布了一项庞大的计划，要在城市之中及周边修建高速公路和桥梁，这样人们就不必再穿过曼哈顿
to get to places on either side anymore. And the Triborough Bridge Authority has begun to actually start building the Triborough Bridge, which will become the centerpiece and provide all the funding for his empire as well. But there's a little bit going on here where his pettiness is starting to seep out to people who are his staunchest allies. So, you know, he destroys the Central Park Casino just because it was Jimmy Walker's playground and he just, out of spite, he just wants to level it instead of turning it into something equally good or better, you know?
去往两侧的目的地了。三区大桥管理局也已经开始着手建造三区大桥，这将成为他帝国的核心，并为他的帝国提供全部资金。但这里发生了一点小插曲，他的狭隘开始流露出来，对象还是他最坚定的盟友。所以，你看，他毁掉了中央公园赌场，仅仅因为那是吉米·沃克的游乐场，出于恶意，他只想把它夷为平地，而不是把它变成同样好甚至更好的东西，你知道吗？
And so, so that's where we are. So he's still like in that phase where he's getting a lot done. Most people are on his side, but that is about to take a turn right now with Chapter 21, The Candidate. And so, Elliot, I love this opening line. Could you read the opening line to The Candidate? Oh, it's wonderful. The Candidate begins, Leslie. There had been a day in 1934 on which the cheering had stopped. It was the day Robert Moses started running for governor. It's like,
所以，这就是我们目前所处的情况。所以他依然处于那种大有作为的阶段。大多数人都站在他这一边，但这即将发生转变，从第21章《候选人》开始。那么，埃利奥特，我很喜欢这句开场白。你能读一下《候选人》的开场白吗？哦，太棒了。《候选人》的开头是这样的，莱斯利。1934年曾有一天，欢呼声停了。那是罗伯特·摩西开始竞选州长的那天。这就像是，
oh boy, that's not a good sign. He's used to everyone loving him and he's like, great, I'm gonna run for public office. And it is almost as if he decides to do everything he possibly can to undo every good thing about his reputation during this very brief run for governor. It's amazing. And this pettiness that you were talking about, it's starting to seep out. It's almost like it starts gushing at this point.
天哪，这不是个好兆头。他习惯了所有人都爱戴他，于是他想，太好了，我要去竞选公职。而在这次非常短暂的州长竞选中，他几乎是在竭尽所能地去毁掉自己声誉中所有美好的东西。这太惊人了。你刚才说的那种狭隘，开始流露出来了。在这个时候，感觉它几乎就像是喷涌而出了。
The faucet gets stuck open and he'll fix that leaky pettiness faucet, but it takes him a little bit of time. And it's just amazing. So Carol points out that in later years, Moses would tell people after he knew that he had lost the governorship. Spoiler alert, he does not become governor. I'll just tell you right now. He'll tell people later.
水龙头卡住了，虽然他会修好那个漏水的狭隘水龙头，但这需要花他一点时间。这真是太神奇了。所以卡罗指出，在后来的几年里，摩西在知道自己输掉了州长竞选之后，会告诉人们。剧透一下，他没有当选州长。我现在就告诉你们。他后来会告诉人们。
I did it reluctantly. I was just trying to hold the party together. But the people around him tell Caro that he was hungry for it. And he gets offered the nomination by our old friend Truby Davison, the wealthy young state legislature who, years earlier, Moses had tricked him into sponsoring his state parks bill that made him the most powerful man in New York state. And there's a little bit here about how Davidson was working for the old guard of the state GOP, and those are the rich barons.
我是勉为其难才这么做的。我只是想把党派团结在一起。但周围的人告诉卡罗，他是渴望得到这个职位的。我们的老朋友特鲁比·戴维森向他提供了提名。特鲁比·戴维森是一位富有的年轻州议员，几年前，摩西曾哄骗他发起自己的州立公园法案，正是这个法案让他成为了纽约州最有权势的人。这里还提到了一些背景，戴维森当时是在为州共和党的老卫队效力，也就是那些富有的权贵们。
They want someone who will stand for them against the New Deal and against Mayor LaGuardia and that kind of stuff. And they also, they want a governor who's finally gonna take all these public power sources like Niagara and turn them over to private companies that just by an amazing coincidence, many of the old guard GOP members own stock in. This is just regular government stuff. It's fine, you know? And Carol goes a little bit into the interior fighting between in the GOP that Moses old enemy W. Kingsland Macy was fighting with the
他们想要一个能代表他们对抗新政、对抗拉瓜迪亚市长之流的人。而且他们还想要一个州长，最终能把所有这些公共电力资源（比如尼亚加拉）移交给私营公司，而极其巧合的是，许多老卫队共和党成员都持有这些公司的股份。这只是常规的政府运作，很正常，你知道的吗？卡罗稍微探讨了一下共和党内部的权力斗争，摩西的老敌人W·金斯兰·梅西与老卫队争夺提名人选的内斗。
old guard about who was going to be the nominee. And it makes it sound like there's like eight people who run the city and state government and they're always butting heads. And that's kind of what it's like. Like if you, when you read about even federal politics, it's the same names over and over again. This is a big country. It's amazing. There's so few people. And there's one sentence here that it's not super important, but I just want to read it because it's maybe my favorite sentence in the, in the book, just for how, for how much I have to assume deliberate satire, uh, Caro gets into this one sentence.
这听起来就像管理市和州政府的只有八个人，而且他们总是针锋麦芒。情况差不多就是这样。就像你读到联邦政治时，也是那些名字翻来覆去地出现。这是一个大国。这太神奇了。人竟然这么少。这里有一句话，虽然不是超级重要，但我还是想读一下，因为这可能是我在这本书里最喜欢的句子，仅仅因为我必须猜测卡罗在这句话里包含了多少刻意的讽刺。
So he is relating a quote that Truby Davison as an older man, years later, is telling him about how Kingsland Macy wanted judge Seabury to be the nominee for governor and Seabury to be the nominee for governor and Seabury is not even a Republican and he's a reformer anyway. Well, that was all we had to hear. Truby Davison would growl three decades later, sitting with one gouty leg propped on a footstool in the 30-foot high study of his mansion on Peacock Point, topping off with cherry as jubilee a light lunch served by a white-coated butler and staring out across the Davison
所以他讲述了一段引言：多年后年迈的特鲁比·戴维森在向他讲述金斯兰·梅西如何希望塞伯里法官成为州长候选人，而塞伯里甚至都不是共和党人，而且无论如何他是个改革派。“好吧，我们听到这就够了，”三十年后，特鲁比·戴维森咆哮道。当时他坐在一座位于孔雀岬的三十英尺高书房里，一条患痛风的腿架在脚凳上，白衣管家端来一顿清淡的午餐，最后用樱桃朱比利甜品收尾，他凝视着戴维森大院半英里长的草地克罗凯球场。
compound's half-mile- mile long terrorist croquet court. That's just, it's one sentence just describing his house when Carol, I assume went to talk to him and there's so much succession just crammed into that one sentence. I love it so much. It's just, it's just amazing. And a good way of getting across, these are
这只是一句话，仅仅是在描述他的房子。当时卡罗我猜是去采访他，而那一句话里塞满了如此多的历史传承。我太喜欢了。这简直太棒了。这也是一种很好的方式，让人明白这些人就是
the people who are backing Moses at this point. Yeah. And these are the people where he built his reputation fighting these very same people, and these are the people where he built his reputation fighting these very same people, in fact, the exact same people. The exact same people who he was like, they're the power and I'm for the people.
在这个时候支持摩西的人。是的。而这些人正是他通过与他们作斗争而建立起声誉的同一群人，实际上，就是完全相同的一群人。完全是同一群人，他曾经说过：“他们代表权势，而我代表人民。”
These are the same people who are now like, hey, why don't you be our candidate for governor? Because they've started to realize something about Robert Moses, that when he was hostile to them earlier, it wasn't because he was this like radical liberal, but because he was a man who knew he had power because Al Smith was backing him. And when he lost that backing, he started becoming more accommodating.
这些人现在却说：“嘿，你为什么不当我们的州长候选人呢？”因为他们开始意识到关于罗伯特·摩西的一点：当他早先对他们抱有敌意时，并不是因为他是什么激进的自由派，而是因为他是一个深知自己拥有权力的人，因为有阿尔·史密斯在背后支持他。而当他失去了这种支持，他开始变得更加顺从。
And the old guard realizes this guy also hates Roosevelt. He also thinks the lower classes need to stay in their place and the upper classes need to get special stuff. But, and this is the greatest gift in the history of state politics, you would think he is a reactionary conservative who the voting public believes is a radical liberal. Exactly. He spent all these years building himself up as his liberal force, but in
老卫队意识到，这家伙也讨厌罗斯福。他也认为下层阶级应该安分守己，上层阶级应该获得特权。但是——这是州政治史上最棒的礼物——你会以为他是一个反动保守派，而选民却认为他是一个激进的自由派。没错。他花了这么多年把自己塑造成这种自由派力量，但实际上
reality he's not. And they're like, this is amazing. And Moses accepts the nomination and the press is fully taken in. And they say, this is a surprising turn of events. The liberal enemy of the old guard is now their candidate, huh? It should have worked beautifully. There's only one big problem. I mean, there's two big problems.
他根本不是。他们觉得：这太棒了。于是摩西接受了提名，媒体完全被蒙蔽了。他们说：这是一个令人惊奇的转折。老卫队的自由派敌人现在成了他们的候选人，哈？这本该进展得非常完美。只有一个大问题。我是说，有两个大问题。
It's a New Deal year. You know, the Depression is still going on. But the big problem is that Robert Moses is maybe the worst political campaigner in American history. He's so bad at it. And this is old style campaigning where the campaign is only five weeks long. So you don't have this long buildup where you can outspend your opponent like we have now, thankfully. Thankfully, we've gotten to the point where only rich people can run because you need so much money to do it. I'm so glad we're away from this time when
这是一个新政年。你知道，大萧条仍在继续。但最大的问题是，罗伯特·摩西可能是美国历史上最糟糕的政治竞选人。他太不擅长这个了。这是老式的竞选，竞选期只有短短五个星期。所以你不会像现在这样有很长的蓄力期来砸钱超过对手，谢天谢地。谢天谢地，我们现在已经发展到只有富人才能参选的阶段了，因为你需要巨额资金才能做到这一点。我很高兴我们摆脱了那个时代：
the campaign was only five weeks and then you just made a decision. So, and he spends all those five weeks antagonizing everybody, starting with his own supporters. And Kara talks about how he goes to speak to an audience of young Republicans who are enthusiastic about him. And it somehow turns into a shouting match between Moses and his base, where they're calling each other names.
竞选只有五个星期，然后你就得做出决定。所以，他把这整整五个星期都用来跟所有人对抗，首先就是他自己的支持者。卡罗谈到他如何去对一群对他充满热情的年轻共和党观众发表讲话。而这不知怎么演变成了摩西和他的基本盘之间的一场叫骂战，双方互相辱骂。
And he's running against his boss, Governor Layman. So the people he considers colleagues, they're mostly Democrats, they're loyal to the governor, they will not support him, but he expects their support anyway, and he gets mad when they don't do it. And Kara talks about how Henry Moskowitz, he goes, I'm supporting Governor Layman, and Moses never talks to him again and doesn't even attend his funeral, which is pretty big. The press, they used to love Moses. We know that, right? The press always talking about how great Moses is. He's in the paper more often than Albert Einstein. He's in the paper more often than J. Edgar Hoover. The press, they used to love Moses. We know that, right? The press always talking about how great Moses is.
他在跟自己的老板莱曼州长竞选。所以他认为是同事的那些人，他们大多是民主党人，忠于州长，他们不会支持他，但他无论如何都期望得到他们的支持，而当他们不这么做时，他就勃然大怒。卡罗谈到亨利·莫斯科维茨时说，他说：“我支持莱曼州长，”而摩西再也没有跟他说过话，甚至连他的葬礼都没去，这可以说是相当绝交了。媒体，他们过去很爱摩西。我们都知道，对吧？媒体总是谈论摩西有多伟大。他在报纸上出现的频率比阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦还要高。他在报纸上出现的频率比J·埃德加·胡佛还要高。媒体，他们过去很爱摩西。我们都知道，对吧？媒体总是谈论摩西有多伟大。
He's in the paper more often than Albert Einstein. He's in the paper more often than J. Edgar Hoover. They love him. But literally after the first question in the first press conference he gives as a candidate, the question is whether he is a protege of the old guard. Moses gives them an angry speech about, you're not doing your job right.
他在报纸上出现的频率比阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦还要高。他在报纸上出现的频率比J·埃德加·胡佛还要高。他们爱死他了。但就在他作为候选人举行的第一场新闻发布会上，甚至在第一个问题之后——这个问题是问他是否是老卫队的门生——摩西就对他们发表了一番愤怒的演讲，内容是：你们的工作没有做好。
You need to ask the right questions. You need to say the right things. And it's like a Brewster's Millions type shoot the moon strategy where it's like, oh, if I have no votes, maybe I'll instantly become governor. It's, it's just astounding. Moses, he does everything wrong. He announces to the press, LaGuardia is going to give me his endorsement. I'm calling a press conference, but he didn't bother to check with LaGuardia first and LaGuardia is pissed off and he says out of the campaign, Moses, he won't campaign for ethnic votes, which you have to do in the New York area.
你们需要问正确的问题。你们需要说正确的话。这就像是一种“布鲁斯特的百万横财”式的孤注一掷的策略，好像在说：哦，如果我一票都没有，也许我就会立刻当选州长。这，这简直令人震惊。摩西，他把每件事都做错了。他向媒体宣布：拉瓜迪亚要支持我。我要召开新闻发布会。但他甚至没有先去跟拉瓜迪亚确认，结果拉瓜迪亚气坏了，并公开宣布退出这场竞选。摩西，他不愿意去争取族群选票，这在纽约地区是必须要做的。
One of the great things about New York city, especially is there's people from every part of the world there and they want you to go to their street fairs and eat their local foods. And they, he refuses to do that. He won't even go outside of large cities. His entire public appearance strategy is 12 formal speeches. And, uh, Caro quotes, uh, Paul Wendles, who was the New York city corporation council, which is one of those.
纽约市最伟大的地方之一，特别是那里汇聚了来自世界各地的人们，他们希望你去他们的街头集市，吃他们的特色食物。而他拒绝这样做。他甚至不愿意去大城市以外的地方。他所有的公开露面策略就是12场正式演讲。卡罗引用了保罗·温德尔的话，他是纽约市公司律师，也是那些……
It's a job that I don't know exactly how it fits into the New York city hierarchy, but it's very, it's powerful and influential. He's a lawyer who does stuff for the city. Uh, he says to Caro, every time he opened his mouth, he lost 10,000 votes and votes that should have been his. He should get the Jewish vote. I mean, layman is Jewish also, but Moses, maybe they'll split the Jewish vote. They're both Jewish, but Moses, he says publicly, I'm not Jewish. He hasn't been, but he hasn't been
这是一个我不太清楚它在纽约市层级中具体如何定位的职位，但它非常重要且有影响力。他是一个为市政府办事的律师。他对卡罗说：他每次一张嘴，就失去了10,000张选票，而且这些本该是属于他的选票。他本该赢得犹太选票。我是说，莱曼也是犹太人，但摩西……也许他们会平分犹太选票。他们都是犹太人，但摩西公开宣称：我不是犹太人。他一直没有，但他一直没有
circumcised and Caro has a footnote about the rabbinical aspects of this, whether it, whether those things are necessary to be considered Jewish or not, which is a, which is one of the, which is, which is the most Jewish moment in the book, in this very New York book is, is that, that little footnote. But he refuses to be considered Jewish or called Jewish. And this is at a time when New York Jews find it especially important to reaffirm their being Jewish. This is the 1930s. This is maybe the most dangerous time for Jews in the world in centuries. And so for Moses to be denying that they take that as a personal affront. And so Moses is like the only one route to becoming governor, because I am so unliked and so unlikable, I have to destroy the public image of governor Herbert H. Lehman, who at this
受过割礼。卡罗在脚注中提到了这方面的拉比教义，即这些事情对于被认为是犹太人是否必要，这是这本书中最具犹太特色的一幕，在这本非常纽约的书里，就是那个小小的脚注。但他拒绝被认为是犹太人或被称为犹太人。正值此时，纽约的犹太人发现重新申明自己的犹太身份尤为重要。这是20世纪30年代。这可能是几个世纪以来对犹太人而言最危险的时期。因此，对于摩西的否认，他们认为是对自己个人的侮辱。所以摩西就像是……唯一的当选州长途径，因为我是如此讨人嫌、如此不讨人喜欢，我必须摧毁赫伯特·H·莱曼州长的公众形象。此时的莱曼
point is famous for both being a New Deal liberal and for his impeccable principles. He is famous for his honesty. He's famous for how much he hews to the rules. And Moses launches just attack after attack that are clearly false. Like, Laman is well known as a reformer. And Moses is like, this Tammany puppet, he's stupid, he's weak. He's bowing down to the Tammany bosses because he's afraid they're going to beat him up. Like, literally, he's physically afraid that they're going to beat him up. Like literally he's physically afraid that they're going to beat him up. It's, it is, it's bonkers. And after the campaign, Carol's like, later on, Moses say, layman layman was a distinguished governor, a fine character. Like Moses knows this is not true. And layman does the smart thing, which is he just ignores Moses and he campaigns everywhere and campaigns on his own record. And it's like, this is how we want politics to work to a certain extent, which is that the guy who has a good record and his putting his all into it is doing well. And the guy who is a big liar, who is just mean, is doing poorly.
以既是一位新政自由派又拥有无可挑剔的原则而闻名。他以诚实闻名。他以严守规则闻名。而摩西发起了接连不断的攻击，这些攻击显然都是虚假的。比如，莱曼作为改革家是众所周知的。而摩西却说：这个坦慕尼协会的傀儡，他又蠢又弱。他在向坦慕尼协会的老大们卑躬屈膝，因为他害怕他们会揍他。字面意思，他身体上害怕他们会揍他。字面意思，他身体上害怕他们会揍他。这，这太荒谬了。竞选结束后，卡罗说：后来摩西说，莱曼是一位杰出的州长，品格高尚。就像摩西明知这不是真的。而莱曼则做了明智的事，那就是他根本不理会摩西，到处奔走拉票，并用自己的政绩进行竞选。这就像是，在某种程度上这就是我们希望政治运作的方式，也就是那个政绩良好并全力以赴的人干得不错。而那个满口谎言、刻薄尖酸的人则表现糟糕。
And he makes a lot of these baseless attacks. One example that he gives, this carries one of the examples I want to highlight. He says, he accused layman of being responsible for corruption in the court of claims, an accusation which ignored the fact that the court was not under the governor's control and which was not strengthened by the fact that to document the courts and confidence, Moses accused of drunkenness a judge who actually had been dead for more than a year. So like Moses just throwing out wild things. He accuses layman of being in bed with the utility companies, which is exactly what Moses is doing at this point. And finally, Moses goes a step too far and he calls
他发起了许多这种毫无根据的攻击。他给出的一个例子，卡罗列举的其中一个我想强调的例子。他说，他指责莱曼对索赔法院的腐败负有责任，这一指控忽视了该法院并不受州长控制这一事实，而且为了证明法院缺乏信任度，摩西竟然指控一个实际上已经去世一年多的法官酗酒，这并没有让他的指控显得更有力。所以摩西简直是在胡乱抛出荒唐的言论。他指责莱曼与公用事业公司勾结，而这正是摩西自己当时在做的事。最后，摩西做得太过分了，他称
layman a liar, which shocks people. Yeah. It's hard to overstate how strong Carol makes the reaction to this charge or describes it where that's when he starts losing support. Other Republicans say he's unfit for office and that there's a radio station service that says we will not run Moses speeches unless the party
莱曼是个骗子，这震惊了所有人。是的。很难高估卡罗对这一指控的反应描绘得有多么强烈，正是在那个时候他开始失去支持。其他共和党人说他不适合担任公职，甚至有一个广播电台服务宣布：除非党派购买
takes out libel insurance that covers every time he speaks. And it all, I hate to look at the past with rose-colored glasses because there was a lot of bad stuff going on and the political system was far from fully equitable or good or non-corrupt, but this whole section, it's just so hard to read it now and not be like, well, things have really changed, huh? Yeah.
涵盖他每一次发言的诽谤保险，否则我们绝不转播摩西的演讲。这一切，我讨厌带着玫瑰色的眼镜去看待过去，因为当时有很多糟糕的事情发生，政治体系距离完全公正、良善或非腐败还有很长的距离，但整段内容，现在读起来就是让人不禁感叹：唉，情况真的变了，对吧？是的。
And what's interesting here to me is that even though Moses was a sort of lifelong Republican, except for the time when he changed his party affiliation. Briefly when he thought it would help him become governor. Exactly. Than the earlier time. When Al Smith was running for president. You know, it's interesting
而这里对我而言有趣的是，尽管摩西可以说是终身共和党人，除了他更改党派 affiliation 的那次……短暂的那次，当他以为这能帮他当选州长的时候。没错。比那更早的一次。当阿尔·史密斯竞选总统的时候。你知道，这很有趣，
because he has surrounded himself with Democrats. He's always worked with Democrats up to this point. In fact, his mentor and big brother in all this is Al Smith. It's only recently in LaGuardia that he has worked with a Republican pretty much at all. And everyone turns their back on him. I mean, they don't try to be mean about it,
因为他身边总是环绕着民主党人。到目前为止，他一直与民主党人合作。事实上，他在这一切当中的导师和老大哥是阿尔·史密斯。直到最近在拉瓜迪亚那里，他才几乎第一次与共和党人合作。而每个人都背弃了他。我是说，他们并没有刻意表现得刻薄，
but they're just like, listen, I, you know, I'm a Democrat. Yeah. Even when he goes to Al Smith, he goes to Al Smith, he will ask for support and Al Smith says, I play this game like a regular. Yeah. And Moses is stung by it.
但他们只是说：听着，我，你知道的，我是个民主党人。是的。甚至当他去找阿尔·史密斯时，他去找阿尔·史密斯寻求支持，而阿尔·史密斯却说：我像个党员规矩人一样玩这场游戏。是的。而摩西对此感到刺痛。
And, and Carol describes how someone tells him about Moses recalling this 30 years later, and it's still clearly hurting him. But you're right. He's surrounded by, he's always called himself an independent Republican, but he has been a fixture in democratic administrations and working with democratic officials.
卡罗描述了有人向他讲述摩西在30年后回忆起这件事，并且显然至今仍让他感到隐隐作痛。但你是对的。他身边环绕着……他一直自称是独立共和党人，但他一直是民主党政府中的常客，并与民主党官员共事。
And it is foolish of him, this guy who understands the political mechanism so well, to expect that they like him so much personally, that they will turn their back on this party and also to be honest, in this case, principles that they've stood by for all this time. Yeah. And I wonder if this, I hadn't thought about this
这个对政治运作机制如此精通的家伙，竟然指望这些人对他的个人好感会深到让他们背叛自己的党派，说实话，在这个案例中，还要背叛他们一直以来坚守的原则，这实在是太愚蠢了。是的。我在想，之前我还没想过这一点，
until just now, Roman, you've led me to this realization that one of the themes throughout the first parts of the book is Robert Moses finding sources of power that other people had discounted earlier and not noticed because they were outside of Moses finding sources of power that other people had discounted earlier and not noticed because they were outside of the official source of power. And I wonder if here is one of those cases where he makes that gamble. He says the Democratic party is more powerful in this region than the Republican party. I'm going to be able to go in there and turn that into my source of power then. And that gamble doesn't pay off this time. He's not able to do it. Yeah. I don't know.
直到刚刚，罗曼，你还让我意识到，这本书前半部分的主题之一，就是罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）寻找那些被其他人早先忽视、没有注意到的权力来源，因为它们位于官方权力来源之外。我想，在这里，他也做了这样一场豪赌。他说，民主党在这个地区比共和党更有力量。那么，我将能够进入那里，把它变成我的权力之源。而这一次，这场赌博并没有得到回报。他没能做到这一点。是的，我不知道。
I also think that he, like you said, that is his superpower is like turning sort of ignored and positions that are not thought of as very powerful into powerful positions. Whereas running for governor is like good old fashioned normal stuff. Like he's not gonna reinvent anything here. He's not going to find some law that he can write
我也认为，就像你说的，他的超级能力就是把那些被忽视的、不被认为很有权力的职位变成权力职位。然而，竞选州长就像是老式的常规事情。他在这里不会重塑任何东西，他不会去写什么法律
to make this better for him or easier for him. He has to do all the things. This stuff has been worked out, you know? He's not gonna get around it. And his unwillingness to play ball in the way that everyone else does to create a successful campaign is just, you know, he's just naive.
来为自己争取利益或让自己更轻松。他必须把所有事情都做好。这些事情都已经安排好了，你知道吗？他是绕不开的。他不愿意像其他人那样为了建立一个成功的竞选活动而做出妥协，你知道的，他只是太天真了。
Like he's never walked a path that other people have walked ahead of him. He's only sort of forged his own way through all these like new ways of looking at the government and the world and municipal structures. And this tried and true way, he's just bad at it. There's something about, and maybe it's one of the, one of the, maybe it's from the beautiful things
就像他从未走过别人走过的路一样。他只是在所有这些看待政府、世界和市政结构的新方法中开辟了自己的道路。而这种久经考验的方法，他偏偏很不擅长。这其中有些原因，也许这是那些美好事物之一
about electoral politics is that it can really humble people who are used to not being humble because suddenly they need the people who they don't care about to give them their approval. They need the approval of the people that previously they saw as beneath them. And I mean, that's, it goes back to the, in some ways, to the original founding of the country where it was like, you know, this king's used to telling us what to do.
关于选举政治的一点是，它真的可以让那些习惯了不谦逊的人变得谦逊，因为突然之间他们需要那些他们根本不在乎的人来给予他们认可。他们需要那些以前被他们视为低人一等的人的批准。我的意思是，这在某种程度上可以追溯到这个国家的最初建立，当时就像是，你知道的，这个国王习惯了告诉我们该做什么。
Well, what if we chose the king and he had to pay attention to us once every four years? You know, it's a real guardrail of docracy that Moses is coming up against. Moses to his credit, he does not hold a grudge against Al Smith. This is before Moses opens the Central Park Zoo, which is basically his love present to Al Smith. So that's the one relationship that he'll never let go of. It's pretty interesting that this is happening simultaneously
那么，如果我们选择国王，而他每四年必须注意我们一次呢？你知道的，这是摩西正在遭遇的民主护栏。值得赞扬的是，摩西并没有对阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）记恨。这是在摩西开设中央公园动物园之前，这基本上是他对阿尔·史密斯的爱的礼物。所以那是他永远不会放手的一段关系。非常有趣的是，这与以下事件同时发生
to that chapter that we read earlier about that ceremony and giving him the key and all that sort of stuff that meant so much to Al Smith. It does, however, make me think that him missing that ceremony and giving him the key and all that sort of stuff that meant so much to Al Smith. It does, however, make me think that him missing that ceremony, there might be something a little bit more to that, because he wasn't there for that. And he says it's because he's sick.
我们之前读到的关于那个仪式以及将钥匙交给他之类对阿尔·史密斯意义重大事情的那一章。然而，这确实让我觉得他错过那个仪式以及将钥匙交给他之类对阿尔·史密斯意义重大事情的事，可能背后还有更多隐情，因为他当时不在场。他说这是因为他生病了。
Yeah, maybe it was, maybe he couldn't handle it, or maybe he just wasn't ready, or it's possible. I do wonder that. But as you said, these guardrails of democracy, well, like, so, like, Robert Moses just goes head first into a guardrail of democracy, and he just, he ends up with the smallest percentage of the vote of any major party candidate in the history of New York State up until that point. Up until that point. Since then, some enterprising candidates have beaten that record and gotten less,
是的，也许确实如此，也许他无法应付，或者他只是还没准备好，或者有这种可能。我确实很好奇。但正如你所说，这些民主的护栏，就像是，罗伯特·摩西一头撞上了民主的护栏，他最终得到了纽约州历史上所有主要政党候选人中最低的得票率。直到那个时候。自那以后，一些有进取心的候选人打破了纪录，得票更少，
but yeah, Moses, he ends up with 35% of the vote, which in a two-party competition is pretty abysmal. And the GOP, they lose both houses of the legislature for the first time in 21 years. He even loses in the, usually the solidly Republican upstate districts, those go for layman. And Moses of course takes no responsibility. He's like, it was 1934.
但是，是的，摩西最终得到了35%的选票，在两党竞争中，这可以说是相当糟糕的。而且共和党在21年来首次失去了议会的两院。他甚至在通常坚决支持共和党的北部地区也输了，那些地区都投给了雷曼（Lehman）。而摩西当然不承担任何责任。他说，那是1934年。
The new deal candidate was always going to win. I couldn't do it. But the political insiders are like, yeah, but election could have been closer. And it's interesting that either Moses doesn't care or forgets or doesn't think about it, that when you have an election year, the person at the head of the ticket, part of their job is to draw support for the people lower down on the ticket. So even if he had run better, even if he had lost,
新政候选人本来就会赢。我无能为力。但政治内幕人士却说，是的，但选举本可以更势均力敌。有趣的是，摩西要么不在乎，要么忘记了，要么根本没去想，当迎来选举年时，排在候选名单首位的人，他的职责之一就是为名单靠后的人拉取支持。所以即使他表现得更好，即使他输了，
perhaps his party would have kept control of part of the legislature or just wouldn't have lost so many seats. But Moses also, I'm sure doesn't care. Like he doesn't care about how the rest of the party is. I mean, he doesn't care about the party. It's not like from this point on, he's really involved in GOP politics. Like, as soon as he loses, he drops them, you know?
也许他的政党还能保住部分议会的控制权，或者至少不会失去那么多席位。但摩西也肯定不在乎。就像他不在乎政党其余部分的死活一样。我的意思是，他根本不在乎这个政党。从这一刻起，他并不是真的卷入了共和党政治。就像，他一输掉就甩了他们，你知道吗？
Yeah, and this is a moment where, you know, Lehman, to his credit, you know, like, it would be, I think, politically reasonable to get rid of Moses at this moment, because, you know, he just was, you know, in a competition for the same job and called him a liar and all these nasty things. Offended most of the state.
是的，这是一个时刻，你知道的，值得赞扬的是，雷曼，你知道的，我想在政治上在这个时候摆脱摩西是合理的，因为，你知道的，他刚刚在争夺同一个职位，还叫他骗子以及所有这些讨厌的事情。冒犯了全州大多数人。
Just made most of the state not like him. But to his credit, Leeman doesn't do it. He keeps him on. Yeah, he says, this guy's great at his job, he's doing work nobody else can do, just because he called me a liar doesn't mean I should fire him It is one of those moments where someone does the principled thing and does ostensibly the right thing
只是让全州大部分人都不喜欢他。但值得赞扬的是，雷曼并没有这样做。他留下了他。是的，他说，这家伙工作很棒，他在做别人做不到的工作，仅仅因为他叫我骗子并不意味着我应该解雇他。这正是那种有人做了符合原则的事情、表面上做了正确事情的时刻
But in the long run you're like, oh man, you know Like this would have missed opportunity I know this would have been the moment the silver lining is that if he had fired Moses then there's no way Robert Carow ever would have written this a wonderful book that we're enjoying so much because the story of the man who was briefly the most powerful person in New York as Parks Commissioner is not as, let's say, not as much of a book as the guy who did it for years and years. And Carroll goes into, he does a little bit of analysis here where he's saying, why did
但从长远来看，你会觉得，哦，天哪，你知道的，这会是一个错失的机会。我知道这本会是个一线生机，那就是如果他当年解雇了摩西，罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）绝不可能写出这本我们如此喜爱的精彩书籍，因为那个作为公园专员曾短暂成为纽约权力最大的人的故事，比起那个干了多年的人的故事来说，不够那么丰满。卡罗在这里做了一些分析，他说，为什么
Moses do such a bad job with this? Like this guy who is usually so good at using the press, who is so good at presenting himself and at positioning himself on the right side of issues. And what Caro says is his theory is that part of it is because Moses was kind of lucky to always have a popular issue before now. He was tied to park building.
摩西把这事办得这么糟？这个平时擅长利用媒体、擅长展示自己并把自己放在问题正确立场上的人。而卡罗说，他的理论是，部分原因在于摩西之前总是很幸运，总能遇到一个受欢迎的议题。他与公园建设捆绑在一起。
People didn't have to like him as a person. They just had to like the fact that he was for parks. But in a political campaign, he can't say, I'm the parks guy, parks, I mean, he could have. If he was a better campaigner, he could have said, I'm the Parks guy. But his actual character had to come out and people did not like it. And Caro says, why couldn't he charm the voters the way he charmed the powerful people who support he needed, the people in the GOP party or as we'll see later in newspapers. And Caro theorizes that most, this is where he gets a little psychoanalytical in a way
人们不必喜欢他这个人。他们只需要喜欢他支持公园建设这一事实。但在政治竞选中，他不能说，我是公园先生，公园，我的意思是，他本可以。如果他是一个更好的竞选人，他本可以宣称自己是公园先生。但他真正的性格不得不暴露出来，而人们并不喜欢。卡罗说，为什么他不能像讨好那些他需要其支持的权贵那样去迷倒选民呢？比如共和党内的人，或者正如我们稍后在报纸上所看到的那些人。卡罗推测，摩西——这就是他变得有点心理分析的地方
that I'm not, I'm not sure I fully buy into, but he says that Moses is so arrogant and so entitled that he literally is incapable of pretending to care about what other people think and that he actually derives pleasure from being able to express the contempt that he holds other people in. And so he needs to display his superiority
我不太确定我是否完全赞同，但他说摩西太傲慢、太自以为是，以至于他字面上就无法假装关心别人的想法，而且他实际上从能够表达自己对别人的轻蔑中获得快乐。因此，他需要展示自己的优越感
and he needs to destroy anyone who opposes him. And that's Caro's like, I can't think of another reason why Moses went antagonize the press. He was so good at manipulating, but now he felt like he needed to show he was better and smarter and he can't just defeat his enemies. He has to destroy them. And what do you think? I'm not sure if it's that or if it's that just Moses is just really good at fawning over people who he feels he needs something from. And as much as he knows he needs the voters, he thinks of them as a mass. And he thinks of individual voters as nobodies. And he doesn't feel the need to fawn over them because individually they're powerless.
他需要摧毁任何反对他的人。这就是卡罗的观点，我想不出摩西去激怒媒体的另一个原因。他那么擅长操纵，但现在他觉得他需要证明自己更好、更聪明，他不能只是击败他的敌人。他必须摧毁他们。你觉得呢？我不确定是这样，还是因为摩西非常擅长拍那些他觉得需要从中得到东西的人的马屁。尽管他知道自己需要选民，但他把他们视为一个整体。他把个别选民视为无名小卒。他觉得没必要拍他们的马屁，因为个别来看他们是无权无势的。
That's my theory. What do you think? I mean, I think it could be both of those things. I think that he— Got to pick one. Got to pick one, Roman. All right. I'll let you forge the middle path.
这就是我的理论。你觉得呢？我的意思是，我觉得这两点都有可能。我觉得他——必须选一个。必须选一个，罗曼。好吧。我让你来走中间道路。
That's fine. Yeah. Okay, all right, I'll let you forge the middle path. That's fine, yeah. Well, I think it's also just that, you know, Robert Moses is really great at creating the conditions where he is doing everything for the first time, all of his whip sawing and his sort of lying and then, you know, steak driving and all this stuff. It just is about, he is the best because there's no one, there's no precedent for him, you know,
没关系。好吧，好的，我让你走中间道路。没关系，是的。嗯，我认为这也是因为，你知道的，罗伯特·摩西非常擅长创造这样的条件：他所做的一切都是第一次，他所有的两面三刀、各种谎言，然后，你知道的，强力推进以及所有这些事情。这只是关于，他是最棒的，因为没有人，没有先例可循，你知道的，
like, and this just is not an unprecedented job to be a politician in this way. And he is finding that he cannot, like, bend his character to do any of these things. Like, it just is anathema to his existence. And he's never had to because he's always done things his own way. And this is just like, I just think he's incapable of it. And when you're in the confidence of someone and they say something mean, you feel very
就像，以这种方式成为一名政治家并非前无古人。而他发现自己无法像这样扭曲自己的性格来做这些事情。就像，这简直违背了他的存在。而且他从来不需要这样做，因为他总是按自己的方式做事。这简直是，我只是觉得他做不到。当你赢得某人的信任，而他们说了一些刻薄的话，你有时会感到非常
warm to them sometimes because you're like, oh, they're being mean to that person and they like me, you know, like, I think he You know, like, I think he plays on that in a small room or with just a group of people, small group of people that he shares, you know, kinship with, but the bigger and bigger that room is, then you're just like shouting at people and it is not fun at all, you know, to watch someone just be mean to someone
对他们感到温暖，因为你会想，哦，他们对那个人很刻薄，但他们喜欢我，你知道的，就像，我认为他，你知道的，我觉得他利用了这一点，在一个小房间里，或者只是一群人中，与他分享亲密感的小群人中，但是房间越来越大，然后你只是在大喊大叫，看着某人对别人刻薄，一点意思也没有，你知道的，
in a large room. And I think that he, I think he just sort of traffics in a kind of gossip and chumminess and you know, like, and being nice to you and mean to you in like unpredictable ways so that his sort of abuses and control over you is strengthened by that. And you just can't do that in a broad scale to people, like to a mass of people.
在一个大房间里。而且我认为他，我觉得他只是在某种八卦和亲热中运作，你知道的，对你友好，对你刻薄，用不可预测的方式，这样他虐待和控制你的权力就得到了加强。而你无法在广泛的范围内对人们这样做，就像对广大民众那样。
I guess it goes to show too that like, there's certain types of people whose personalities react to other personalities. And Moses, for some reason in public and on a large scale had the kind of personality that nobody reacted well to, that it just didn't mesh with anybody. Not at all. Like except for when he could put up a ceremony,
我想这也表明，某些类型的人，他们的性格对其他性格会做出反应。不知为什么，摩西在公开场合和大规模上表现出的那种性格，没有人能做出好的反应，它与任何人都合不来。根本合不来。就像除了他能举办一个仪式时除外，
like somewhat, but that's it. Like, he kind of knew the details of how to make people have a good time when he was opening something or doing something grand. But when he spoke, it was, you know, pretty uninspiring. You know, like, it's really fascinating. That's not what his strength was. And so at this point, you know, he's kind of at his lowest that we've seen him since, you know, his initial ascendancy. This is the lowest he's been since he was a 30 year old guy who could not get a job in government.
某种程度上可以，但仅此而已。就像，他当他开幕或者做什么宏大事情时，他确实知道如何让大家度过一段美好时光的细节。但当他开口说话时，你知道的，相当缺乏灵感。你知道的，这真的很迷人。这不是他的强项。所以在这一点上，你知道的，他处于我们见过的他自最初崛起以来的最低谷。这是他自30岁无法在政府找到工作以来最低谷的时期。
He is now, he has, I mean, he has two amazing jobs, but he actually has like 11 amazing jobs, but he is, but people don't like him. The shine is off the star, the bloom is off the rose, you know, the halo's hanging by a thread. I don't know how many different messed up metaphors. Unfortunately for us, unfortunately for him, a strange savior is about to enter the scene as we roll into chapter 22 as Moses' oldest foe is about to become his inadvertent support beam. I couldn't come up with the right metaphor for that either. We'll do that one with chapter 22, order number one 29 after this break.
他现在，他有，我的意思是，他有两份令人惊叹的工作，但实际上他有大约11份令人惊叹的工作，但人们不喜欢他。光环褪色了，玫瑰失去了芬芳，你知道的，头顶的光环摇摇欲坠。我都不知道有多少种混乱的比喻了。不幸的是对我们来说，对他也一样，一个奇怪的救世主即将登场，当我们进入第22章时，摩西的老对头即将成为他的无意之中的支撑梁。我连这都找不到合适的比喻了。我们将在休息后处理第22章，序号129。
This next chapter is chapter 22. It's called order Number 129. And this is when Robert Moses is at his lowest. His old foe, Franklin Roosevelt, who's now the President of the United States, he decides that he's going to take his revenge on him. And this is such a misfire. It's so colossal of a mistake. It's a Moses running for governor level of misfire from the president of the United States. And it has the exact opposite effect of what
这下一章是第22章。它叫序号129。这就是罗伯特·摩西处于最低谷的时候。他的老对头富兰克林·罗斯福，现在已经是美国总统，他决定要报复他。这真是一个严重的失误。这是一个如此巨大的错误。这是一个来自美国总统的“摩西竞选州长”级别的失误。并且它产生了与总统
the president is hoping. Technically, this revenge happens, it starts before the gubernatorial campaign. In February of 1934, we have this scene where Kara scribes where LaGuardia is crying to Paul Wendell's New York City Corporation counsel. Again, don't know what the job is, but he's around a lot in this book. He realizes that the guy he picked as his federal money guy, the city's interface between its needs and the federal government's largesse is Robert Moses, the one guy the president hates most in the world and other than Hitler, I guess. And so there's a quote that I love here. I'm gonna try it. I wanna do it in an accent, but I know I can't do justice, where Wendell says to Taro,
所希望的完全相反的效果。严格来说，这次报复发生在州长竞选开始之前。在1934年2月，我们有这样一个场景，卡罗描述了拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）向保罗·温德尔（Paul Wendell）的纽约市公司法律顾问哭诉。同样，不知道具体是什么工作，但他在这本书里经常出现。他意识到他选的联邦资金先生、城市需求与联邦政府慷慨解囊之间的接口正是罗伯特·摩西，这个总统在世界上最讨厌的人，除了希特勒吧。所以这里有一句我很喜欢的话。我想试试。我想带点口音说，但我知道我无法做到原汁原味，温德尔对卡罗说，
I got in the car and no sooner did I sit down than he cut loose. Jesus Christ, of all the people in the city of New York, I had to pick the one man who Roosevelt won't stand for. And he won't give me any more money unless I get rid of him. Jesus Christ, I had to pick the one that he hated. Jesus Christ.
我一上车，刚坐下他就爆发了。耶稣基督，在纽约市的所有人中，我偏偏选了罗斯福绝不容忍的那个人。如果我不甩掉他，他就不会再给我一分钱。耶稣基督，我偏偏选了他最恨的那一个。耶稣基督。
He was shaking his fist in the air and shouting, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ. Seven million people in the city and I had to pick the one that he hated. Jesus Christ. He was shaking his fist in the air and shouting Jesus Christ Jesus Christ seven million people in the city and I had to pick the one Roosevelt can't stand and I just I love that it's so amazing my favorite movie of all time is the taking of Palom 1 2 3 and LaGuardia sounds like the mayor in that movie at that moment. It's just like oh What it like just over overcome with with his with his troubles? And so this is the case interior Interior Secretary Harold Ickes has made it clear to LaGuardia that until Moses is fired from the Triborough Authority Board, the Public Works Administration, which Harold Ickes oversees in the Interior Secretariat ship, in the Department
他挥舞着拳头大喊：“上帝啊，上帝啊！城里有七百万人口，我偏偏挑中了他最讨厌的那一个。上帝啊。”他挥舞着拳头大喊上帝啊上帝啊城里有七百万人口我偏偏挑中了一个罗斯福最容不下的人，我就是——我太喜欢这个了，这太棒了，我此生最喜欢的电影就是《地铁惊魂》（The Taking of Pelham One Two Three），而拉瓜迪亚在那一刻听起来就像那部电影里的市长。就好像，哦！什么情况？就好像被、被他的麻烦压得喘不过气来？所以情况就是这样，内政部长哈罗德·伊克斯已经向拉瓜迪亚明确表示，除非摩西被开除出三区大桥管理局董事会，否则公共工程管理局——由伊克斯在内政秘书处、在部门内政部中监督的机构
of the Interior, it will give no money to New York City. No money until Moses is fired. And LaGuardia is like, I can't legally fire Moses from Triborough. I can't legally do it. But maybe I can get him to resign by threatening to fire him as the parks commissioner, which I can do. And Moses, of course, he knows there's only one tool that gets what you want, which is a bigger resignation threat. So he goes, yeah, I'll resign from Triborough. I'll also resign from the park jobs. And then I'll tell everyone publicly that you made me resign because the federal government
将不会给纽约市一分钱。一分钱都不给，直到摩西被开除。而拉瓜迪亚的反应是：“我从法律上无法将摩西从三区大桥管理局开除。我在法律上做不到这一点。”但也许我可以通过威胁要解雇他的公园专员职务来迫使他辞职，这个权力我确实有。而摩西当然知道，只有一个工具能让你得到想要的东西，那就是进行更大规模的辞职威胁。所以他说：“行啊，我会辞去三区大桥管理局的职务。我连公园的职位也一块辞了。然后我会公开告诉所有人，是你逼我辞职的，因为联邦政府
told you to. And Wendell tells LaGuardia, if that happens, everyone will see you as weak. If publicly you're seen as bowing to federal pressure and LaGuardia tries to stall and Roosevelt's losing his patience. And as soon as the governor's race is over, Roosevelt is like, nobody likes this guy anymore. Let's do it. And they turn off the PWA money faucet until the day when Moses is cut loose. And Caro, it's worth looking up on page 429, Caro goes through this ridiculously melodramatic description of the whole thing as a stage play and which parts everyone's playing and it is this metaphor that goes way too far, but it's so, I love it. It goes
命令你这么做的。”温德尔告诉拉瓜迪亚：“如果发生这种事，所有人都会觉得你很软弱。如果公众看到你在向联邦压力低头……”拉瓜迪亚试图拖延，而罗斯福正在失去耐心。州长竞选一结束，罗斯福就表态了：“已经没人喜欢这家伙了。咱们动手吧。”于是他们切断了PWA（公共工程管理局）的资金水龙头，直到摩西被彻底抛弃的那一天。卡罗——这很值得在第429页翻阅一下——卡罗对整件事进行了极其夸张的戏剧化描述，把它比作一出舞台剧，每个人都在扮演着各自的角色。这个隐喻有点用得太过了，但它太——我太喜欢了。它用得
beautifully too far. So it's too long to read here, but go open up your hymnals to page 429 and take a look at it. And the Guardia is in a bind. He needs this money to improve the city. He has big plans for the city. He wants to do the things that Moses is trying to get done, but he can't be seen as giving into Roosevelt. And then on December 26th, 1934, a date which will live on in bureaucracy, Ichius issues PWA administrative order number 129, the very order that gives this chapter its title, drafted in Par drafted in Parker Roosevelt stating the PWA will give no money to an independent entity that has a project entirely in one city. If the governing board of that entity
妙得过头了。所以在这里读它的篇幅太长了，但大家去翻开你们的圣歌集第429页看一看吧。拉瓜迪亚陷入了两难的境地。他需要这笔资金来改善城市。他对城市有着宏伟的规划。他想做那些摩西正试图去完成的事情，但他又不能被视为向罗斯福屈服。然后，在1934年12月26日——一个注定要在官僚主义历史上留名的日子——伊克斯颁布了PWA行政命令第129号，正是这个命令让本章有了这个标题。草拟于帕——草拟于帕克和罗斯福之手，声明PWA不会向一个独立实体提供资金，如果该实体有一个项目完全位于某个城市，并且该实体的管理委员会
has anyone on it who also holds public office in that city. And it's so specifically worded. It's so clearly describing most of the situation, but it happens to affect another guy too, Tenement House Commissioner Langdon W. Post. And Nicky's is like, confidentially don't worry about him. It doesn't matter. We don't care about him. And Post is on a,
中任何人同时在该城市担任公职。这个措辞太具体了。它太清楚地在描述大部分情况了，但碰巧也波及了另一个人——贫民窟房屋专员兰登·W·波斯特（Langdon W. Post）。而伊克斯的态度是：“私下里说，不用管他。这没关系。我们不在乎他。”而波斯特当时正在
he's actually on a cruise at that moment. So he doesn't even know any of this is happening. They should have written in that, you know, like in addition to give no money to an independent entity that has a project entirely in one city, if that governing board has an entity as anyone who hold public office in that city and your name rhymes with Paubert Poses, you know? LaGuardia's like, my hands are tied.
乘邮轮度假。所以他甚至根本不知道这一切正在发生。他们本该在里面写上，你知道的，比如“除了不向一个独立实体提供资金，如果该实体有一个项目完全位于某个城市，且其管理委员会中任何人都在该城市担任公职，并且你的名字押韵于‘帕伯特·波西斯’（Paubert Poses），你知道的？”拉瓜迪亚的反应是：“我的手被绑住了。
Sorry. You and Sharbert shows this have to leave the government. I apologize. And LaGuardia does a foolish thing here, which is in order to show Moses he has to give and he shows the order to Moses. And Moses like, huh, interesting, interesting. Press, can I leak something to you? And he goes, I'm revealing this purely
很抱歉。你和夏伯特·肖西斯（Sharbert shows this）必须离开政府。我深表歉意。”而拉瓜迪亚在这里做了一件蠢事，为了向摩西证明他必须妥协，他把这份命令拿给摩西看了。摩西的反应是：“哦？有趣，真有趣。记者们，我能向你们泄露点东西吗？”他说：“我揭露这一点纯粹是因为
because the public deserves transparency. And the press are unaware that Roosevelt and Moses have hated each other for years. This feud is common knowledge among the political types, but it's not public knowledge. And so the press portrays it as the president is trying to force a public servant out of his job, purely because while he was running for governor, he criticized the New Deal.
公众理应享有知情权。”而记者们并不知道罗斯福和摩西多年来一直互相仇恨。这种不和在政治圈子里是公开的秘密，但并非公众所知。因此，记者们将这件事描述为：总统正试图迫使一位公共公仆丢掉工作，纯粹是因为他在竞选州长期间批评了新政。
This is political partisan payback of the worst type. And suddenly, Ickes is being asked about whether Roosevelt knew about the order, and LaGuardia is on a train to DC and doesn't know that Moses leaked it. And as soon as he gets off the train, he's mobbed by reporters. And I really love, there's something about how old world this all is where if you are traveling, you do not know what is happening outside of the container that you are in.
这是最恶劣的党派政治报复。转眼间，伊克斯开始被追问罗斯福是否知道这项命令，而拉瓜迪亚正坐着火车去华盛顿，还不知道摩西已经泄露了消息。他刚一下火车，就遭到了一群记者的围堵。我真的很喜欢——这一切有一种“旧时代”的感觉，那就是如果你在旅行中，你根本不知道你身处的那个容器之外正在发生什么。
So if you're on a cruise ship, you don't know. If you're on a train, you don't know. Whereas now, you know, the scene would be like his aides, Blackberry suddenly buzzes, not Blackberry, his cell phone, they don't use Blackberry anymore, but his cell phone suddenly buzzes and he go, uh, sir, we'll have to take a look at this. And then by the time they are getting off the train, he's got a statement prepared. Instead, he is just totally taken by surprise. He has no idea what's been happening
所以如果你在一艘游轮上，你不会知道。如果你在一辆火车上，你也不会知道。而现在，你知道的，当时的场景会是这样的：他的助理的黑莓手机突然震动起来——不是黑莓，是他的手机，他们现在不用黑莓了，但他的手机突然震动了，他会说：“呃，先生，我们得看看这个。”然后等他们下火车时，他已经准备好了一份声明。然而相反的是，他完全被打了个措手不及。他根本不知道发生了什么
because he's on a train. I love that. And I like the image of a flustered LaGuardia is like an image I kind of love conjuring in my mind, because you can totally imagine, it's just his sweaty face, you know, just like. He already looks like he just rolled out of bed. So even more now, he's like,
因为他在火车上。我太喜欢这个了。而且我挺喜欢那种手忙脚乱的拉瓜迪亚的形象，这是我在脑海中很喜欢勾勒的一种画面，因为你完全可以想象，就是他那张冒汗的脸，你知道的，就那种。他看起来本来就刚从床上爬起来。所以现在更是如此，他就像是
I have to imagine him as a guy who runs his fingers through his hair a lot when he's like stressed out and thinking and makes it all poof out and, yeah, I love it. And he's just like, what the fuck has this guy done to me now? Yeah. Oh, Jesus Christ, Jesus Christ.
我得把他想象成那种在压力大、思考时会不停用手指抓头发的人，把头发抓得蓬蓬的，对，我太喜欢了。他当时的反应就像是：这王八蛋现在到底对我干了什么啊？哈。哦，上帝啊，上帝啊。
You know, like, you have to imagine every press report, because back then they would kind of clean up a politician's answers to make them look better. That every press report, they're just blacking out the words Jesus Christ in the transcript, you know. But editorials are written about this. They're attacking LaGuardia. They're attacking Ickes. Suddenly, dozens of business and civic organizations are issuing resolutions in support of Moses. He's a hero again. Suddenly he's a hero. And there's this long list of different organizations,
你知道的，你得想象每一篇新闻报道——因为当时他们会稍微美化一下政治人物的回答，让他们看起来好一些——每一篇新闻报道，他们都在文字记录里把“上帝啊”这几个字给涂黑了，你知道的。但社论却纷纷出炉。他们在攻击拉瓜迪亚。他们在攻击伊克斯。突然间，几十个商业和市民组织纷纷发表决议支持摩西。他又成了英雄。转眼间他又成了英雄。随后是一长串不同的组织，
different local civic and business groups that are going out of their way to issue public resolutions in support of Moses. And everyone's trying to stonewall, LaGuardia's like, this problem doesn't exist, but Moses keeps the fight in the press. Every week he's announcing how little money they have left on hand to complete building the Triborough Bridge because the federal government's not giving them any. And Roosevelt
各种地方市民和商业团体，他们大老远地跑来发表公开决议支持摩西。每个人都在试图采取拖延战术，拉瓜迪亚的态度是“这个问题不存在”，但摩西一直在媒体上挑起战事。他每周都在通报他们手里还剩多少资金来完成三区大桥的建设，因为联邦政府根本不给他们钱。而罗斯福
finally admits to reporters that he was aware of Order 129 and then 147 different civic organizations then meet and they basically make a show of re-accepting Moses as a member of the civic reform community because they want to support the principle of independent local government. This principle of balance of powers and local control of things that is so fundamental to the founding blah blah blah and etc etc and Moses is now the symbol of that and by 1935 it's a national issue and people are like the New Deal funds are being used for political purposes this is not okay and Republicans want And the process is now the symbol of that. And by 1935, it's a national issue, and people are like, the New Deal funds are being used for political purposes.
终于向记者承认他知道129号命令，随后47个不同的市民组织开会，他们基本上做出了一个姿态，重新接纳摩西为市民改革社区的一员，因为他们想要支持独立地方政府的原则。这种三权分立和地方自治的原则是建国之本，等等等等，而摩西现在成了这一原则的象征，到了1935年，这已经成了一个全国性的议题，人们纷纷表示：新政资金正被用于政治目的，这绝对不行。共和党人想要……而摩西现在成了这一原则的象征。到1935年，这已经成了一个全国性的议题，人们纷纷表示：新政资金正被用于政治目的。
This is not okay. And Republicans want to investigate it. LaGuardia finally comes with a solution. It's, you know, months later, as after he has been going, oh, Jesus Christ, you know, to anybody who'll listen. He sends a letter to the government saying, I will abide by the order,
这绝对不行。共和党人想要对此进行调查。拉瓜迪亚终于拿出了一个解决方案。那是——你知道的，几个月后，在他对任何愿意听的人抱怨过“哦，上帝啊”之后。他给政府写了一封信，表示：我会遵守这项命令，
but it would cause so much trouble to apply it retroactively because I cannot lose Langdon Post from the tenement housing position. I can't do it. He's just too important. You know, this guy who was on vacation when all this was going down. He's just, I'm sorry, it's too much to ask. Oh, and PS, this would also apply to Robert Moses in addition, but Langdon Post is really why I'm doing this. And Al Smith, who's been kind of biding his time waiting for the right moment to step in, this is when he does step in. He says, now's the time to put my finger on the scale. And he gives a speech talking about how necessary it is that Moses stay at the Triborough authority so his big Rhodes plan can go through. And that's presented by Caro as the final kind of feather on the scale. That's the straw that breaks the camel's
但如果要溯及既往，会带来太多麻烦，因为我不能失去兰登·波斯特的贫民窟房屋管理职位。我做不到。他太重要了。你知道的，就是那个在这一切发生时正在度假的家伙。他只是——我很抱歉，这要求实在太高了。哦，顺便说一句，这当然也适用于罗伯特·摩西，但兰登·波斯特才是我这么做的真正原因。而阿尔·史密斯（Al Smith）——他一直在养精蓄锐，等待合适的时机介入——这正是他介入的时刻。他说：“现在是把我的手按向天平的时候了。”他发表了一篇演讲，谈到摩西留在三区大桥管理局是多么必要，这样他宏大的道路规划才能得以推进。卡罗将此描述为压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草——
back. I'm trying to get more metaphors into this. And so Roosevelt, he has Ickes write a letter to LaGuardia accepting this non-retroactive reading, but they predate the letter to one day before Smith's speech so that it won't look like it was because of the speech that they did it. And the press immediately sees through it and they're like, Moses beats Ickes. They did it. And Ickes, who at this point has just been doing what the president has been telling him to do. He doesn't have a personal stake in this. He's very hurt by it, but he still kind of gives props to Moses for handling the fight in such a powerful way. And the most important thing of all is with this action,
天平上的最后一块筹码。我正努力在这个播客里加入更多隐喻。于是罗斯福让伊克斯写信给拉瓜迪亚，接受了这种不溯及既往的解释，但他们把这封信的日期提前到了史密斯演讲的前一天，这样看起来就不会是因为那场演讲才这么做的。媒体立刻看穿了这一点，他们的反应是：“摩西击败了伊克斯。他们赢了。”而伊克斯——此时此刻他只是在执行总统吩咐他做的事，他在这件事上并没有个人利益纠葛，他对此感到非常受伤，但他仍然在一定程度上对摩西以如此强有力的方式处理这场斗争表示赞赏。而最重要的一点是，通过这一行动，
Moses now has his halo back. Now he is no longer the mean guy who calls people a liar, running to support the old guard. He is again, the defender of the people that the bigger guy is trying to crush. And this is the halo that stays on him halo that stays on him pretty much the rest of the time. Yeah, it's pretty amazing like this is this is this is a real like If you come at the king you best not miss it's kind of a scenario and they really missed and it really Resurrected him in every way possible
摩西的光环现在又回来了。现在他不再是那个叫别人骗子、跑去支持老卫派的刻薄家伙了。他又成了那个被大人物试图碾压的人民的捍卫者。这就是那个几乎伴随了他余下职业生涯的光环。是的，这太惊人了，这真是一场“你要是向国王开枪，最好别打偏”的剧本，而他们真的打偏了，这在各个方面都让他死而复生。
It's like the bullet missed the king, bounced off the wall, hit a bottle of super medicine that then tipped into the king's mouth and made him stronger. Like that's how badly they missed, yeah. And so much so that they eventually share a stage, you know, when the opening of the Trier Bridge happens. And this is one of my favorite things is like, Moses can't accept that he just won this like completely.
就像子弹打偏了国王，从墙上弹开，击中了一瓶超级药水，然后那瓶药水倾倒进国王嘴里，让他变得更强壮。对，他们打偏得就是这么离谱。以至于当三区大桥开通时，他们最终甚至同台亮相了。这是我最喜欢的事情之一：摩西简直无法接受他竟然这么彻底地赢了。
Like this is like, he won this so thoroughly. It's almost embarrassing. It's embarrassing to Roosevelt. But the pettiness continues because when the Triborough Bridge opens, the ceremony happens. And you know, he's smart enough to know that he has to invite Roosevelt.
就像是——他赢得太彻底了。这甚至有点尴尬。这对罗斯福来说很尴尬。但这种小家子气还在继续，因为当三区大桥开通、举行落成典礼时——你知道的，他足够精明，知道自己必须邀请罗斯福。
Cause otherwise, I mean, this is a big federal project. But he only allows him, cause he puts together the ceremony, he only allows Roosevelt five minutes to speak. Like the president of the United States of America. Exactly. And this is happening in 1936. So the president is also running for reelection that year.
否则——我的意思是，这是一个宏大的联邦项目。但他只允许他——因为典礼是他筹办的，他只允许罗斯福发言五分钟。就好像对待美利坚合众国的总统一样。没错。而且这发生在1936年。所以总统当年还要竞选连任。
Like this is a bit like, the president's gonna wanna talk for more than five minutes. Yeah, yeah. And so LaGuardia tells him, he's gotta talk more than five minutes. And Moses yeah. And so LaGuardia tells him, he's gotta talk more than five minutes. And Moses says, okay, he can talk for six minutes. It's so ridiculously petty. And I was looking over this again,
这就有点像——总统肯定想讲不止五分钟。对，对。所以拉瓜迪亚告诉他：“他得讲超过五分钟。”而摩西说：“好吧，他可以讲六分钟。”这真是荒谬的小家子气。当我再次翻看这些资料时，
I was thinking back to our talk with AOC last episode, go back and let's do it if you didn't hear it, where she was talking about how like, this happens. This is how decisions get made often is, I don't like that guy, I'm not gonna do this. Or, ugh, I just cannot, I have to poke this guy. And so he goes, all right, I'll give him one more minute to talk. And also Ickes is invited as a general spectator and he is really mad that he isn't going to get to speak. And finally he does. And Roosevelt and Ickes, they give their speeches
我想起了上一集我们和亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯（AOC）的谈话——如果你没听过，回去听听吧——她谈到过类似的事情：这种事时常发生。决策往往就是这样做出：“我讨厌那家伙，我才不这么干呢。”或者，“呃，我真是受不了，我非得去挑衅那家伙一下。”所以他说：“好吧，我再给他一分钟发言时间。”而且伊克斯也作为普通观众被邀请了，他对不能上台发言感到非常生气。最后他还是讲了。罗斯福和伊克斯发表了他们的演讲，
that do not mention Moses and Moses in his speech does not mention the president, but he indulges and this is classic Moses. I think it's the perfect way to end this chapter and the duo of the candidate chapter in this one, because it's Moses falling back in his bad habits again. As far as his speech, he has this incredibly oblique insult towards Roosevelt, this veiled insult that is based around knowing an anecdote from the life of Samuel Johnson. And it flies completely into the radar because nobody knows what he's talking about. And Carol has to take time to explain
演讲中完全没有提到摩西；而摩西在自己的演讲中也没有提到总统，但他沉缅于——这绝对是典型的摩西作风。我认为这是结束本章以及本集中“候选人”篇章的完美方式，因为这正是摩西又一次陷入他那些恶劣习惯的时候。在演讲中，他对罗斯福进行了极其隐晦的侮辱，一种含沙射影的讽刺，这个梗建立在一个关于塞缪尔·约翰逊（Samuel Johnson）生平轶事的典故之上。这完全超出了雷达探测范围，因为根本没人听懂他在说什么。卡罗不得不花时间去解释
what this insult is and what it means. It's like Moses cannot help being like, I know I won, I'm going to try to be gracious in public, but secretly I'm going to insult him in this way that nobody but me will understand. Like it's almost if he's like every, the first letter of every sentence of my speech, if you add it up, it says Roosevelt sucks
这个侮辱是什么意思、代表着什么。就好像摩西忍不住要想：“我知道我赢了，我尽量在公众面前表现得大度一点，但私底下我要用这种只有我一个人能听懂的方式来侮辱他。”就好像他在说：“每句话的第一个字母，如果你把它拼起来，它写着‘罗斯福烂透了’
or something like that. Like no one will know, but me. And it's, it's just so incredible. There's such children, there's such petty children and they're, they have the lives of millions in their hands. So, I mean, I love it looking back on it, reading a book, but I have to admit, but knowing that this is still how the world operates. I'm like, Oh, it's so, it's so frustrating. It is a little painful,
”或者诸如此类的话。除了我之外，没人会懂。这简直太不可思议了。他们简直就像小孩子，像一群小肚鸡肠的孩子，而千百万人的命运却掌握在他们手中。所以，我的意思是，回过头来读一读这本书，我觉得很有趣，但我必须承认，一想到世界至今仍然是以这种方式运转的，我就觉得：哦，这太——这太令人沮丧了。确实有点痛苦，
although I'm always having this sort of pang of wanting to see the downfall of Robert Moses before it actually happens, you know what I mean? So like when you get these petty squabbles, I'm mainly on FDR side in these things. Sure, yeah, at this point. And it just is just, oh, it's just rough. It's just rough to witness it.
尽管我总是有一种隐隐的冲动，想要看到罗伯特·摩西在现实中倒台之前先经历一次破灭，你知道我的意思吗？所以当看到这些琐碎的争吵时，在这类事情上，我基本上是站在FDR（罗斯福）这一边的。当然，是的，目前来看。这感觉——哦，这真的很难受。目睹这一切真的很难受。
It's the same thing. I mean, it's not as bad as this. The worst version of this for me is, I read a lot about Abraham Lincoln. I read a lot of Abraham Lincoln books because I think he's the greatest person who ever lived. We don't have to talk about that. This is a Robert Moses podcast.
这完全是一回事。我的意思是，还没那么糟。对我和最糟糕的情况来说，我读了很多关于亚伯拉罕·林肯的书。我读了大量林肯的书，因为我认为他是史上最伟大的人。我们不必讨论这个。这是一个关于罗伯特·摩西的播客。
But every time I'm reading a biography of him and it's getting closer and closer to him going to Ford's Theater, I'm always like, don't go. Yeah, I know. Don't do it. And then his bodyguard leaves to get a drink in the middle of the show. And I'm like, what are you doing? And it's, you know it's gonna happen.
但每次我读他的传记，看到剧情越来越接近他前往福特剧院（Ford's Theater）时，我总是忍不住想：别去啊。对，我懂。别去！然后他的保镖在演出中途出去喝饮料了，我就会想：你在干什么啊？而且——你知道结局会发生什么。
I mean, it's what happens in it when you watch a movie over again too, you know it's gonna happen, but you're hoping it doesn't happen. And, but that's part of the thrill of history, I guess, is knowing that it could have gone differently, but it's too late now. It's not gonna go differently ever again.
我的意思是，当你重看一部电影时也是这样，你知道接下来会发生什么，但你还是希望它不要发生。但我想，这就是历史的刺激之处吧——明知事情本可以有不同的走向，但一切都太迟了。历史绝不会再有另一种结局了。
But because of these petty magnations of FDR, Moses is sort of back on top and doing what he's doing. He is back in the saddle, which is the title of chapter 23, in the saddle. And it starts with this description of LaGuardia being just hilariously omnipresent in New York City. You're just everywhere that something is happening. LaGuardia is there just having fun, showing off, trying to make everyone love him. It's hilarious. Carol makes it sound like there are 17 LaGuardia
但由于罗斯福这些琐碎的阴谋诡计，摩西某种程度上又回到了权力巅峰，继续做他的事。他重新回到了马鞍上，这也是第23章的标题：《在马鞍上》。故事一开始就描述了拉瓜迪亚在纽约市那令人捧腹的无处不在。无论哪里发生什么事，拉瓜迪亚就在那里，自得其乐、爱出风头，试图让所有人都爱他。这太搞笑了。卡罗把这一切描写得好像在任何特定时刻，都有17个拉瓜迪亚
is running around the city at any given point. It's like he's over there. He's personally inspecting the treatment of people in public housing. There he is over there. He's at the Bronx terminal market. There's been stories of artichoke racketeering. So he's personally banning artichokes from the Bronx terminal market. Uh-oh,
在全市到处乱跑。就好像他在那边，正亲自视察公共住房里居民的待遇。他又在那边，在布朗克斯终端市场（Bronx terminal market）。有人爆料说那里存在朝鲜蓟（artichoke）敲诈勒索案，于是他亲自下令在布朗克斯终端市场禁止销售朝鲜蓟。噢，糟了，
firefighters are trapped under a collapsed wall. He's going to go whisper encouragement to them while they're being saved. He's everywhere. And the same time he's slashing non-essential jobs in city budget. He's pushing back on local corruption. He's bullying the city into submission, but he's also bullying his staff. He loves to yell at his staff. He loves to fire his staff. This is not entirely all positive, but yeah, he's just, it just presents him as I have to imagine him zooming around like cartoon character, just puffs of smoke appearing where he used to be as he like runs off and the person who can always stand up to him is Moses and they fight.
消防员被困在坍塌的墙壁下了，他要跑去对他们低声说鼓励的话，同时他们正在被营救。他无处不在。与此同时，他在大幅削减市预算中的非必要职位，他在回击地方腐败，他用蛮横手段迫使这座城市就范，但他也用蛮横手段对待他的员工。他喜欢对员工大喊大叫，喜欢解雇员工。这并不完全都是积极正面的，但——对，他就是这样，这把他描绘得——我不得不想象他像个卡通人物一样到处乱窜，每次跑开时原位都会留下一团烟雾，而唯一能与他抗衡的人就是摩西，他们俩总是大吵大闹。
They shout Moses is deliberately rude to him. He calls him by Italian slurs, both behind his back and in front of his back. He's always threatening to resign to the point where I love this so much. This is makes me love LaGuardia is he has a pad printed up with forms on it that say I, Robert Moses do hereby resign as blank, effective blank. And the next time Moses resigns, he hands him the pad and Moses gets really mad about it. And it totally wins.
他们大喊大叫，摩西故意对他的无礼，在背后和当面都用带有意大利人贬义的词汇称呼他。他总是威胁要辞职，以至于——我太喜欢这个细节了。这让我爱上了拉瓜迪亚：他特意印好了一个记事本，上面印着格式化的表单，写着：“我，罗伯特·摩西，在此辞去……职务，自……起生效。”下一次摩西再威胁要辞职时，他直接把这个本子拍在摩西手里，这把摩西气得够呛。这招彻底管用了。
Like he, he blunts that as a thing. And, and, and Robert Moses really mad about it. And it totally wins. Like he blunts that as a thing and Robert Moses doesn't do it to him anymore. They have figured out this way of like complimentary abuse that somehow fosters this kind of mutual respect that just kind of works for them. It's amazing, but it just, it does. Yeah, but it means they're constantly
他用这招化解了这一威胁，而罗伯特·摩西再也没有这样对他过。他们摸索出了一种“互损”的相处方式，这种方式不知为何培养了一种相互尊重的默契，对他们俩来说竟然挺管用的。这太不可思议了，但它确实管用了。是的，但这意味着他们一直在
butting heads against each other. Even though in the grand scheme of things, they agree on the major goals, means they're constantly butting heads against each other, even though in the grand scheme of things, they agree on the major goals, but they're always butting heads. And there are a couple of fights that Kara goes into, my favorite of them, but I find it very sad is in 1936, Moses, he wants the land that's currently being held by the terminal for a ferry that goes
针锋相对。尽管从宏观大局来看，他们在核心目标上是一致的，但他们总是互不相让。卡罗在书中提到了好几场争端，其中我最喜欢、但也觉得最悲哀的一场发生在1936年，摩西看中了目前被一个渡轮码头占用的土地，该渡轮码头往返于
between Astoria and Manhattan. And you're like, Oh, I'd like to go take that ferry. You can't, it's not there anymore. Don't, don't even try. I'll tell you why it's not there. The guard is like, you should wait. The commuters are not ready to lose it.
阿斯托里亚（Astoria）和曼哈顿之间。你可能会想：“哦，我想去坐坐那个渡轮。”你坐不了了，它已经没了。甚至不用去试。我来告诉你它为什么没了。拉瓜迪亚的态度是：“你该等等。通勤者们还没准备好失去它。”
It's a five cent ferry trip, which is more pleasant and cheaper than riding on what's gonna be a 50 cent toll road. And Caro, he paints it as the kind of like endearing antiquated piece of old New York, this old rusty old ferry that modern New York is doing its best to just throw away as fast as possible. And Moses is impatient. So literally as soon as the ferry leaves the dock one day,
这是一次只要五美分的渡轮之旅，比乘坐即将开通的、要收五十美分过路费的公路要更惬意、也更便宜。卡罗把它描绘成老纽约一种迷人而古朴的存在，这个生锈的老旧渡轮是现代纽约正竭尽全力以最快速度抛弃的过去。而摩西却毫无耐心。所以，就在某一天渡轮刚离开码头的瞬间，
he just sends his workers in and they start smashing up the dock and smashing up the ferry terminal building and even tearing up the road leading to the ferry terminal building. And LaGuardia has to send the police to arrest the parks workers who are doing this. And then a week later, Moses, he just gets the land and he tears down the fairy house completely. Yeah. It's crazy. I mean, like he calls the police on his own parks guy and, and it's just sort of
他直接派工人冲进去，开始砸毁码头、砸毁渡轮候船大楼，甚至把通往渡轮候船大楼的道路都给铲了。拉瓜迪亚不得不派警察去逮捕那些干这事的公园局工人。然后过了一个星期，摩西直接拿下了这块地，把渡轮候船室彻底给拆了。太疯狂了。我的意思是——他竟然为了自己的公园员工而报警，而且这感觉
like, it's like they're playing a game of chess and there's all these people, you know, caught in the middle of it where, policeman has to arrest a worker who's just being told, don't stop for anybody because this jerk Robert Moses tells him not to stop for anybody and the cops come and it's just a nightmare. And then they have to like, there's like a boat out that has nowhere to go because- Yeah, it has to find another place to dock because he tore the dock up. He just doesn't care. There's people on that boat. They can't live on it.
就像——就像他们在一盘国际象棋，而有那么多人夹在中间受罪：警察不得不去逮捕一个工人的原因，仅仅是因为这个混蛋罗伯特·摩西告诉他“谁也不准停”，而警察赶到了，这简直是一场噩梦。然后他们不得不——有一艘船甚至无处可停，因为——对，它必须去找另一个地方靠岸，因为他把码头给拆了。他根本不在乎。船上还有乘客呢。他们总不能住在船上吧。
It's crazy how much he doesn't think about individuals. And it's just sort of stunning. I'm sort of like, this is like real villainy. Yeah, well, he knows that his goals, and this will become clear more and more in this section of the book as we're talking, this overall episode, that his goals he believes are the best and only useful goals. And so anything that has to be done to get those goals as quickly and as effectively
他完全不考虑个体感受，这简直太疯狂了。这太震撼了。我当时的感觉是：这绝对是真正的恶棍行径。嗯，他深知自己的目标——随着我们在这本书的这一部分以及本集节目中的深入探讨，这一点会变得越来越清晰——他坚信自己的目标是最好、也是唯一有用的目标。因此，为了尽可能快、尽可能有效地达成这些目标，任何必须采取的手段，
as possible, he'll do it. There's in 1937, so the next year, LaGuardia's got to call the police out on him again because LaGuardia's like, we've got to move 2,000 of the laborers the federal workers were working for you We got to reassign them from your projects to other projects and he goes, okay We'll reassign the playground supervisors and he fires 2,000 playground supervisors and he locks shut over 140 playgrounds and removes the playground equipment so they can't be reopened and Moms with kids start protesting because they went to their playground They found that the police have chained it shut and there's no equipment.
他都会去做。在1937年，也就是第二年，拉瓜迪亚不得不再次报警对付他，因为拉瓜迪亚的立场是：“我们必须把为你工作的联邦工人中的2,000名劳动力调走。我们得把他们从你的项目重新分配到其他项目上去。”而摩西的反应是：“好吧，那我们就重新分配操场管理员吧。”结果他直接解雇了2,000名操场管理员，把140多个儿童游乐场全部上锁，甚至把游乐设施都拆掉了，这样它们就无法重新开放。带着孩子的妈妈们开始抗议，因为她们走到游乐场时，
And he's got to call out the police again to try to get him to stop closing these playgrounds. And every time this happens, Moses is able to spin it so that they blame the city or they blame LaGuardia rather than Moses. And Caro starts to theorize that Moses got away with this partly because LaGuardia respected people who would stand up to him and fight him and partly because they both wanted the same thing ultimately. LaGuardia wants New York to be a beautiful city. He wants it to be a new functioning gleaming city and he loves engineering. He's hugely in awe of large scale construction.
发现警察用链条把它锁上了，里面没有任何游乐设施。拉瓜迪亚不得不再次报警，试图制止他关闭这些游乐场。每当发生这种事，摩西总能把舆论风向扭转过去，让人们去责怪市政府或拉瓜迪亚，而不是责怪摩西。卡罗开始推论说，摩西之所以能屡屡逃脱惩罚，一部分是因为拉瓜迪亚敬佩那些敢于顶撞他、跟他斗争的人，另一部分则是因为他们俩最终想要的东西其实是一样的。拉瓜迪亚希望纽约成为一座美丽的城市。他希望它是一座崭新、运转良好、熠熠生辉的城市，而且他热爱工程建设。他对大规模建设有着极大的狂热。
He's like a child. He likes to wear a construction hat or a hard hat and go to a construction site and go, wow, look at those big machines. Wow, look at that. And at one point LaGuardia calls Moses the greatest engineer in the world. And Moses even is not technically an engineer. He doesn't have an engineering degree. He doesn't know how to draw up plans, but he has the staff that can draw up plans. And he's the only person who has it.
他就像个孩子。他喜欢戴着施工帽或安全帽去建筑工地，然后惊叹道：“哇，快看那些大机器！哇，快看那个！”有一次，拉瓜迪亚甚至称赞摩西是“世界上最伟大的工程师”。而摩西其实并不是个技术意义上的工程师。他没有工程学位。他不会画图纸，但他手下有能画图纸的员工。他是唯一拥有这种资源的人。
So the third part of it, I don't remember how many, I haven't counted the final leg in this school of how many, however many legs is that they need this federal money to do it. And most, the only guy who can get that federal money because he can create the plans. He has the people who can create the plans to get it. Yeah. He has shovel-ready projects that allow them to pass through the PWA system, and he can keep getting money and money and money. He's just like always ready, always on the ball. He also like when it comes to these types of arguments and the rough tactics which they use against each other,
所以其中的第三部分——我不记得是多少了，我没数过这套逻辑里究竟有多少个环节，不管有多少个环节吧——他们需要联邦资金来完成这些项目。而摩西是唯一能搞到这笔联邦资金的人，因为他能拿出方案。他拥有能拿出方案并申请到资金的人手。对。他手里总是有那些“万事俱备、只欠东风”的项目，能够顺利通过PWA系统的审批，于是他能源源不断地搞到资金。他总是蓄势待发，时刻保持高度警惕。此外，当涉及到这类争论以及他们彼此使用的强硬战术时，
Moses sort of lacks compunction. Like I think they fight over these things and LaGuardia wants a lot of the same things Moses wants. But the reason why Moses wins in each of these moments is because he does not care about these people, and LaGuardia actually does. And it's just infuriating to watch. I mean, it just makes me so mad to read about it.
摩西基本上缺乏道德顾忌。我觉得他们为了这些事情争吵，而且拉瓜迪亚想要的很多东西其实和摩西是一样的。但摩西在每一次较量中获胜的原因在于：他根本不在乎这些老百姓，而拉瓜迪亚是真的在乎。看这段历史简直气死人了。我的意思是，读到这些真的让我火冒三丈。
It's a little bit like the story of Solomon and the two mothers and the baby. If Solomon had said, we're gonna have to cut this baby in half, and the one mother said, okay, go ahead, do it. And Solomon said, I had my guts. Yeah, you take the baby. You stood up and you wouldn't compromise.
这有点像所罗门王和两个争夺孩子的母亲的故事。如果当年所罗门说的是：“我们得把这孩子劈成两半，”而其中一个母亲说：“行吧，那就劈吧，动手吧，”然后所罗门说：“我真是服了。行，孩子归你。你态度强硬，坚决不肯妥协。
You take this baby. Like it feels unjust. It feels like things go the wrong way. And when Moses just bullies his way into getting stuff done. But that happens in in politics still that there's a certain respect for the ability to not care in that you're unstoppable. You won't let anyone stand in your way.
这孩子归你。”这就让人感觉很不公。感觉事情总是走向错误的方向。而摩西正是靠着这种无赖作风强行推行各项事务。但这在政治斗争中依然时常发生——人们往往对那种“毫不在乎”的狠劲抱有一种敬畏，因为这意味着你是不可阻挡的。你不会让任何人挡你的路。
And it's the person who cares too much who is more easily held hostage because if things go bad, they'll be upset. But the other side of things go bad, they don't care. It doesn't matter to them. They don't care at all. And I think the other part that keeps Moses sort of buttressed in these fights is he has such a tight relationship with the press.
而那个在乎太多的人反而更容易被当成软肋受制于人，因为一旦事情搞砸了，他们会心烦意乱。但反过来，如果事情搞砸了，另一方根本无所谓。这根本不关他们的事。他们压根不在乎。我想，另一个让摩西在这些争斗中始终坚如磐石的原因是，他和媒体有着极其紧密的联系。
So like none of this would leak out. Like him not caring, him being the person that moved the park workers and fired them so that the parks would be shut down, you know, none of that leaks out because he just has cultivated this relationship with the press that is almost, there's just no light between them. He's very good at wooing the press. He takes publishers and editors and reporters. At this point, there's 13 daily newspapers in New York City, which is astonishing to me.
所以这些丑闻全都没有泄露出去。比如他不在乎民生、他为了关闭公园而故意转移并解雇公园工人的事——你知道的，这些全都没有泄露出去，因为他精心培植了与媒体的关系，双方之间几乎可以说是天衣无缝。他非常擅长讨好媒体。他带着出版商、编辑和记者去参加宴会。他会带他们乘游艇出海。他会在琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）为他们举办派对。书的后面有一个章节，直观地展现了罗伯特·摩西穷奢极欲的奢华生活方式。我太期待那一章了。那太惊人了。但他同时也是城里一些最有权势的报业巨头的私交好友。他和《先驱论坛报》（Herald Tribune）的奥格登·米尔斯·里德（Ogden Mills-Reed）是朋友。你可能还记得，奥格登·米尔斯·里德就是当年摩西在耶鲁当学生时试图敲诈勒索的对象。没错。
It's just incredible. And he takes the publishers and the editors and reporters on banquets. He'll take them on yacht trips. He'll throw parties for them at Jones Beach. And there's a chapter much later in the book where it kind of gives you a firsthand look at the luxury lifestyle that lavishes in the RM chapter. I'm so looking forward to that one. It's amazing. But he's also personal friends with some of the most powerful newspaper owners in the city. He's friends with Ogden Mills-Reed of the Herald Tribune. You may remember Ogden Mills-Reed as the guy that Moses was gonna con money out of when he was a Yale student. That's right.
里德一直没发现那件事，所以他俩至今还是朋友。但最重要的是，他和《纽约时报》的所有者苏尔茨伯格家族（Sulzbergers）是朋友。当时和现在一样，《纽约时报》都是全国最具影响力的报纸。《纽约时报》三分之二的股份由伊塔根·奥克斯·苏尔茨伯格（Iphigene Ochs Sulzberger）持有——多么了不起的名字。她热爱公共公园。她热爱公园。而且她也崇拜摩西，把他视作那个能够创造公园的人。虽然她并不总是赞同他的做法。
Reid never found out about that, so he's still his friend. But most importantly, he's friends with the Sulzberger's, the owners of the New York Times. At the time, as is now, it's the most influential paper in the country. And two-thirds of the Times stock is owned by Ithagene Ox-Sulzberger, such an amazing name. And she loves public parks. She loves parks. And she worships Moses too, as the guy who can make parks. And she doesn't always agree with him.
卡罗曾引用过她的一句话，说工程师们有着“直线狂热”（straight line crazy），这也是大卫·海尔（David Hare）关于罗伯特·摩西的话剧剧名的由来。所以她希望公园里有草地。她不想要混凝土设施。她觉得摩西的做法不对。但即使他的做法不对，他毕竟还在建公园。一座混凝土公园总比没有公园强。这才是她真正在乎的。有一次，她和摩西意见不合，摩西竟然给她写了一封充满侮辱性的信。
She's the one that Carol quotes as saying that engineers are straight line crazy, which becomes the name of the David Hare play about Robert Moses. So she wants parks that are grass. She doesn't want concrete facilities. And she thinks Moses is doing the wrong way. But even if he's doing the wrong way, he's still building parks. A concrete park is better than no park. And so that's what she cares about. And there's a part where she disagrees with Moses and he sends her an insulting letter.
而《纽约时报》甚至刊登了她的道歉声明——她因为与摩西意见不合而发表的公开道歉。《时报》的记者们从来没有接到过她的命令说“你们必须支持罗伯特·摩西”，但他们心里清楚如何让老板高兴。就像你在某人手下打工一样，你自然知道怎么让他们开心，知道他们想要什么，知道他们会喜欢什么。所以每当摩西发表什么言论，
And the New York Times prints her apology, her public apology for disagreeing with him. And the reporters at the Times, they're never told by her, you have to support Robert Moses, but they know how to keep the boss happy. Like when you work for someone, you know how to keep them happy, you know what they want, and you know what things they're gonna like. And so when Moses says something,
《纽约时报》——还有其他报纸，尤其是《纽约时报》——都会将其奉为真理。他成了那个说真话的人，他的立场才是最值得报道的。因此拉瓜迪亚根本无法开除他。在那个报纸远比现在更有影响力的时代，报纸是大多数人获取周围世界信息的主要途径，最具权势的报纸
the Times, but also the other papers, but especially the Times, takes it as truth. He's the guy who's telling the truth, and his side is the one that deserves reporting. So LaGuardia can't fire him. The most powerful newspaper at a time when newspapers were so much more powerful than they are now, it's the way most people still got their information
会在他胆敢开除摩西时让他吃不了兜着走。所以在某种程度上，拉瓜迪亚甚至不再向摩西提出抱怨，他学会了：他只能私下里跟摩西争论，但随后不得不顺着摩西的意思来，并且在公开场合假装两人之间没有任何分歧，因为摩西简直是不可触碰的，
about the world around them. It'll give him hell if he fires Moses. And so at this point, at a certain point, LaGuardia is like not even bringing up complaints to Moses and he learns that he's got to argue with Moses in private, but then let Moses have his way and then pretend in public that there was no disagreement between the two of them because Moses is just untouchable
就因为他与媒体有着这种关系。而且他之所以不可触碰，还因为他手握从联邦政府揽钱的权力。他在市政府担任着重要职务，同时他在州政府也担任要职。这就是为什么法律曾明令禁止身兼数职，因为这是让人变得比市长还要权势滔天的最便捷途径。
because of this relationship to the press. And he's also untouchable because he holds this sort of like role getting money from the federal government. He holds this role in the city and he also has this role in the state government. And this is the reason why there was a law that made that illegal because it is a very easy way to make someone more powerful than the mayor.
没错，这正是现实中发生的事情。因为摩西能够接触到联邦资金。他的项目通常不花市政府的钱。所以他根本不需要市政府的批准。而且市里的选民怎么想也根本不重要，因为他压根不听他们的。如果市长说：“嘿，你不能这么做。
Yes, which is exactly what happens because Moses has access to the federal money. He's not using city money to build his projects usually. So he doesn't need the city's approval. And it doesn't matter what the voters of the city necessarily think because he's not listening to them. And if the mayor says, hey, you shouldn't do that.
市里的老百姓不会喜欢的。”他可以直接对州政府的人说：“给拉瓜迪亚找点麻烦吧。既然他在给我使绊子，我也别让他好过。”或者在需要州批准时，他可以直接批准自己的项目。这就好比我的孩子们有外部资金来源，同时他们还和我的父母建立了某种关系，每当我管教他们说：“该睡觉了。你们现在必须去睡觉。”他们的反应却是：“哦？有趣。要不我给爷爷打个电话，让他生你的气？要不我让爷爷在电话里冲你吼？”而我的反应则是：“那你们就拿不到零花钱了。”他们会说：“无所谓啊，因为联邦政府给了我十亿美元。所以我根本不需要你这点零花钱。我想今晚熬到半夜。”“可是你明天还要上学啊！”“是吗？我非得
The people in the city aren't gonna like it. He can say to the people in the state government, make some trouble for LaGuardia. I don't want things to go easy for him while he's making it difficult for me. Or he can approve his own projects when it needs state approval. And it's as if my children had outside money coming in and also then had a relationship
再给爷爷打个电话吗？”这就是当时的处境。所以，表面上看，这个给市长打工的人权力比市长还要大，而且在掌控着一切。所以，表面上看，这个给市长打工的人权力比市长还要大，而且在掌控着一切。
with my parents where I'd be like, it's time to go to bed. You got to go to bed right now. And they're like, huh, interesting. Well, why don't I call up grandpa and have him get mad at you? Why don't I have grandpa yell at you over the phone? And I'm like, well, then you're not going to get your allowance. And they're like, that's cool, because the federal government is giving me a billion dollars. So I don't need this allowance money. I think I'm going to stay up until midnight tonight. But you have school tomorrow. Do I? Do I have
正如卡罗所指出的——他在书中对此进行了详尽的描述，不过我们可以稍微略过——为了重建这座城市，市里花掉的资金比以往任何时候都要多，但这根本不是市政府的钱。因此，摩西在重建城市的过程中拥有巨大的话语权，比市长的话语权更大，比选民的话语权更大，这一切都仅仅因为他建立了一个不向任何人负责的权力机构，不需要对任何理应监督他的民选官员负责。是的，是的。而且这种情况实际上只会越来越糟，因为很快他就要把那些收费站的]]></thought
to call grandpa again? Like that's, that's the situation. And so yeah, ostensibly, the guy who works for the mayor is more powerful than the mayor and, and is running things. And so, yeah, ostensibly, the guy who works for the mayor is more powerful than the mayor and is running things. And so, Carol makes the point, and he goes into a lot of detail about it, but we can kind of like skim, is that more money is being spent in the city than ever before to rebuild the city, but it's not the city's money. And so, Moses has so much say in rebuilding the city, more say than the mayor does, more say than the voters does, all because he's constructed this power organization that is beholden to no one, no one elected figure who is supposed to have oversight over him. Yeah, yeah. And this actually just gets worse because pretty soon he's going to get all that toll
又要去叫爷爷了吗？就像那是，那就是当时的情况。所以，表面上，为市长工作的人比市长更有权势，并且在掌管一切。所以，是的，表面上，为市长工作的人比市长更有权势，并且在掌管一切。所以，卡罗提出了一个观点，他对此进行了详细阐述，但我们可以略过，那就是为了重建这座城市，花在城市里的钱比以往任何时候都要多，但这不是市长的钱。因此，摩西在重建城市方面拥有如此大的话语权，比市长的话语权更大，比选民的话语权更大，这一切都是因为他建立了一个不向任何人效忠的权力组织，没有任何本应对他进行监督的民选官员来管他。是的，是的。而且这实际上只会变得更糟，因为很快他就会得到所有的过路费
money too to do the same thing. But right now, he is just balancing all these different forces that he has his tentacles in, and he can just lean on one, get money from another, circumvent another, and he just is this amazing operator, just taking advantage of the gaps between these different organizations and how they cannot work together.
金钱来做同样的事情。但现在，他只是在平衡他所涉足的各种不同势力，他可以倚仗一方，从另一方获取资金，绕过又一方，而他就是这样一个出色的操纵者，正利用着这些不同组织之间的缝隙以及他们无法合作的现状。
Exactly, and the things that he saw as impossible to do before, like trading political favors to get support, he's now totally fine with doing. And whereas before he used to be the no pay, he'd tell people, go to hell if you want patronage. Now he's like, does your kid need a summer job as a lifeguard? Well, give me your vote.
没错，以前他觉得绝对不可能做的事，比如通过做政治交易来换取支持，现在他做起来完全没有任何心理负担。过去他可是个对金钱毫无兴趣的人，如果有人想要求得庇护，他会叫对方滚蛋。而现在，他却会说：“你家孩子需要一份救生员的暑期工作吗？行，那就把你的选票投给我。”
He's got that job. He's very happy to do that. And at this point, Moses, as we mentioned before, he has more in common with the Republicans in the state legislature than LaGuardia, who is ostensibly the Republican mayor. LaGuardia is the original rhino. He's basically a New Deal liberal who just happens to be Republican. And he just has so much power. And the ultimate point of this that Caro is trying to make throughout the book is that in theory, the purpose of a democracy is so that the people have ultimate control and
这份工作他轻而易举就能搞定。他非常乐意这么做。正如我们之前提到的，到了这个时候，比起拉瓜迪亚这位名义上的共和党市长，摩西与州议会共和党人的共同点反而更多。拉瓜迪亚是典型的虚假共和党人。他基本上就是一个恰好顶着共和党头衔的新政自由派。他拥有如此巨大的权力。卡罗整本书试图传达的终极观点是，从理论上讲，民主的目的是为了让民众拥有最终的控制权和
ultimate say over how they are governed and how their municipalities exist, what's built and what's not built and things like that. And Moses has hacked the system in a way that takes him completely out of that accountability control. And is that the way that a city government or a state government or a federal government should be operating? No, sir. No, sir. Not at all. And yet. That's the way it is. The cracks are there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is really it. He has just, his knowledge of all these different systems, it just allows him to exploit and, you know, wheedle his way through and strong arm in some places,
最终的决定权，来决定他们如何被治理、他们的城市如何存在、什么该建、什么不该建诸如此类的事情。而摩西通过黑客般的方式打破了这个体制，使他完全脱离了这种问责控制。这难道就是市政府、州政府或联邦政府应该有的运作方式吗？绝不。绝不。完全不是。然而事实就是如此。裂痕已经出现了。对的。对的。对的。这正是关键所在。他凭借对所有这些不同体制的了解，得以进行剥削，你知道的，在某些地方巧舌如簧、步步为营，而在其他地方又在适时的时候选择
acquiesce in others when it's appropriate. He just is thinking around these people in ways that is just like the system wasn't built to stop a Moses. He just has this ability to work around it. And he really does it because of the halo effect of the parks and then the halo effect of the integrity of local governance, I guess. And that's one of the things that's so ironic about it is it's like, we've got to support
顺从。他算计这些人的方式，就好像这个体制本来就不是为了阻挡一个摩西而建造的。他总是有办法绕过它。他之所以能做到这一点，实际上是因为公园带来的光环效应，以及我想象中的地方治理廉洁性的光环效应。这正是其中最具讽刺意味的事情之一，这就好比是说，我们必须支持
Moses because supporting Moses means supporting the independence of the New York City government. And then it it's like if there's one guy who is doing an end run around the New York City government It is Robert Moses. Yeah, it is. He is such a so many times. I feel like throughout the book in the public's eye he's the champion of the exact thing that he is not doing or the exact danger that he has and Just astounding. He's like it's like they put a card counter in charge of the casino and he's like, yeah, yeah, I'm just making sure nobody's counting cards around here while he's just keeping track of everything. And it's astonishing.
摩西，因为支持摩西就意味着支持纽约市政府的独立性。然而接下来，这就好像如果说有一个人在绕过纽约市政府的话，那个人就是罗伯特·摩西。没错，就是他。他真的是这样，好多次我都觉得，在公众眼中，整本书里他都是他所反对的事物的捍卫者，或者说他是他所带来的那种危险的化身。真是令人震惊。这就像是他们把一个数牌手派去管理赌场，而他还信誓旦旦地说：“没问题，没问题，我只是在确保这里没有人偷偷数牌”，同时他自己却在掌控着一切。这太惊人了。
And he's gonna make greater and greater use of that as we go into the next chapter. Yes, the next chapter is driving. We'll get to that after this break. So we're up to chapter 24. It's called driving. Uh, it's another chapter called driving. Um, so one of the things that I'm always impressed by about this book is the structure of it.
随着我们进入下一章，他将对这种权力进行更大规模的运用。是的，下一章讲的是驾驶。我们在休息过后就会讲到。所以我们现在讲到第24章。这一章叫做“驾驶”。呃，又是一个叫做“驾驶”的章节。呃，所以，这本书最让我赞叹的一点一直是它的结构。
It's a long book and it's structured in a way that is not straightforward chronology, which can be confusing sometimes, but is often thematically illuminating and Karo is returning to themes and finding new layers to them or new meanings to the same words. And it just, it's a book that exists on a literary level, in addition to existing on a
这是一本大部头书，它的结构并非采用直白的编年史顺序，有时这可能会让人感到困惑，但它往往能从主题上给人以启迪，卡罗不断回归相同的主题，并为它们发掘出新的层次或赋予相同的词语以新的含义。这使得它不仅仅是一部历史非虚构作品，同时也是一本在文学层面上立得住的书。所以，这就是其中一个关于“驾驶”的章节。“改变”是他喜欢用的章节标题。“驾驶”也是他喜欢用的章节标题。出于某种原因，花椰菜的策展人，这是一个关于驾驶的章节。“改变”是他喜欢用的章节标题。“驾驶”是他喜欢用的章节标题。出于某种原因，花椰菜的策展人，这是一个一次性的章节标题。我肯定想把那个标题用两次。是的。
historical non-fiction level. And so this is one of the driving chapters. Changing is a chapter title he likes to use. Driving's a chapter title he likes to use. For some reason, the curator of Cauliflower's, this is a of the driving chapters. Changing is a chapter title he likes to use. Driving's a chapter title he likes to use. For some reason, the curator of Cauliflower's, this is a one-time title chapter. I want to use that one twice for sure. Yeah.
书的最后一句本应该是：“真的，策展人现在已经被花椰菜化了。”或者像，“花椰菜们正在策展他。”这本来是一个很有冲击力、却错失的良机。你知道的，这是一本大书。你不可能面面俱到。但这个嘛，你本以为摩西正处于人生巅峰，对吧？但没有，他仍然得赶时间。
The last line of the book should have been, truly, the curator had now been Cauliflowered. Or like, the Cauliflower's are curating him. He's a really drive-it-home, but missed opportunity. You know, it's a big book. You can't hit them all. But this is, you'd think most on top of the world, right? But no, he's still got to rush.
他总是得赶时间，因为他把自己置于这样一种境地：如果他眼下依赖某样东西——正如你刚才所说，在三区大桥刚刚建好、真正带来大量收入之前——他是依赖联邦资金的。而联邦政府并不是绝对可靠的，因为每当经济看起来略有起色时，国会中的
He's always got to rush because the position he's put himself in is that if he's dependent on one thing at the moment, before, as you're saying, the Triborough bridges up really bringing in a lot of money, he's dependent on that federal money. And the federal government is not ultra reliable because whenever the economy looks like it's getting a little better, the conservatives in
保守派就想要削减正在源源不断拨出的联邦资金。每当经济变好，摩西的处境就会变糟。从某种非常现实的意义上说，他的成功与整个美利坚合众国的经济健康状况成反比。所以他必须抓紧时间干活。他不能让任何人挡他的路。而且，你知道的，因为他自己撰写了赋予他权力的法律，所以他必须抓紧时间。他不能让任何人挡他的路。并且由于他自己写了那些赋予他权力的法律，他不受某些法律的约束。至于其他的法律，他则直接无视。
Congress want to cut that federal money that's being poured out. Every time the economy gets better, things get worse for Moses. He's in a very real sense, his success is, has an inverse relationship to the economic health of the entire United States of America. So he's got to work fast. He can't let anyone get in his way. And he's, you know, because he's written his own laws that give him power, he's got to work fast. He can't let anyone get in his way. And because he's written his own laws that give him power, he's not beholden to some laws. In other ones, he ignores them.
他非常热衷于在施工开始当天或者事情快要完成时才提交计划书以供审查。他开始雇用他所谓的“猎犬”——这些人专门去挖掘那些不情愿的官员的个人黑料，以便他能用来向他们施压。这完全就是赤裸裸的敲诈勒索。如果某个公务员反抗他，又没有什么把柄可以利用，他就会通过媒体去抹黑对方，把对方塑造成一个碍手碍脚的庸官。这招对莱曼州长不管用，因为莱曼州长很有名。人人都知道他是谁。
He's very big on submitting plans to be examined on the day that the construction starts or when things are almost finished. He starts employing what he calls his bloodhounds, who are digging up compromising personal information on reluctant officials that he can use to pressure them. It's just out and out blackmail. And if a civil servant resists him and there's no blackmail material, he can use the press to smear them to make them seem like a hack who's getting in the way. And that didn't work against Governor Layman because Governor Layman is famous. Everybody knows who he is.
但如果你只是个副主计长，而报纸开始报道你是个多坏的家伙、多大的惹事精，根本没有人知道你是谁。由于这种压力，你最终只能选择辞职。这一切的第一层逻辑就像是：哦，这些只不过是无能的官僚，什么事也干不成。而我能把事情办成。如果我们非得等什么估价委员会来做决定，那我们永远也别想把事情办成了。
But if you're the deputy comptroller and the papers start talking about what a bad dude you are, what a troublemaker you are, there's no one knows anything about you. You're going to have to, you resign because of that pressure. And the first level of this is just like, oh, these are just namby pamby bureaucrats who can't get anything done. And I get things done. And if we had to wait for, you know, this like board of estimate to do something, we'll, we'll never get anything done.
这招让他在相当程度上顺风顺水。但当这招不管用时，事情就变得相当难看了。在给别人贴上共产主义者标签这方面，他是一个非常、非常早期的麦卡锡主义者。没错。卡罗写道，他说，如果说罗伯特·摩西是公园和公路领域的先驱，那他也是麦卡锡主义在麦卡锡出现二十年之久的先驱。这是在20世纪30年代。他当时就已经在说：这个家伙不同意我的观点，他很可能是个红派分子，这家伙很可能
And that gets him pretty far. But then when that doesn't work, it gets pretty ugly. And he's a very, very early kind of McCarthyist when it comes to labeling people as communists. Yep. Carol writes, he says, if Robert Moses was a pioneer in the fields of parks and highways, he was also pioneer in McCarthyism 20 years before McCarthy. This is the 1930s. And he always already saying, this guy doesn't agree with with me he's probably a red, this guy's probably
是个激进分子，这家伙是个社会主义者。而且他打从一开始就讨厌无阶级社会的理念，所以这并不意味着他——这就好比他是把自己的信仰当作一种雇佣兵式的武器来使用。卡罗讲述了拉瓜迪亚的法律秘书保罗·J·科恩的故事。科恩当时正在与拉瓜迪亚建立一种类似于摩西与艾尔·史密斯之间的关系，而且科恩挺喜欢摩西的。但当科恩试图阻止摩西绕过公务员招聘规章时——正是摩西年轻时曾极力倡导的那类法律——摩西的反应却是：呃，不行。他对拉瓜迪亚说，科恩一直在说你的坏话。这实在太糟糕了。诸如此类，他简直就是在对拉瓜迪亚撒谎。然后科恩说，我要建立一套制度，对那些举报职场违规行为的员工给予奖励。
a radical, this guy's a socialist and he already doesn't like the idea of a classless society so it's not like he's it's like he is using his own beliefs as a weapon in a mercenary way and Carr tells the story of LaGuardia's law secretary Paul J. Kern who was kind of building the kind of relationship with LaGuardia that Moses had with Al Smith and Kern likes Moses. But when he tries to keep Moses from circumventing civil service hiring regulations, the kind of laws that Moses
于是摩西跑到媒体面前说：“这是一个苏维埃式的秘密警察。”好吧，好吧，我猜是科恩这个共产主义者引发了这一切。而拉瓜迪亚作为一名新政共和党人，极其害怕被指责为共产主义者，于是他二话不说就把科恩给解雇了。拉瓜迪亚作为一名新政共和党人，极其害怕被指责为共产主义者，于是他二话不说就把科恩给解雇了。卡罗指出，直到1960年摩西卸任公园专员之前，再也没有哪个公务员委员会敢干涉他的招聘做法。一切变得清清爽爽。
was the champion of in his younger days. Moses is like, uh, no. And he's like LaGuardia, Kern is, is saying bad things about you. This is really terrible. Like he's just lying to him about him. And then Kern says, I'm going to start a system where workers are rewarded for reporting violations in the workplace.
他太擅长霸凌别人了。唯一的办法，也许如果你自己足够强大，你就能顶撞他。如果你敢于站出来对抗他，也许他会有所收敛，尊重你的实力。但除此之外，他只会对你为所欲为。据说市长行政班子里所有专员每周都有一次午餐会。摩西讨厌去参加。他觉得那是浪费时间。所以他总是派一盆盆栽代替自己去坐在午餐会上。专员们对他是又气又恨，
And Moses goes to the press and says, a Soviet style secret police. Well, well, I guess Kern, the communist is causing this. And LaGuardia as a new deal Republican is so afraid of being accused of being communist, he just fires Kern. Guardia as a New Deal Republican is so afraid of being accused of being communist, he just fires Kern. And Carrow notes that until Moses stopped as Parks Commissioner in 1960, no civil service commissioner ever interfered with his hiring practices again. It was just clear.
但又不敢采取任何行动。而且摩西会对手下的其他专员说：“你们应该指派你们的人作为我部门的官方联络员。”然后他会去培植那个员工，基本上把他们变成安插在其他委员会里的内线。所以正如你刚才所说，他太擅长在智力上压制别人了。他擅长霸凌他们。他精通那些我们已经熟知并热爱的种种手段：木桩开道——在获得批准之前就强行开工，等别人开始就此质问时，已经太晚了，工程早就动工了。
He's so good at bullying people. And the only way, maybe if you're powerful enough, you can push back on him. If you stand up to him, maybe he'll back down a little bit, respect your strength. But otherwise, he'll just run all over you. He's supposed to have a there's a weekly luncheon of all the commissioners on the mayor's administration. And Moses hates going to it. He sees a waste of time. So he always sends a potted plant in his place to sit at the lunches. And the commissioner is so mad at him,
左右开弓——他跑到市政府说：“哦，联邦政府说会给我这笔钱，所以你们为什么不也给我一点呢？”然后他又跑到联邦政府说：“哦，市政府会给我这笔钱，所以你们为什么不把剩下的部分也给我呢？”其实他两边都没钱，但他却对双方谎称自己有钱。
but they're afraid of doing anything about it. And Moses would he'd say to the other commissioners, you should designate one of your people as like an official liaison to my department. And then he would cultivate that worker and basically make them his mole in the other commission. So he's just so good at, as you were saying before, out-thinking people. He's good at bullying them. And he's just, he's got all those techniques that we've come to know and love so well. Stake driving, when you start a project before you have permission, by the time they're answering questions about it, it's too late, it's already started.
楔子战术——你跑去问：“我能要一点点钱吗？好，只需要这么一点就够了。”然后一年后，“我还需要更多钱，你们现在必须得给我。”还有欺骗手段，他就是睁眼说瞎话。如果有人告诉他别做什么事，他偏要开始做。他想在布鲁克林建一座滨海公园。他说：“我需要600万美元。”
Whipsawing, you go to the city and you go, oh, the federal government said I would get this money, so why don't you give me a little bit? And then he goes to the federal government and says, oh, the city is gonna give me this money, so why don't you give me the rest of it? He doesn't have the money, but he's telling both sides that he has it.
这就是全部的造价。而当这笔钱花光后，他又说：“我还需要另外600万美元。难道你们要让前面花掉的那600万美元打了水漂吗？就因为你们没有去核实我告诉你们的是不是真的？好吧，如果你想告诉全市民众说你又被摩西给耍了的话——这真的很像那种恶作剧兔子式的把戏。”
Wedge driving, you go, can I have a little bit of money? Okay, that's all it's gonna take. And then a year later, I'm gonna need more money, you have to give it to me now. And deception, he just lies about things. If he's told, don't do something, he starts doing it. He wants to build a Marine Park in Brooklyn. He goes, I need $6 million.
我最喜欢的一个例子是，当他想在兰德尔岛建一个体育场时，他跑到市议会，即估价委员会面前说：“WPA（公共事业振兴署）会出资建设。我不需要市政府出一分钱。”好吧，“我需要25万美元，但这就是整个三元大桥项目将花费市政府的全部资金。”然后他回来又说：“我需要25万美元，但这就是整个三元大桥项目将花费市政府的全部资金。”然后他又回来改口说：“我需要800万美元。”接着他说：“我可没说桥梁引道的地皮钱包含在内。当我说整个项目时，是你们自己理解错了。”
That's the whole cost. And then when that's spent, he goes, I need another $6 million. You're gonna let that last $6 million go to waste? Because you didn't check that what I was telling you was true? All right, if you wanna tell the people of the city that you got tricked by Moses again, like it's such, you know, trickster rabbit type stuff.
你们以为我指的是项目里的一切。如果他们敢顶撞他，他就会破口大骂。他会进行言语虐待，就像他对群众做的那样。群众或许不会逆来顺受，但在这些较小的房间里，这些个人却会默默忍受，尽管名义上他们的权力比他大，但实际上他的权力比他们大。他才是真正的权力经纪人。对的，对的。
My favorite one is when he wants to build a stadium on Randall's Island and he goes to the board of the city, the board of estimate goes, the WPA is going to pay for it. I don't need any money from the city. Well, I need $250,000, but that's all the money that the entire Triborough project is going to cost the city. And then he comes back and he goes, I need $250,000, but that's all the money that the entire Triborough project is going to cost the city." And then he comes back and he goes, I need $8 million. And he goes, I didn't mean the land for the approach roads to the bridge. You were foolish when I said the whole project.
而这正是他权力的源泉所在——他根本不在乎人。他会摧毁他们。他会摧毁，你知道的，就像这些组织内部那些无名的小官僚，以及那些稍微有点名气的专员。但是，他 realmente 根本不在乎城市里的人类。能够按照自己的喜好重写
You thought I meant everything in the project. And if they push back on him, he is abusive. He is verbally abusive in the way he was to crowds. And the crowds wouldn't take it, but these individuals will in these smaller rooms, even though ostensibly they have more power than he does, but really he has more power than they do. He's the power broker. Yeah, yeah.
规则，以及拥有无视规则的自由，这里面蕴含着巨大的力量。就像时不时地，总感觉会冒出这样一个人，大家都会说：“这家伙在完全不同的维度的棋盘上下棋。他比所有人都聪明。”而他们的秘密其实仅仅在于他们不守规矩。仅仅是拒绝按照游戏的规则出牌。只要你被允许抢劫其他玩家，并且，你知道的，随心所欲地在你的地产上免费加盖酒店，你就能赢得《大富翁》游戏的胜利。这就是，你知道的，如果你不按规矩出牌，
And this is just like becomes his source of power is that he does not care about people. He will destroy them. He will destroy, you know, like these sort of somewhat nameless bureaucrats inside these organizations, these somewhat more named commissioners. And, but he really does not care about the humans inside of a city at all. There's an enormous strength in being able to rewrite
赢得游戏就会容易得多。他就是这么干的。没错。而且他还在长岛这些地方建立了自己的政绩档案，因为那里需要应付的发火民众更少。你知道的，你知道的，这些地方的大部分土地都是荒地。
the rules to your liking, but also in having the freedom to ignore the rules. Like every now and then there, it feels like someone comes along and people are like, this guy is playing chess on a whole nother level. Like he's out thinking everybody. And their secret is just that they're being bad. Just refusing to play by the rules of the game. You can win Monopoly if you're allowed to rob the other players and, you know, and like just throw free hotels onto your properties. Like that's, you know, if you don't play by the rules,
土地是有主人的。也许会有偶尔几个被他毫不留情地毁掉的农民。只有偶尔出现的几个小农场主，以及偶尔需要他稍微应付一下的富有权贵。是的，但他现在正在人口稠密的纽约市大兴土木，而这些项目对这些人的生活将产生巨大的影响。
it's a lot easier to win the game. And that's what he does. That's right. And he's also built up his sort of like portfolio of accomplishments in these places like Long Island, where there are fewer people to get angry. You know, like, you know, these places like mostly that land was empty land.
这正引发种种复杂的问题。他就像是一家初创公司什么的。他需要保持那种相同的增长速度。呃，他，他只是有点像是被要求以——也许这只是一种个人野心，就像他注意到规则正在改变，而他能够借以发展的那种轻而易举获取土地的阶段已经被开发到极限了。
It was owned by someone. Maybe there's the occasional farmer that he destroys without any regard. Just the occasional small farmer, the occasional wealthy baron he has to accommodate slightly. Yeah, but now he's building all this stuff in densely populated New York City, where these things have a big effect on what's
他必须不断地，现在他不得不在这些更加复杂的街区里工作，在这些地方，你不能像琼斯海滩那样直接铺设开来，因为那里原本空无一物。这就好比现在那里已经有了许许多多的东西。是的，他成功的秘密在于找到未被使用的土地并加以利用。卡罗在这里花了大量笔墨谈到，你在纽约市是无法做到这一点的。你不能，它是一座城市。
going to happen in these people's lives. And it's just causing a bit of complication. And he's like, he's like a startup or something. Like he needs to go at that same rate of increase. Um, he, he's just sort of like required to go at like maybe it's just some kind of personal ambition, like where he notices the rules are changing and the easy land where he can grow has now been exploited to the extent that it can be.
他将长岛的建设比作在空白画布上作画。而他将纽约市的建设比作在已经存在的壁画上作画。他有一段非常优美的段落，用来描述这幅壁画以及，我只读一小段给你听，因为——因为一幅壁画，它的笔触精细而错综复杂，而且往往当你
And he has to keep, now he has to work in like in these neighborhoods that are more complicated and where you cannot just lay down Jones Beach because nothing is there. It's like now there's lots of stuff there. Yeah, the secret to his success was finding unused land and taking advantage of it. And Carol makes a big, talks a lot about this here that you can't do that in New York City. You can't, it's a city.
仔细端详时，会发现它们十分奇妙，为广阔的城市全景增添了微妙的阴影、精致的色调以及无尽的变化。因此，尽管它拥挤、混乱而丑陋，但它同时也充满了生机，极其人性化。事实上，以至于尽管这幅画整体上可能缺乏美感、秩序、平衡、透视、统合原则以及与其规模相称的整体效果，但它依然拥有许多迷人的小细节，以及一种赋予其独特性的整体活力和生命力，这是不应该失去的。”
And he compares building on Long Island to painting on a blank canvas. And he compares building in New York City to painting in a mural that already exists. And he has this very beautiful section about kind of describing the mural and the, the, the, I'll read you just a little bit of that because, because a mural whose brushstrokes were tiny and intricate and often when one
我觉得这段话太美了，把纽约视为一件非常繁杂的作品的理念：你离它越近，就越能看到其中精美的细节，以及那些你不想失去的东西。但摩西眼里只看得到整块画布，他会想：“好吧，我们在这里修条路。”他直接把一大块油漆涂在了人们的家园、生活和街区之上。而且，你把它比作初创公司，这个类比真是太贴切了，因为很多初创公司，他们的全部意义就在于他们在做一件以前没做过的新事情。
looked closely, quite wonderful, lending to the vast urban panorama, subtle shadings and delicate tints and an endless variety. So that if it was crowded and confused and ugly, it was also full of life and very human. So much so in fact, that while the painting as a whole might lack beauty, order, balance, perspective, a unifying principle and an overall effect to commensurate with its size, it nonetheless possessed many charming little touches and an overall vitality, a brio that made it unique and should not be lost."
也许他们必须快速行动，或者也许他们不得不进行某种过度扩张，因为没有人以前做过这事。感觉其中许多公司当它们变大之后，都会觉得：好吧，现在唯一的增长方式就是接管已经存在的东西，或者获取其客户基础，然后将其货币化。他们不再把这些人当成客户，而是把他们当作针对大公司的产品。感觉摩西做的事几乎正是如此。
I think that's so beautiful, the idea of New York as this really messy piece of work and the closer you get to it, the more you see the beautiful details in it and the things you don't want to lose. But all Moses can see is the full canvas and he's like, well, let's put a road here. Sport just puts a huge thing of paint over people's homes, lives, neighborhoods. And you, you comparing it to a startup is such a good parallel because often a startup will, their whole point is they're doing a new thing that hasn't been done before.
他就像是说：我在这里做过的事，我必须把它做得更大。我原本是在理论上这么做的。我建造了这些公园供人们前来享受。现在我拥有了一个挤满人的地方，我要为那些居住在这个社区之外的人修建道路，在很大程度上是为了他们的便利，而不是为了——为了那些居住在这个社区之外的人的便利，在很大程度上，而不是为了身处其中的人们。那些名义上是我的客户的人，现在他们成了我的——如果还算不上产品的话，至少也是一种障碍。好吧，你举了一个非常棒的类比，
And maybe they have to move fast or maybe they have to kind of overreach because nobody's done this thing before. And it feels like so many of those companies, when they get big, they are like, well, the only way to grow now is to take over something that already exists or to take its customer base and then monetize that. And they stop being their customers and start being their product for larger companies. And it feels like Moses is doing pretty much that.
而我把它给彻底搞砸了。我真的把它弄得、我真的把事情变得过于复杂了，就像一幅美丽的壁画，虽然总体上可能很杂乱，但仍有许多小细节依然很美。卡罗谈到，在长岛，你可以通过修一条路来开发土地用于公共建设。但在城市里，如果你开发了尚未完全开发的土地，
He's like, the thing that I did here, I have to do it bigger. And I did it in theory. I built these parks for people to come and enjoy. Now I have a place that's full of people and I'm going to build roads for the people who live outside of this community for their convenience to a great extent and not for the people who live outside of this community, for their convenience to a great extent, and not for the people who are in it. The people who ostensibly are my customers, they are now my, if not a product, exactly an obstacle. Well, you had a really great parallel
在城市准备好为一个街区提供城市所应提供的各项服务之前，那么这将会导致一团糟。卡罗话锋一转。他说，摩西的冲劲，他把事情办成的冲劲——正是本章标题所指的这种“驾驶”——以及他冲破繁文缛节、强力推进事物的能力，并不一定都是坏事，也不一定是不需要的。一座城市需要建造宏大的工程。它需要把事情办成。它需要有这样一个人，其办事能力即便不是无可置疑的，至少也是极高水平的。它需要有人能够把这些事情造出来。但它必须将人性纳入这些决策中。它必须包含对小群体人们的理解。而摩西要么无法从那种
and I really messed it up. I really got made it, I've really found out how to overcomplicate that, much like a beautiful mural that maybe in the aggregate is messy, but there's lots of little points that are still beautiful. And Kara talks about how in Long Island, you can open up land to public development by running a road there. But in a city, if you open up land that hasn't been fully developed,
更小、更具体的层面去思考，要么根本不在乎。对一个现在习惯于只建造庞然大物的人来说，单个街区的规模毫无意义。他本可以去那个街区问问：“你们需要什么？这里最好的是什么？”但他不想这么做。
before the city is prepared to provide the services that a city provides to a neighborhood, then it's going to lead to a mess. And Caro bounces a little bit. He says that Moses' drive, his drive to get things done, the very driving that is the title of this chapter, and his ability to cut through red tape and to force things are not necessarily bad, and they're not necessarily unneeded, that a city needs to build big things. It needs to get them done. It needs to have someone whose ability to get them done is, if not unquestioned, at least is very high level. It needs someone who's able to make these things. But it needs to include humanity into those decisions. It needs to include an understanding of the smaller groups of people. And Moses either cannot think on that
就像他根本不在乎一样。而且他太专注于积极娱乐的理念了，因为他自己就是个好动的人。他喜欢游泳，你知道的，他喜欢做各种事。以至于对于平静的保护、给某人一个坐下的地方或一个在树荫下纳凉的地方的理念——给那些不只是在开车或干嘛的人留个地方——
smaller granular scale or just doesn't care. Like the scale of a single neighborhood means nothing to a guy who is now used to building only enormous things. And he'd go to that neighborhood and say, what do you need? What's the best thing about this? But he doesn't want to do that.
这些对他来说毫无吸引力。他对保护事物不感兴趣。他只对搞建设感兴趣。在摩西的性格中达到了一定程度，以至于他无法指着一片他保护下来的森林说：“看那个。那难道不是一项成就吗？”因为对他来说那不算。
Like he doesn't care. And he's also so focused on the idea of active recreation because he is an active guy. He likes to swim, you know, he likes to do things. That the idea of peaceful conservation, a place for someone to sit or a place for someone to be in the shade of a tree, someone who's not just driving a car or something,
在他看来，他会觉得：“那可不是我干的。我想那是上帝造的。我要造点别的。我要在那里建个体育场。我要建个露天乐池。我要建点能刻上我名字的东西。”他对建造宏大的东西极其感兴趣。当你面对这样一幅布满精细笔触的壁画时，
that's uninteresting to him. He's not interested in preserving things. He's interested in building things. There's a certain level at most his character where he can't point to a forest that he's preserved and be like, look at that. Isn't that an achievement? Because it's not.
小事其实很重要。就像每一处笔触，小事都很重要，比如一个只有两英亩的小公园对附近的人来说至关重要，但在摩西眼里它却无足轻重。正如卡罗所描述的那种规划天才的时刻，他伸出手拿过一张卷起来的地图并把它展开，
To him, he's like, I didn't do that. I guess God built that. I wanna build something. I'm gonna put a stadium there. I'm gonna put a band shell. I'm gonna put something I could put my name on. He's really interested in building big things. And when you have this mural of intricate brushstrokes,
然后在上面画了起来。他能把宏大的事物看得非常非常清楚，但他对细微的事物却极其盲目。我想这是因为他的灵魂出了点问题。你知道吗？好吧，我要对他的态度稍微好一点。我再来扮演一次理中客。
like little things matter. Like each of those brushstrokes, like little things matter, like each of those brushstrokes matter, and like a tiny park that's only two acres matters a lot to the people right near there, and it just does not matter to Moses. Like when Caro talks about a kind of planning genius that he witnessed where he holds his hand out and gets a rolled up map and he rolls it out
我要说，这是一种类似——我想这叫享乐适应症什么的，即以前觉得新鲜刺激的标准，现在对你来说已经变得稀松平常了。我想随着他不断致力于更大、更大规模的项目，他已经，他只是不再与那些东西产生共鸣了。那些对习以为常了。修建一条迫使成千上万的人流离失所的公路，或者拆毁房屋却对那里的人们漠不关心，对现在的他来说都是习以为常的事，因为他已经对此见怪不怪了。
and he starts drawing on it. He sees big things really, really well, but he's very, very blind to small things. And I think it's because there's something wrong with his soul. You know? I mean, I'm gonna be a little bit nicer to him. I'm gonna play devil's advocate again.
在涉及一个项目、尤其是公共工程项目时，有太多的选择需要做出。它究竟在为谁服务？它是如何为他们服务的？需要满足什么需求？什么需求无法满足？如果驾驶的本质已经变了，如果它不再是为了休闲，
I'm gonna say that it's a sort of like, I think it's called what hedonic adaptation or something where the standard that was new and exciting before becomes normal to you now. And I think as he's, as he's been working on these larger and larger scale things, he has, he just doesn't connect with that stuff. That's normal to him. It's normal to him to build a road that displaces thousands of people or to tear up buildings and not care about the people who are there because he's just gotten so used to it.
如果它是为了从A点到B点，为什么最好的风景应该留给坐在汽车里的人，而不是留给步行的人？一个社区需要的究竟是哪种公园，而不是罗伯特·摩西心血来潮想建哪种公园？所有这些事情都需要被讨论，但摩西对讨论事情毫无兴趣。
There are all these choices that need to be made when it comes to a project and especially a public work. Who is it serving? How is it serving them? What needs need to be met? What needs can't be met? If the nature of driving is different, if it's not about leisure anymore,
过去他还会跟他的员工稍微过过招，在需要讨论时让他们对他的观点提出一点点挑战，但现在摩西对讨论事情全无兴趣。过去他还会跟他的员工稍微过过招，在需要讨论时让他们对他的观点提出一点点挑战，并且他会鞭策他们做到最好。现在他根本不在乎别人的意见。他周围簇拥着的都是唯命是从的马屁精，无论RM说什么，事情就会照着那个方向去发展。卡罗进一步——我觉得他以一种非常美妙而微妙的方式，延续了这种——
if it's about going from point A to point B, why should the best scenery be preserved for people in cars instead of people on foot? And what kind of park does a neighborhood need rather than what kind of park does Robert Moses feel like building? And all that stuff needs to be discussed, but Moses is not interested in discussing things.
比喻或类比，我也不知道，我又不是英语教授。呃，我觉得他以一种非常美妙而微妙的方式，延续了这种比喻或类比，我也不知道，我可不是英语教授，不管它是什么，关于摩西作为艺术家的比喻，他指出摩西是如何将自己与新信息和新想法隔绝开来的。他
And where he used to like kind of spar with his staff a little bit and let them challenge him slightly when it came to be discussed, but most is not interested in discussing things. And where he used to like kind of spar with his staff a little bit and let them challenge him slightly when it came to ideas and he would push them to do their best. Now he just doesn't care about other people's opinions. And he surrounded himself by yes, man, who whatever RM says, that's what it's going to be. And Caro draw, he continues this, I think in a very nice and a very subtle way, he continues this, uh, metaphor of, or analogy, I don't know, I'm not an English professor. Uh, this, I think in a very nice and a very subtle way, he continues this metaphor of or analogy, I don't know, I'm not an English professor, this whatever it is of Moses as an artist by saying how Moses has cut himself off from new information and new ideas. His
将自己理解为“建筑大师”，这一认知横亘在自己与世界之间。如果他能像过去那样，对正在从事的工作投入那种深沉而持久的思考，或许他还能克服这个障碍。当他过去花上几个小时在长岛跋涉、在城市四处奔走，构思各种点子、观察现实生活并思考如何去改善它，而不是只盯着地图看的时候。而他现在再也做不到这一点了。
understanding of himself as the master builder stands between him and the world and he could overcome this obstacle maybe if he was giving the work he was doing the kind of deep sustained thought that he used to. When he was spending hours tromping through Long Island, tromping around the city, thinking of ideas, looking at real life and thinking about how to fix it instead of just looking at maps. And he can't do that anymore.
他没有时间了。他承接了太多的工作。他超负荷了。他包揽了纽约市所有的公园，负责长岛的公园，修建州的康庄大道，建造像尼亚加拉那样的大坝工程。他加了太多的工作，
He doesn't have the time. He's taken on so much work. He's overloaded. He is doing all the New York city parks. He's doing the Long Island parks. He's building the state parkways. He's building his dam work like in Niagara. He's added so much work that,
卡罗提到了这一点，但没有展开细说，那就是到1934年底，他由于工作过度劳累，几乎精神崩溃了。他无法将注意力集中到每一个项目上。因此它们开始变得平庸化。他不再做出个性化的决策，而是采用一套被不断重复使用的标准化表格。就像一个伟大的艺术家失去了与现实、与真实世界的联系，只懂得艺术，他的作品
Carol mentions this, but he doesn't go into detail, that he nearly has a nervous breakdown by the end of 1934, that he's so overworked. And he cannot give his attention to each of these projects. And so they're starting to become banal. Instead of making individual decisions, he has a standardized form that just gets reused. And that like a great artist who loses connection with the reality, with the real world, and only knows art, his work
开始变成了一种自我重复或自我评述，而不再真正关乎人们的生活、需求和情感。这是任何身处创意领域的人都可能会遭遇的事情，而摩西的工作在很大程度上确实具有创意性质。这会发生在任何只了解自己的小泡沫、却永远不肯走出去看看外部世界的人身上。你会发现很多这样的例子，比如电影制作者
starts to become a repetition or a comment on itself rather than something that really relates to the lives and needs and emotions of people. And it's something that happens to anyone who's in a sort of creative field. And Moses is very much working in a creative way. It happens to anyone who only knows their own bubble and doesn't really ever get out of it and see the outside world. And you see a lot in the way that like movie makers
在某个特定阶段开始制作这样的电影：它们感觉更像是关于其他电影的电影，而不是别的。单口喜剧演员开始创作关于普通生活的段落。然后，如果他们变得足够出名，他们所有的表演套路就会变成关于如何成为一个名人、以及身为人名是怎样一种体验。或者，——有人曾向我指出，如果你按顺序阅读斯蒂芬·金的书，书中的角色会从某种蓝领普通人逐渐变成作家，然后是大学教授，这种转变，
at a certain point start making movies that feel more like they're about other movies than they are. Standup comedians will start doing jokes about ordinary life. And then if they get famous enough, all their routines become about being a famous person and what it's like to be famous. Or, uh, it was pointed out to me once that, uh, if you read Stephen King's books in order, the characters go from being kind of like blue collar ordinary people to being like writers and then college professors, like this, which at one point,
在某种程度上是可以理解的。你与你那段历史的那部分失去了联系。所以你不再从中获得灵感。但这并不意味着——我不是在说斯蒂芬·金。他依然产出伟大的作品——而是说罗伯特·摩西的工作与现实的联系越来越少，而与他关于公园是什么的先入为主的概念
to a certain point makes sense. You lose touch with that part of your history. And so you're no longer inspired by it. But it means that, I'm not saying this about Stephen King. He still comes out with great work, but that Robert Moses' work is less and less connected to reality and more and more just connected to his pre-conceived notions
的联系越来越多。是的，没错。就像他的观念几乎没有演变过一样。与他关于公园是什么的先入为主的概念的联系越来越多。是的，没错。就像他的观念几乎没有演变过一样。他在一开始确实有些好点子，也有了施展身手的画布。他有实现这一切的独创性。而现在这些已经不再具备，
about what a park is. Yeah, that's right. Like it hasn't evolved much at all. connected to his pre-conceived notions about what a park is. Yeah, that's right. Like it hasn't evolved much at all. Like he had some good ideas in the beginning and he had the canvas to make it. He had the ingenuity to make it all happen. And now that's not available,
但他的想法却根本没有修正或改变过。就像城市已经发生了巨大的变化，但他却没有变。因此这就好比，他对解决这些问题毫无兴趣。他对细节毫无兴趣。当琼斯海滩正在设计时，他对给那些来到这些公园的人带来欢乐毫无兴趣，就像他当年所做的那样。
but his ideas have not modified or changed at all. Like the city has changed a lot, but he hasn't changed. And therefore it's just like, he's not interested in solving these problems. He's not interested in the details. He's not interested in providing gaiety to people who arrive at these parks like he did when Jones Beach was being designed.
这简直就像是：他拥有了有史以来最大的权力来把事情办成，但他与自己正在做的工作之间的脱节却是如此巨大，以至于导致了更多这种混乱的、考虑不周的、甚至是残酷的决策不断出炉。是的，我们将在后面的章节中看到，我们将看到他是如何通过他的建设工作
It just is like, he has the most power he's ever had to get things done. And his disconnect with the job he's doing is so much greater that it makes more of this just messy, thoughtless, even cruel decisions are being made. Yeah, and we'll see in later chapters, we'll see how he's really destroying people's lives
真正毁掉人们的生活的。但卡罗在这里甚至还提到了许多小事情。他提到他在城市公园里使用了与长岛公园相同的规划设计——在长岛，人们是开车去公园的，而不是针对小型的公园和游乐场。所以他设计了台阶，而在城市里，如果你是一个带着婴儿的父母——卡罗说的是母亲，因为这本书是50年前写的，但我会说是父母。现在，
through his construction of work. But there are even little things that Carol mentions here. He mentions how he uses the same design for parks in the city that he would use for parks in Long Island where people are gonna drive to the parks rather than small parks and playgrounds. So he has steps where in the city, if you're a parent with a baby, Carol says mothers because this book was written 50 years ago, but I would say parents. Now,
如果你推着婴儿车或童车，你就得对付所有这些台阶，因为在长岛的公园里，你是开车把孩子送到那儿的，然后直接抱出来到处走，或者由他们自己走。但在城市里，你需要推着婴儿车。这意味着，这只是一个小小的例子：这些公园根本不是为了实际使用它们的人而设计的，因为摩西只是在机械地重复他过去一遍又一遍做过的事情，就像你经常听到的那样，大厨们在开餐厅时，端出的往往是他们多年来一直在做的那些老掉牙的菜品。新的创意在哪里呢？部分原因也在于，你在城市之外可以做一些更具奇思妙想的事情，但在城市里则不行。卡罗谈到，当摩西重新改造中央公园时，早期的中央公园游乐场要更有奇思妙想，但这意味著你拥有了所有这些隐蔽的空间，供动物或变态狂在那个空间里做他们想做的事，这可不是什么好事，
if you're pushing your baby in a baby carriage or a stroller, you got to deal with all these steps because in a Long Island park, you drive your kid there in a car and you just take them out and carry them around or they walk. But in the city, you need to be pushing a carriage. And it means that these, it's just a small instance of these parks are not being designed for the people who are actually using them because Moses is just repeating the same things he's been doing over and over again, much like a, you hear a lot with chefs, I guess, when they open a restaurant and they're like, oh, it's just the same slate of dishes they've been doing for years. Where's the new ideas? And part of that is also, you can do more whimsical stuff outside of a city than you can in a city. And Carol talks about how the early Central Park playgrounds, when Moses was redoing Central Park, were much more whimsical, but it meant you had all these kind of hidden spaces for animals or perverts to do what they wanted to do with the space, which was not great,
这并不是当时需要做的事情。卡罗在这部分的文风略显重复，但我认为这种重复是有目的的：他向你展示了关于摩西局限性的类似想法的细微变体，几乎就像他也在一笔一笔地叠加着油漆的图层，在你的脑海中构建这个论点，直到章节结束时，你已经完全理解他在谈论什么了，而不是仅仅陈述完就直接跳过。他真的是在反复敲打这个核心观点。
which was not what needed to be done. And Carol's style throughout this section is a little repetitive, but I think in a way that's purposeful, where he is giving you slight variations on kind of similar ideas about Moses's limitations here, almost as if he is also laying down brushstroke after brushstroke layers of paint to kind of build up this argument in your mind until by the end of the chapter, you're fully understand what he's talking about, you know, rather than just stating it and then moving on. He's really hammering it home.
而他在这里开始反复强调、并将在下一集进行更深入探讨的事情是：摩西不仅对单个街区以及个人如何反应不感兴趣，他个人尤其对某种特定类型的人不感兴趣。用一个不太恰当的词来形容，那种人就是穷人。用一个不太恰当的词来形容，那种人就是穷人。而那种人，用一个不太恰当的词来形容，就是黑人或波多黎各人。他指出，有那么多机会可以在贫民区
And the thing that he starts to hammer home here, which we'll talk about in even more depth next episode, is that Moses is not just uninterested in individual neighborhoods and how individuals react. He's particularly personally uninterested in a certain type of person. And that person is, for lack of a better word, poor. And that type of person person is for lack of a better word, poor. And that type of person is for lack of a better word, black or Puerto Rican. He's making the point that there are all these opportunities to build these small parks in slum
修建这些小公园，在那些人们没有钱的地区，或者在非白人占多数人口的地区，而城市的黑人人口增长得非常快。1900年时有6万人。到1940年，就在我们现在讨论的这个时期刚结束时，这一数字达到了458,000人。城市人口的那一部分，那些居民，被排斥在经济和娱乐生活的主流之外。他们没有城市其他地方现在正视为理所当然的东西——而摩西此时正在把公园和游乐场到处洒满城市的各个角落。
areas, in areas where people don't have money or in areas where there is a majority non-white population and the black population of the city has grown very quickly. In 1900, it's 60,000 people. In 1940, right after the period we're talking about now, it's 458,000 people. And that part of the city's population, those residents, are shut out of much of the mainstream of economic and recreational life. They do not have the things that the rest of the city is taking for granted now that Moses is sprinkling parks and playgrounds all over the place.
这些人感到自己在这个城市现在拥有公园和游乐场的那些地方不受欢迎。他们需要玩耍的地方。我想在下一章更深入地探讨这一点，因为卡罗在其中提到了更多细节。但摩西对为他们提供这些服务、为他们的孩子提供玩耍的地方毫无兴趣。这意味着那些地区的穷苦孩子被迫在街头玩耍，在那些对他们来说不安全、肮脏或危险的地方玩耍。
And these are people who feel unwelcome in the parts of the city that now have parks and playgrounds. They need places to play. I want to talk about this more next chapter because Carol brings it up in more detail. But Moses is not interested in providing those services to them, in providing their children with places to play. And this means that the kids in those areas are forced to play in the streets, play in places that are not safe for them, that are dirty or dangerous,
这些人感到自己在这个城市新修建了公园和游乐场的区域里不受欢迎。他们需要玩耍的地方。我想在下一章中更多地讨论这一点，因为卡罗尔更详细地提到了它。但摩西对为他们提供这些服务、为他们的孩子提供玩耍的地方并不感兴趣。这意味着这些地区的儿童被迫在街头玩耍，在对他们不安全、肮脏或危险的地方玩耍，
but it sends the message to that large part of the city's population that the city does not care about them. And the reformers who are now kind of turning on Moses slightly, a little bit at a time, they see that Moses has effectively barred poor black New Yorkers from his parks through their lack of public transportation going to them. And now he won't even provide little parks in
但这向城市大部分居民传递了一个信息，即这个城市并不在乎他们。那些现在开始有点反对摩西、一点一点转变看法的改革派们发现，摩西实际上通过没有通往这些公园的公共交通，将贫穷的纽约黑人拒之公园门外。现在他甚至不愿在
their neighborhoods for them. He's just not interested in doing it. And Moses push backs a little bit and he says, well, they can always go to Randall's Island or Riverside Park. And he also says, eh, the smallest a park should be is three acres. It's not really financial sense to make a park
他们的社区里为他们建造小型公园。他根本对此不感兴趣。摩西对此进行了小小的反击，他说，他们随时可以去兰德尔岛或河滨公园。他还说，公园的最小面积应该是三英亩。建造一个
that's smaller than three acres. And the reformers are like, uh, but you could make one that's smaller than three acres. Yeah, we could do that, uh, but you could make one that's smaller than three acres. It would be nice. You could do it. It's possible. And also that because Moses doesn't want bus service to Reynolds Island where he has these
小于三英亩的公园在经济上是不划算的。而改革派则觉得，呃，但你完全可以建造一个小于三英亩的公园啊。是的，我们可以做到，呃，但你完全可以建造一个小于三英亩的公园。那样会很好。你能做到的。这是可能的。而且由于摩西不希望有巴士服务通往他拥有这些
facilities, he says that black New Yorkers can go to. It means that to get there from Harlem or the South Bronx, where much of New York's black population is centered, you have to walk anywhere from three quarters of a mile to two miles. And it's, it's an, it's, that's an insane idea to say that, yeah, they've got park facilities. They just have to walk two miles to get to them in one of the most crowded cities
设施的兰德尔岛（他说纽约黑人可以去那里），这意味着从哈林区或南布朗克斯（纽约黑人人口集中的地方）出发去那里，你必须步行四分之三英里到两英里不等。而且这，这简直是一个荒谬的想法，说什么，是的，他们有公园设施。他们只是必须步行两英里才能到达，在这个美国最拥挤的城市之一。
in the United States of America. Cause it's not like it's a pleasant walk for all that time. I mean, to be honest, I like walking through cities. So it would be, I mean, in some ways it's a pleasant walk, but they're not walking through the best areas probably. You don't do it daily after school. You don't walk two miles to get to a park. Yeah. Or we're on a weekend when you've been working all week
因为这可不是那种全程都很愉快的散步。我的意思是，老实说，我喜欢穿过城市散步。所以，从某种程度上说，这是一次愉快的散步，但他们可能并不是在最好的区域散步。你不会每天放学后都这么走。你不会为了去公园而步行两英里。是的，或者在周末，当你整整工作了一周
and your children wanna go play, it's hard to get up and you have to bring, I mean, if you've gone any, you've gone plays with children, Roman, you gotta bring food with you, you gotta bring stuff for them to do. It's like the storming of Normandy, yeah, it sucks. Yeah, it's the worst. Bringing children anywhere.
而你的孩子们想去玩的时候，你很难振作起来，而且你还得带——我的意思是，罗曼，如果你和孩子们去过任何地方玩的话，你得随身带食物，你得带让他们玩的东西。这就像诺曼底登陆一样，是的，糟透了。是的，太糟糕了。带着孩子去任何地方。
And the press will, they'll print the letters to the editor of these reformers about this stuff, but they'll also print Moses' rebuttals and they won't put their editorial support, the idea of slum parks, of need it. Yeah. And you were getting at this point now where Moses had the support of a lot of reformers because he was preserving all this woodland around the city. And they were like, he's doing it. Yeah. And now they're watching as he is cutting down that woodland. Like he's chopping it down to replace it with ball fields and things like that.
而媒体会刊登这些改革派关于这些事情的读者来信，但他们也会刊登摩西的反驳，并且他们不会把社论支持给贫民窟公园的概念、对它的需求。是的。而且你现在达到了这样一个点：摩西得到了许多改革派的支持，因为他在城市周围保留了所有这些林地。他们当时的想法是，他在做这件事。是的。而现在他们眼睁睁地看着他砍伐这些林地。就像他把它们砍掉，用来换取球场之类的地方一样。
And they're only starting to realize again, it's like that, and this happens throughout the book and it is very frustrating. And I don't know if it's how it happened in real life or it's the way Caro organized it. But the reformers are always like, wait a minute, he did this thing.
而他们才刚刚开始意识到——这就像那样，而且这在整本书中一直发生，这非常令人沮丧。我不知道这到底是现实生活中发生的，还是卡罗组织的方式。但改革派总是觉得，等一下，他做了这件事。
Maybe he's not so great. So like he tore down the casino. That wasn't so great. Now he's cutting down these forests. Wait a minute. That's not so great. Later we'll see him attack a genuinely historically important building. Yeah.
也许他没那么伟大。比如他拆除了赌场。那可没那么伟大。现在他正在砍伐这些森林。等一下。那可没那么伟大。后来我们会看到他攻击一栋真正具有历史重要性的建筑。是的。
And, uh, for no real reason. And they're like, wait a minute, that's not so great. And Carol says here that no one was putting the pieces together that this is an overall overarching ideology for Moses Moses because they're kind of, they're still enthralled to his image, but also they're only really paying attention to their local parks. They don't see that the same thing is happening all over. And they probably have the same blind spots that he has. I mean,
而且，呃，毫无真正的理由。他们的反应是，等一下，那可没那么伟大。卡罗在这里说，没有人把这些碎片拼凑起来，意识到这是摩西的一种全面且首要的意识形态，因为他们某种程度上仍然被他的形象所倾倒，而且他们也只真正关注自己当地的公园。他们没有看到同样的事情正在各地发生。而且他们可能有着和他一样的盲点。我的意思是，
they're probably not aware of people that are different from them. And they, you know, they see the good parts of them of him and they don't have to experience the bad parts of him because he's not running a road through their house. He's not putting up parks in their neighborhoods. They just probably just don't really connect with the suffering that he's causing even at this point. But they will. Not yet.
他们可能并不了解与他们不同的人。而且他们，你知道，他们看到了他好的一面，却不必经历他糟糕的一面，因为他没有在他们家门前修路。他没有在他们的社区里建公园。他们可能只是无法真正体会到他正在造成的痛苦，即使在这一点上也是如此。但他们会的。还没有。
But look, he put roads through the other neighborhoods and I said nothing because it wasn't my neighborhood. And then he tore down a park in this other neighborhood and I didn't say anything. I really should have had the details for this thing before I said it. Anyway, eventually it came for me. That's the end. Eventually it came for my neighborhood, which does happen, which starts to happen. And as we'll see, that's when the turning point doesn't come until years later when he does start doing things in middle-class neighborhoods that have kind of a louder,
但你看，他在其他社区修了路，而我什么也没说，因为那不是我的社区。然后他在另一个社区拆了一个公园，我什么也没说。我在说这件事之前，真的应该先把细节搞清楚的。不管怎样，最终它还是找上了我。这就是结局。最终它找上了我的社区，这确实发生了，开始发生了。正如我们所看到的，转折点要到几年后才会出现，那时他才开始在那些拥有更大、
more powerful voice. But they also, this is also one of their flaws is they have the classic flaw of all liberals. All liberals have this flaw. I have it, Roman, I don't know you super well, but I'm sure you have it too. I probably do.
更有力量的声音的中产阶级社区做事。但他们也有，这也是他们的缺点之一，他们有着所有自由派的经典缺陷。所有自由派都有这个缺陷。我有，罗曼，我不太了解你，但我确信你也有。我可能确实有。
This belief that if I just sat down and discussed this with him and just explained to him why this was not gonna work, he would say, oh yeah, you're right. I will, I was wrong to do that. We will do it the other way. Let's come to a compromise. Whenever anyone's like, we need a national conversation on this, as if a conversation has ever made anything better. It almost never does. But they're like, if we can just discuss this with him, if we can just get in there and talk to him about it, we're sure we could show him the truth.
这种信念认为，如果我只是坐下来和他讨论这件事，并向他解释为什么这行不通，他就会说：“哦，是的，你是对的。我错了，我不该那样做。我们会换个方式做。让我们达成妥协吧。”每当有人说“我们需要对此进行一场全国性对话”时，就好像对话曾经让事情变得更好过一样。它几乎从来没有。但他们的想法是，如果我们能和他讨论这件事，如果我们能进去和他谈谈，我们确信能向他展示真相。
And that's how Caro leads into the end of the chapter, which is chilling, he says. But Moses no longer had to discuss. He had long had great dreams for the city, and now he had learned how to make dreams come true. He had learned the technique of stake driving and of whipsawing. He had learned how to mislead and conceal and deceive, how to lie to men and bully them, how to ruin their reputations. And he used all these methods to bring the dream to reality. And then there's a little space, indent, indent, indent. Or was it all for the dream?
这就是卡罗如何引向这一章的结尾，这是令人不寒而栗的，他说。但摩西不再需要讨论了。长期以来，他对这座城市怀有伟大的梦想，而现在他已经学会了如何让梦想成真。他学会了打桩和拉锯的技巧。他学会了如何误导、隐瞒和欺骗，如何对人撒谎和欺凌，如何毁掉他们的声誉。他用尽了所有这些方法，将梦想变为现实。然后是一小段空白，缩进，缩进，缩进。这一切难道都是为了梦想吗？
And that's how he ends that chapter. That's how chapter 24 driving ends and is where this section ends. Was it for the dream or are there darker desires? Well, the next part, part five is entitled the love of power So that's a little spoiler. I think that tells you what it's about We'll cover the love of power on the next episode. That's only two chapters It's pages 499 to 606 chapters 25 and 26
这就是他结束那一章的方式。这就是第二十四章《驱使》的结束，也是这一部分结束的地方。这是为了梦想，还是有着更黑暗的欲望？好吧，下一部分，第五部分题为《对权力的渴望》。所以这是一个小小的剧透。我想这告诉你它是关于什么的。我们将在下一集讨论对权力的渴望。这只有两章，页码从499到606，即第二十五章和第二十六章。
You may be wondering how only two chapters can be a longer section of the book than the one we covered in this episode One of them is a very long chapter It's only two chapters, but it feels like a Robert Moses type thing to be like, it's only two chapters. By the way, one of those chapters is 75 pages long. I didn't tell you that, but they're very good chapters. I'm very excited about the next episode. Coming up, our conversation with investigative journalist, Brandi Zdrosny.
你可能在想，为什么只有两章的篇幅会比我们这一集涵盖的部分还要长？其中有一章非常长。虽然只有两章，但感觉很像罗伯特·摩西的风格，就像是：只有两章。顺便说一句，其中一章长达75页。我之前没告诉你，但它们是非常棒的章节。我对下一集非常兴奋。即将播出的是我们与调查记者布兰迪·兹德罗斯尼的对话。
Brandi Zdrosny. Our Power Broker Book Club guest for this week is Brandi Zdrosny. I am a reporter for NBC News. I cover misinformation, disinformation, extremism, the internet, platforms, politics, people. It sort of runs the gambit. Brandi mostly works on longer investigative pieces where her research background as a reference librarian comes in handy. One of her recent stories is about how a far-right sheriff's group is urging local law enforcement agencies to investigate baseless claims of voter fraud. She also hosted this great podcast called Tiffany Dover is Dead about a nurse in Tennessee
布兰迪·兹德罗斯尼。我们本周的《权力掮客》读书俱乐部嘉宾是布兰迪·兹德罗斯尼。我是全国广播公司新闻（NBC News）的记者。我报道虚假信息、造谣、极端主义、互联网、平台、政治、人物。可以说是包罗万象。布兰迪主要负责较长的调查性报道，她在其中发挥了作为参考馆员的研究背景优势。她最近的一篇报道是关于一个极右翼治安官组织如何敦促地方执法机构调查毫无根据的选民欺诈指控。她还主持了一个名为《蒂凡尼·多夫死了》的精彩播客，讲述了田纳西州的一名护士，
who passed out on live television after receiving the COVID vaccine in December of 2020 and then became the center of an anti-vax conspiracy. It's really compelling stuff and infuriating and compelling at the same time. Somehow Brandi also found time to read The Power Broker. What struck me about this book from the beginning was I knew who Robert Carrow was. I had never read his books, but I know a little bit about his story. And so the very first thing is just, it's kind of, he's realizing a dream for so many of us. You know, like the idea of turning every page is a real luxury. And so, you know, he, I think he started this series because he was a reporter on Long Island, right? He was doing a story on some piece of infrastructure and then he thought,
她在2020年12月接种新冠疫苗后在电视直播中昏倒，随后成为反疫苗阴谋的中心。这真的是引人入胜的内容，同时又令人愤怒又引人入胜。不知何故，布兰迪还抽空阅读了《权力掮客》。这本书从一开始就让我震惊的是，我知道罗伯特·卡罗是谁。我从未读过他的书，但我对他的故事略知一二。所以最重要的一点是，这有点像，他正在为我们许多人实现一个梦想。你知道，就像翻阅每一页的想法都是一种真正的奢侈。所以，你知道，他，我想他开始这个系列是因为他曾是长岛的一名记者，对吧？他在做一个关于某项基础设施的故事，然后他想，
wow, that's really strange. You know, how did this guy amass all this power? And we have a million questions like that when doing any story, right? But you never really get the time to keep going. You're sort of onto the next story or onto the next beat of that story and no one has the time to turn every page. So the fact that he said, I'm going to and did the thing for however many years, it took him to do that. It's just, it's so aspirational. And then when you get in it from the very beginning, you're like, he's gonna do this thing. Like there is nothing left.
哇，这真奇怪。你知道，这个人是怎么积累起所有这些权力的？我们在做任何报道时都有成百万个类似的问题，对吧？但你永远没有时间继续追查下去。你差不多就要进入下一个故事，或者该故事的下一个节点，没有人有时间翻阅每一页。所以事实上他说，我要这么做，并且不管花了他多少年时间，他真的把这件事做成了。这太令人向往了。然后当你从一开始就投入其中时，你会觉得，他要把这件事做成。就像什么都没落下一样。
And it's just great. You're saying you would love to come to your editor and say, I have this story, it's amazing. And they say, how long is it gonna take me to work on the story? And you say, seven years. And for them to say, yes, go for it. And then you go and talk to your spouse and you say,
这太棒了。你是说你会很想去找你的编辑说，我有一个故事，太棒了。然后他们会说，我需要花多长时间来做这个故事？然后你说，七年。然后他们会说，好的，放手去做吧。接着你去找你的配偶说，
okay, we're gonna sell the house and we're gonna get real poor for a time period. For a long time. And then it's going to pay off because a bunch of nerds are going to talk about it 50 years later. Well, my, my conversation with my editor is always like, how many words do you think this is going to be Brandi?
好吧，我们要把房子卖了，然后在一段时间内变得非常穷。很长一段时间。然后这一切都会得到回报，因为一群书呆子会在50年后谈论它。好吧，我和编辑的对话总是像，布兰迪，你觉得这会有多少字？
And I'm like, 10,000. She's like, try five. And then, you know, you get into a place where you're like, ha ha, I snuck six. And that's like, try five. And then you get into a place where you're like, ha ha, I snuck six and that's like a big win. I can't even imagine being able to do that. And also the details that I think are so interesting about these stories are often cut by my editor,
然后我说，1,0000字。她说，试试5,000字。然后，你知道，你进入了一个状态，你会想，哈哈，我塞进去了6000字，那就像是——试试5000字。然后，你知道，你进入了一个状态，你会想，哈哈，我塞进去了6000字，这就像是一场巨大的胜利。我甚至无法想象自己能够做到这一点。而且我认为这些故事中非常有趣的细节，经常被我的编辑删掉，
who's like, eh, superfluous, boring. And it's like, but that's what the fun thing is, that's really interesting. Yeah. And interesting doesn't always make it into the final cut. I mean, a lot of what Robert Caro is doing, and I don't know if he just intuited this or this is the writer he is, he is about building a gestalt through lots of information
编辑会说，呃，多余的，无聊的。然后就会觉得，但这正是有趣的地方啊，这真的很有趣。是的。而且有趣并不总能进入最终剪辑。我的意思是，罗伯特·卡罗在做的很多事情——我不知道他是凭直觉做到的，还是他本身就是这种作家——他致力于通过大量的信息来构建一个完形，
so that you, like, it sort of fills in your foundation. And then when he's making his really bold case, which is like changing the mind of a bunch of people who think this man is a saint for decades of his professional existence. Well, narratives are really strong and people don't read. I mean, I say that, you know, with a heavy sigh, because I will write some, you know,
这样你就会，就像，它某种程度上填补了你的基础。然后当他提出真正大胆的论点时——比如改变一群几十年来一直认为这个人是圣人的专业人士的看法——好吧，叙事非常强大，人们不读书。我的意思是，我带着沉重的叹息说这句话，因为我会写一些，你知道的，
revelatory piece on someone that really pulls the mask off who they are. And then the next day they're sitting in front of a house judiciary committee and I'm like, don't you know who this is? I told you. So I can only imagine someone with sort of the heft and reputation that Moses had just that not getting through
关于某人的启示性文章，真正揭开了他们是谁的面具。然后第二天他们坐在众议院司法委员会前，我就会想，难道你不知道这是谁吗？我已经告诉你了。所以我只能想象，像摩西那样拥有分量和声誉的人，在事情发生之前，这种声音根本无法传达进去。
until this thing happened. Mm-hmm. So when you investigate things, I mean, I suppose like a lot of, since you cover stuff sort of in the modern era of misinformation and lots of online things, your archive is the world of the internet and then talking to people and stuff like this. How did it strike you when you picture Robert Caro in these basements on Randall's Island and things like this? Does this make you feel envious? Do you like, or does it make you just admire it? What is your take on it?
嗯。所以当你调查事情的时候，我的意思是，我想很多，既然你报道的事情有点处于现代错误信息和大量网络事件的时代，你的档案就是互联网世界，然后与人交谈诸如此类的事情。当你想象罗伯特·卡罗坐在兰德尔岛的这些地下室里以及类似的地方时，你有什么感想？这会让你感到嫉妒吗？你会喜欢，还是只会让你感到钦佩？你是怎么看的？
So I was actually thinking about this last night as I was trying to remind myself of what happened in the chapters that y'all are going to discuss. And I just started looking through the New York Times time machine because they have all their archives up. And so I was looking at like, you know, in the 30s, like what were the letters to the editor and all this stuff. And I was just thinking, I was literally thinking, oh, he must have been like in a library for this. Or like he must have been in the stacks. That's so interesting. And I also thought, because I did a pretty clean sweep in a couple hours before bed.
所以我昨晚其实在想这个，当时我正试图提醒自己你们要讨论的那些章节里发生了什么。然后我开始翻阅《纽约时报》时光机，因为他们把所有的档案都上线了。所以我一直在查阅，比如，你知道，在30年代，读者来信都是什么样的，诸如此类的事情。我当时就在想，我简直在想，哦，他一定是为了这个待在图书馆里什么的。或者他一定是在故纸堆里。这太有趣了。我还想到，因为我在睡觉前花了几个小时做了相当彻底的检索。
And that's really great that we have the opportunity to do that. But so much is lost because we think everything is online. Like there are a lot of things that if you just walk down to the courthouse, I was doing a story on Trump in 2016 and walked down to the New the courthouse, I was doing a story on Trump in 2016 and walked down to the New York courthouse, the New York City courthouse, and got a large portion of his divorce records, which we weren't supposed to get. But because it was a real person, you know, and there were real papers, we got a bunch of things. And I remember for that story, specifically a friend at a different outlet wanted to go down to the courthouse,
我们有机会做到这一点，这真的很棒。但很多东西都丢失了，因为我们以为一切都在网上。就像有很多事情，如果你走到法院去——我在2016年做一个关于特朗普的报道时，曾走到纽约法院，当时我在做关于特朗普2016年的报道，然后走到了纽约法院，纽约市法院，并拿到了他很大一部分离婚记录，这是我们本不该得到的。但因为这是一个真实的人，你知道，而且有真实的纸质文件，我们拿到了很多东西。我记得对于那个报道，特别是另一个媒体的一个朋友想去法院，
but they wouldn't let her leave her desk. And it was like, oh, you can still get so much by using those sort of old school reporting techniques and going to the place and trying to get the things. Yeah, I think that's really true. That's so much fun to think about. And that's what I love. I mean, just the excitement of that hunt
但他们不让她离开办公桌。这就好像是，哦，你仍然可以通过使用那些老派的报道技术，去到那个地方并试图弄到那些东西，从而获得那么多的信息。是的，我认为这真的很真实。思考这些真是太有趣了。而这正是我所热爱的。我的意思是，仅仅是那种搜寻的兴奋感
is like so enjoyable, especially when it takes place in a physical location when you're opening up files and stuff like that. Like I just love archive research so much. Yeah. The scariest part of a story is not having one. And once you have a story that you're like, this is a story that I'm working on, and you can just dig and dig and dig and dig and dig. Like that's all the fun stuff, that needing a story and then actually writing the story,
就如此令人享受，尤其是当它发生在实体地点、当你打开文件之类的时候。我就是非常喜欢档案研究。是的。报道中最可怕的部分是没有报道。而一旦你有了这样一个报道，你会觉得，这是一个我正在做的报道，然后你可以不断地挖掘、挖掘、挖掘、挖掘、挖掘。所有这些都是有趣的部分，而需要一个报道然后真正去写这个报道，
that's what terrifies me. The rest is the best part. That's what Kara told us. Kara told us basically that if he could get away with just doing all the research and not writing the book, he'd be very happy. If he could just do the research all the time. Yeah, I had an editor who refused to let me talk to him about my work when I'd be like,
那才是我感到害怕的地方。其余的都是最好的部分。卡罗就是这么对我们说的。卡罗基本上告诉我们，如果他能只做所有的调研而不写这本书，他会非常高兴。如果他能一直做调研的话。是的，我曾有一个编辑拒绝让我跟他谈论我的工作，每当我想要说的时候，
oh my gosh, he's like, nope, because once you say it, once you communicate it, then you won't get it out. You won't write the thing. And they were right. So this episode, we talk about a lot how Moses has great success using the press to get what he wants. And the one thing, the mainly thing that he does is he just puts out kind of press releases
哦天哪，他会说，不，因为一旦你把它说出口，一旦你把它交流出来，你就无法把它表达出来了。你不会去写那个东西。而他是对的。所以这一集里，我们深入探讨了摩西如何通过成功利用媒体来达到他的目的。而他做的一件事，主要做的一件事，就是他只是发布了某种新闻稿，
or he has lots of familiarity with a lot of press people. And his story becomes the story. I'm just, I'm curious about this. Like when you're, you talk or you report on sort of like how a mainstream media outlet, you know, like reports a thing, how a citizen journalist in quotes reports a thing, you know, what does it strike you about like that time period
或者他与许多新闻界人士非常熟悉。他的故事就成为了那个故事。我只是，我对此很好奇。比如当你在，你谈论或者报道主流媒体机构是如何报道一件事的，所谓的公民记者是如何报道一件事的，你知道，关于那个时代，你有什么感想？
and how information is spread and how the press is used in these ways? I think it still works that way for the most part. I mean, when you go to a website or when you open the paper, you're mostly reading commodity news. You're mostly reading the kind of news that like you get anywhere because a thing has happened. You know, there is a unveiling, there is a crime,
信息是如何传播的，媒体又是如何以这些方式被利用的？我认为在很大程度上它仍然是那样运作的。我的意思是，当你访问一个网站或打开报纸时，你主要阅读的是同质化新闻。你主要阅读的是那种你在任何地方都能得到的新闻，因为事情已经发生了。你知道，有一个揭幕仪式，有一场犯罪，
there is a, you know, so like, and the police have told the police beat reporter about that crime. Like you get into this rhythm as a reporter where you're like, this is my beat, these are the sources for my beat and here is how I report that out day to day. And especially if you're in a paper, if you're like, this is my beat. This is, these are the sources for my beat. And here's how I report that out day to day. And especially if you're in a paper, if you're
有一个，你知道的，所以就像，警察已经把那个犯罪情况告诉了警察口记者。作为一名记者，你会进入这样一种节奏：这是我的跑口，这些是我跑口的消息来源，这就是我日复一日报道这件事的方式。特别是如果你在一家报纸工作，如果你在——这是我的跑口。这些是我的跑口消息来源。这就是我日复一日报道这件事的方式。特别是如果你在一家报纸工作，如果你在
broadcasting where you have to have something every single day, like you have to fill that space. Then you rely on these people that you know are good for factual stories that people like and your editors like. And so like, I don't think that that has changed much. There are still.
进行广播，你必须每天都有内容，就像你必须填补那个空间一样。那么你就会依赖于那些你知道能提供事实故事的人，大家喜欢，你的编辑也喜欢。所以，我认为这并没有太大改变。仍然有
And so I don't think that that has changed much. There are still bazillions of publicists who make their living on getting a story to a reporter who takes that press release and writes it up and makes it a story. So that's not very different at all. What's funny about this book and what is leading, I think, to your question is that it feels very today, all of it, the way that he manipulates the press with these events,
所以，我认为这并没有太大改变。仍然有无数的公关人员，他们以将故事送到记者手中为生，记者采用该新闻稿并将其写成报道，使其成为一个新闻故事。所以这根本没有太大不同。这部书有趣的地方以及导致——我想——你提出这个问题的原因是，这一切都感觉非常符合当今时代，他利用这些事件操纵媒体的方式，
with, you know, leaking to them, with, you know, befriending them and bringing them to nice events, like that, with the way the New York Times operates, like all of this feels very of the moment. And it's like, he used it to such great effect. I mean, like, you know, Moses in this moment has just spectacularly lost running for governor. Like, just is completely on his ass.
通过，你知道，向他们泄密，通过，你知道，与他们交朋友并带他们去参加美好的活动，就像那样，《纽约时报》运作的方式，所有这一切都感觉非常符合当下。而且感觉就像是：他如此有效地利用了这一点。我的意思是，就像，你知道，摩西在这一刻刚刚在竞选州长中惨败——就像，简直是彻底栽了。
And FDR concocts this order 129 to do this sort of final blow and take him out. And Moses leaks that to the press, and it totally revives his career, which sets up the entire rest of the book. I mean, it really is like his resurrection that makes him stronger than ever. And that comes about because the press
而罗斯福精心策划了这项129号行政命令，来进行这致命一击并将他除名。而摩西把这个消息泄露给媒体，彻底复苏了他的职业生涯，这为整本书的其余部分奠定了基础。我的意思是，这真的就像他的复活，让他比以往任何时候都强大。而这之所以发生，是因为媒体
just take Moses's side of this at face value. Moses seems to discover that like, yeah, that newspapers need material. They need things to print. And so if he can provide that in the form of press releases or leaked documents, or we're opening a park, we're opening a pool, then they're not going to say, uh, let's double check this before we actually put it in the newspaper. You know?
只是按字面意思接受了摩西的这一方说法。摩西似乎发现，就像，是的，报纸需要素材。它们需要东西来印刷。所以如果他能以新闻稿或泄露文件的形式提供这些，或者我们正在开放一个公园，我们正在开放一个游泳池，那么他们就不会说，呃，在我们真正把它登在报纸上之前，让我们双重核实一下。你知道吗？
Well, A, we love a leak. Like that is like, we love a leak, we love a whistleblower. And that's just human nature, right? Because that makes a good story. Like, oh, this is secret. This is secret information that I'm giving you, that nobody knows about. That is what we live for. And so that makes sense.
好吧，A，我们喜欢泄密。这就好像是，我们喜欢泄密，我们喜欢吹哨人。这只是人性，对吧？因为那能造就一个好故事。就像，哦，这是秘密。这是我给你的秘密信息，没有人知道。这就是我们赖以生存的动力。所以这说得通。
I think the other part of it is sort of human nature. And I try to think about this all the time, about my just human biases and narrative and the way that when sources approach me, because my sources are not all good guys. Like I have sources who are literal white supremacists, right? Who are like not people that I'd want to have tea with, but who have given me information that is true and helps me explain this world that we live in right now. But the point of that is that when someone comes to you with a narrative, it might be like, when my child comes to me and says, my other child hit me, then now I'm investigating
我认为另一部分是某种人性。我一直试图思考这个问题，关于我自身的人性偏见、叙事方式，以及当消息来源接近我时——因为我的消息来源并不全都是好人。我的意思是，我有字面意义上的白人至上主义者作为消息来源，对吧？他们不是那种我想一起喝茶的人，但他们给了我真实的信息，并帮助我解释我们现在生活的这个世界。但重点是，当有人带着一个叙事来找你时，可能就像，当我的孩子来找我并说，我的另一个孩子打了我国，现在我正在调查
my child hit me. And that's the narrative that has been started. So like, Roosevelt hit me. Okay.'s like the narrative that has been started, right? So like Roosevelt hit me. Okay. That is what I understand the facts to be. And so I might go as they did to Roosevelt's team and say, why did you do this? Right. But then they're on the defensive and I've already set up that narrative.
我的孩子打了我。这就是已经开始的叙事。所以就像——罗斯福打了我国。好吧。这就好像是已经开始的叙事，对吧？所以就像——罗斯福打了我国。好吧。这就是我理解的事实。所以我可能会像他们对罗斯福的团队所做的那样去问，你们为什么这么做？对吧。但随后他们处于防守状态，而我已经建立起了那个叙事。
That is the narrative that I've established. And that is very, very powerful. It's hard to come back from that, which is why, you know, again, like he's so good on offense and less so on defense. So I've been checking out your work and I love your podcast. Tiffany Dover is dead. A lot of the time it makes me really angry because I have this just complete disdain for conspiracy theorists.
那是我确立的叙事。而且那是非常、非常强大的。很难从中扭转回来，这就是为什么，你知道，再次强调，他在进攻端非常出色，而在防守端则不然。所以我一直在关注你的作品，我非常喜欢你的播客《蒂凡尼·多夫死了》。很多时候它让我真的很生气，因为我对阴谋论者有一种完全的鄙视。
And then I started thinking about this book, the power broker. And if you take like a 30,000 foot view of this, you just squint really hard, it kind of has the vague shape of a conspiracy theory. Like instead of, you know, infrastructure being done by committee and through goodwill and trying to make the world a better place, you know, this is 1300 pages of Robert Caro, you know, convincing you that there's this man behind it all, Robert Moses, and this man has evil intent and he did bad things. And this feels like it's conspiracy theory and it kind of blew my mind.
然后我开始思考这本书，《权力掮客》。如果你采取一种三十五千英尺高的视角，你稍微眯起眼睛，它有点具备阴谋论的模糊雏形。就像，基础设施不是由委员会、通过善意并试图让世界变得更美好来完成的，你知道，这是罗伯特·卡罗的1300页内容，你知道，让你确信这一切背后有一个人，罗伯特·摩西，这个人有着邪恶的意图，他做了坏事。这感觉就像是阴谋论，这让我有点大开眼界。
So I've been thinking about what makes the difference between an investigative piece that reveals something that, you know, sinister intent by a small group of people versus conspiracy theories that are completely out the airlock and completely crazy and just trying to reconcile that and, and how you reconcile that in your work. Well, no, I, I, I've been thinking about that. Like the deep state is real and it is Robert Moses. He is, he is the man who by his great machinations and money and power is, is literally like choosing who, what children get sunlight and what
所以我一直在思考是什么区别了一个揭示了某种（你知道）一小群人的险恶意图的调查性报道，以及完全脱离现实且完全疯狂的阴谋论，并试图协调这一点，以及你在工作中如何协调这一点。好吧，不，我一直在思考这一点。深层政府是真实存在的，它就是罗伯特·摩西。他就是那个人，通过他巨大的阴谋、金钱和权力，字面意义上就像在选择哪些儿童能得到阳光、哪些
children don't. Who gets access to the water and who doesn't? It's stuff that rings very true in conspiracy land and conspiracy theories are great because conspiracies are real and conspiracies happen, especially at the local government. But what's interesting about this is that the truth is that real conspiracies operate like this in sort of banal ways, in paper pushing, in behind the scenes meetings,
儿童不能。谁能获得水源，谁不能。这些东西在阴谋论世界里听起来非常真实，而且阴谋论很棒，因为阴谋是真实存在的，阴谋确实会发生，尤其是在地方政府层面。但有趣的是，真相是真实的阴谋就是这样以一种陈腐的方式运作的，在推文牍、在幕后会议中、
in, you know, through the New York Times and, and it's like, it, it takes however many pages, several hundred over a thousand something, I listen to the audio book, 60s plus hours of pages to explain in fact how this conspiracy worked because it's, it's boring, you know, it's not like one secret meeting at a CDC in Georgia, which determined that everybody's going to get autism. Well, and also that the the ends are banal. The ends are, I don't want poor people to be able to take the bus to these communities on Long Island. And so I'm going to I'm going to do everything I can to block that, as opposed to the fun conspiracies where helicopters are going to round us up and and send us you know, and make us slaves to its transdimensional reptiles and things like that. Those are the fun conspiracies.
在（你知道）通过《纽约时报》进行，而且就像，它需要——不管多少页，几百页到一千多页，我听的是有声书，60多个小时的页面——来解释这个阴谋实际上是如何运作的，因为它很无聊，你知道，它不像佐治亚州疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）的一次秘密会议，决定了每个人都会得自闭症。好吧，而且其目的也很平庸。其目的是，我不希望穷人能够坐巴士去长岛的这些社区。所以我要——我要尽我所能阻止这一点，而不是那些直升机要把我们围捕起来并把我们送到（你知道）让我们成为跨维度爬行动物奴隶的有趣阴谋。那些才是有趣的阴谋。
And this feels like the real conspiracies are harder maybe to get people to see because they're not as exciting, you know? Yeah, ones that are rooted in things like institutional racism and like, you know, rich people not liking poor people and not thinking they are deserving of the same things. And like it's stuff like that. It's like, that's the real thing. You want something to be mad about, go be mad about that. Not your fake Guantanamo Bay stuff.
而这让人感觉真正的阴谋可能更难让人看清，因为它们没有那么令人兴奋，你知道吗？是的，那些植根于诸如体制化种族主义之类的事情，比如富人不喜欢穷人、不认为他们应该得到同样的东西。这就像是诸如此类的事情。这才是真正的事情。你想要找点什么生闷气的话，去为那个生闷气吧。而不是去管你那些虚假的关塔那摩湾的事情。
It does strike me that these conspiracies of Robert Moses and the Moses men are all that hidden. And they're not really about a conspiracy of action and deed. They're kind of a conspiracy of shared values. They all agree on a thing. They tacitly or explicitly express those things and create the world that they see fit.
确实让我感到，罗伯特·摩西和摩西手下这些人的阴谋并没有那么隐蔽。它们其实并不是关于行动和行为的阴谋。它们更像是某种共享价值观的阴谋。他们都同意某件事。他们默认或明确地表达这些事情，并创造出他们认为合适的世界。
But it's not like they're secretly doing a whole lot. You know what I mean? Because when Robert Caro goes and talks to him and talks about the bridges, and when you investigate it today, and you go, how did you know that Robert Moses really did make the bridges shorter? And he was like, his assistant told me,
但并不是说他们在暗地里做了很多事情。你知道我的意思吗？因为当罗伯特·卡罗去跟他们谈论桥梁时，当你今天去调查时，你会去想，你怎么知道罗伯特·摩西真的把桥建得更矮了？而他的助手是这么告诉我的，
that's what he said. You know, like, it just is like, you know, it's just like. Yeah, I mean, how easy would it have been for a reporter to go into some of the communities that were being raised to build these new expressways or to, you know, clear these slums and go talk to those people? Like, that was a story in plain sight. That was, you know, thousands and thousands of people being displaced, communities being destroyed over and over and over again. So like, why weren't those stories bigger than the man Robert Moses? Why didn't those stories get more play?
他是这么说的。你知道，就像，你知道，这就像是。是的，我的意思是，对于一个记者来说，走进那些为了修建这些新快速路或清理这些贫民窟而被拆迁的社区之一，去跟那些人谈谈，这会有多容易？这本就是一个显而易见的故事。那是成千上万的人流离失所，社区一次又一次被摧毁。所以，为什么这些故事没有比罗伯特·摩西这个人更大？为什么这些故事没有得到更多的关注？
It's because I would venture to say those people were not cared about in the same way. They were not valorized. They weren't important in the same way that Robert Moses was. And the reporters were more like Robert Moses than they were like the people that were. Yeah, they were all the same people.
这是因为——我敢冒险说——那些人没有以同样的方式受到关怀。他们没有被赋予英雄般的色彩。他们没有像罗伯特·摩西那样以同样的方式变得重要。而记者们更像罗伯特·摩西，而不是那些人。是的，他们都是同一群人。
They hung out at lunch. I mean, the owner of the New York Times loved him so very, very much. Like. I've been trying to think a lot about corollaries, and just selfishly, maybe because I'm living aspirationally through Robert Harris' work, but I'm like, who is the Robert Moses of our time? Who is the person who is doing the things that we should be looking at right now that we're all missing? I haven't thought about it, but listeners can please contact me. That's kind of one of those things where if we knew about it, it wouldn't necessarily be the same thing because he was so good at presenting a different version of himself than was actually
他们一起吃午饭。我的意思是，《纽约时报》的老板非常、非常喜欢他。就像。我一直在努力思考相关的推论，可能仅仅是出于自私，因为我在通过罗伯特·卡罗的作品过着一种志存高远的生活，但我在想：谁是我们这个时代的罗伯特·摩西？谁是那个正在做我们现在应该关注、而我们却全都错过了的事情的人？我还没想过，但听众朋友们请联系我。这有点像那种如果我们知道了，它就不一定是一回事的事情，因为他非常擅长展现一个与实际正在
taking action. You need some kind of amazing whistleblower leaker that can meet you in a parking garage somewhere, I guess, and give you the information. Although, that's something I like so much about the book is that Robert Caro is consistently not dramatizing his own investigation or his own research. There's not a lot of like, and then I did something that was really exciting.
采取行动的自己截然不同的版本。你需要某种了不起的吹哨人、泄密者，可以在某个停车场跟你见面，我想，并把信息交给你。尽管如此，我对这本书非常喜爱的一点是，罗伯特·卡罗始终没有将他自己的调查或研究戏剧化。这里没有太多类似“然后我做了一件非常令人兴奋的事”的内容。
At most he'll say, as he does in this episode, well, when I talked to this guy in his house, he told me this, you know, or I went to this guy's office and this is what he said. There's a, there's not a, he's not creating the suspense around himself during the story. No, I wasn't even aware and maybe because I missed it, but while I was listening, I wasn't even aware that he had spoken, actually spoken with Moses, that he had gotten like the Moses interview. And at the end I was sort of like, wait, what? This, oh, okay.
顶多也就是像他在这一集里所做的那样，当我和这个人在他家里谈话时，他告诉了我这个，你知道，或者我去了这个人的办公室，这就是他所说的。这里没有一种——他并没有在故事进行的过程中围绕自己制造悬念。不，我甚至不知道——也许是因为我错过了，但在我听的时候，我甚至不知道他实际上跟摩西谈过话，他得到了类似摩西的采访。而在最后我有点像，等等，什么？这，哦，好吧。
Which is a bold and the best choice. It's a very old school choice. I mean, it's like, it's like, it's not the current sort of fashion for sure. Like if I would, if I were to do this story, it would be all about how amazing it was that I did this story. Like I did this for seven years.
这是一个大胆且极佳的选择。这是一个非常老派的选择。我的意思是，这就像，这肯定不是目前的那种流行时尚。如果我要做这个报道，那将会全部关于我做这个报道是多么了不起。就像我做了七年一样。
You know, like that would be the opening line. Can you believe what I did? Exactly. Yeah, you know, I appreciated it as I appreciate something old that I read. I see it, but at the same time, you see those little, he does it in his own way. There is a quiet bragging that goes on here where he's talking about like forming of Long Island and like even at the beginning where he's like, and then like, okay, you know all the roads.
你知道，那将是开场白。你能相信我做了什么吗？没错。是的，你知道，我欣赏它，就像我欣赏我读过的一些老旧作品一样。我看到了，但与此同时，你会看到那些微小的细节，他是以自己的方式做到的。这里有一种悄然的自吹自擂，他在谈论长岛的形成，甚至在开头，他说：然后就像，好了，你知道所有的路。
Like I, like you've done it. I get it. So it's different. And I sort of like the, the narrator. I like knowing a little bit about the narrator who's leading me something through something. I appreciate the modernization of that a little bit. I do think, I think what it, what it felt like to me, and I think this is true,
就像我，就像你已经做过的一样。我懂了。所以这是不同的。我有点喜欢——旁白。我喜欢了解一点带领我经历某些事情的旁白。我有点欣赏这种现代化的处理方式。我确实认为，我所感受到的——而且我认为这是真的，
regardless of like the little flair that he would insert about himself as the author. Um, I, I, it shows to me, it's another sort of brick in the house that shows me that, um, he cares about story, about the factual tale of this person more than anything. I think he also, what I also love about Caro is, and I think this is the next thing I wanna talk to him about when I talk to him, was this,
不管他作为作者对自己的微小炫耀如何——它向我展示了，它就像是房子里的又一块砖，向我表明他最关心的不仅仅是故事本身，还有关于这个人的事实故事。我想他也，我同样喜欢卡罗的一点是——我想这是我下次跟他谈话时想跟他谈的下一件事——是什么让他在面对那些人时如此富有同感，（你知道）他真的能感受到摩西造成的毁灭。就像他是带着这种心态去探究的。我发现这非常迷人。我想知道，当你思考你的工作时，是什么让你想要去讲述某个故事中受害者的故事，你的敏感点在哪里，你究竟在为谁而战、为谁讲述这个故事。我认为罗伯特·卡罗有一种真正的——他是一个老派的自由派，你知道，就像。他是一个老派的自由派，你知道，就像他想要照顾这些人。
what made him so empathic in regards to the people that, you know, he really feels the destruction of Moses. Like he's going into it with that in mind. And I find that very fascinating. And I wonder, you know, when you think about your work, you know, what tunes you into wanting to tell the story of who the victim is in a certain story and and where your sensitivities lie and where you who you are fighting for fighting to tell the story of. I think robert caro has a real like he old school liberal like you know just like. He, old school liberal, like, you know, just like he wants to take care of these people.
就像他想要确保他们的故事被讲述一样。其中有一种高尚且有趣的东西是我喜欢的，但他并没有真正大声说出来，但我能感觉到。这看起来可能有些脱节，但我发誓我有我的观点。请讲。所以我经常说，我爱上了我采访的每一个人，而且我会去——所以，所以我经常说，我爱上了我采访的每一个人，我会
Like he wants to make sure that their story is told. There's just something noble and interesting about that that I like, but he doesn't really go out and say it, but I can just feel it. This is gonna seem disjointed, but I swear I have a point. Please. So I will often say that I fall in love with every person that I interview, and I will go point. Um, so I will often say that I fall in love with every person that I interview and I will
去进行采访，甚至，你知道，我用带引号的“坏人”、“阴谋论者”（你知道，不总是最好的人），但每次我和某人交谈时，我都觉得我在点头附和他们，哦，你这样做是合情合理的。我认为大多数人在他们的需求（你知道）和信仰上是真诚的，就像
go to an interview and even, you know, I'm using little quotations, bad guys, conspiracy theorists, um, you know, just not always the nicest people, but every time I talk to someone, I feel like I'm nodding along with them like, Oh, that makes sense why you would be doing this thing. Most people, I think, are sincere in their wants, you know, and in their beliefs, like
摩西可能也是这样，他认为他所做的事最终对这座城市是最好的。所以，我认为人们通常是真诚的，每次交谈时我都相信他们，然后你知道，我相信了所有人，然后我会回家说，我已经和所有需要交谈的人谈过了，我有所有需要的文件，现在我要写这个故事了。然后你知道，在故事写完并发表之后，尽管里面的任何事实都没有让任何人感到惊讶，那些我交谈过的人会打电话给我说，我对这个结果不是很满意。我觉得你真的理解了我的来意和我的观点，但你对另一群人太仁慈了。
Moses probably was, where he thought he was doing what was ultimately best for the city. And so, like, I think people are typically sincere, and I believe them each time we talk and then you know I believe sort of everyone and then I will go home and I will say I've talked to everyone I need to, I have all the documents I need to, and now I'm going to write this story. And then you know after the story is written and is published, although none of the facts in it surprise anyone, the people that I speak to will call me back and say, I'm not so happy with the way that this came out. I felt like you really understood where I was coming from and my point of view, but then you were too kind to this other group.
摩西可能也是这样，他认为自己做的事情最终是对城市最好的。所以，就像，我认为人们通常是真诚的，每次我们交谈时我都相信他们，你知道的，我基本上相信每一个人，然后我会回家说，我已经和所有需要交谈的人谈过，我有所有需要的文档，现在我要写这个故事了。然后你知道，在故事写好并发表之后，虽然其中的事实没有让任何人感到惊讶，但我谈过的人会打电话给我说，我对这个结果不是很满意。我觉得你真的很理解我的立场和观点，但你对另一群人太好了。
And so I will joke that at the end of a story, if everybody's a little mad at me then I've probably done a good job. But I do feel there is, you know, a certain group or a certain type of source that you do feel like I am the only way this person is going to get this story out. Nobody seems to care about, you know, about this group of people, about, kids and their mothers who are being fed misinformation or being scammed in this way. And so you feel an affinity for people whose voices aren't being heard. And there's so much power in the press. We have so much power to elevate certain voices. And those are always a choice. It's always a choice who we choose to elevate and how we tell this narrative. And there's a lot of responsibility that comes with that.
所以我会开玩笑说，在一个故事讲完时，如果每个人都对我有点生气，那我大概是把工作做好了。但我也确实觉得，你知道，有某种群体或某种消息源，你会觉得，我就是这个人能把这个故事公之于众的唯一途径。似乎没有人关心，你知道的，这个群体的人，关心那些被喂食虚假信息或以这种方式被诈骗的孩子和母亲。所以你会对那些声音没有被听到的人产生一种共情。新闻界有着巨大的力量。我们有巨大的力量去提升某些声音。而这些总是一种选择。我们选择提升谁以及我们如何讲述这个叙事，这总是一个选择。这背后伴随着巨大的责任。
And I got that very much that feeling from Carol as well. Yeah. Yeah. I also kind of have that issue when I interview people, I, I'm bored. I mean, I don't know if I, I don't talk to quite the extremists you do, but like, you know, like, so it's, I don't know what that situation is like, but I do.
卡罗给我的也是这种强烈的感觉。是啊。是啊。当我采访别人时，我也有点这种毛病，我，我很无聊。我是说，我不知道我，我谈话的对象可能没有你采访的那些极端分子那么极端，但是，你知道，就像，所以，我不知道那种情况是什么样，但我确实……
You talk to a lot of people with extreme views about architecture. Exactly. So, but I'm always like, yeah, okay. And then I have to go back and assess it. Like, when you take all that stuff in and then you recalibrate to form this narrative, you know, how do you adjust that?
你和很多对建筑持有极端观点的人交谈过。没错。所以，但我总是会想，好吧，然后我得回去评估它。就像，当你把所有这些东西都吸收进去，然后重新校准来形成这个叙事时，你知道，你是如何调整这一切的？
Like, how do you pull yourself back from the emotional sort of like seduction of their passion and turn the dials to make it into what you're presenting as the truth? I mean, it's probably some sort of like emotional disability or something, but I don't know if it's a good thing, but like I remember what's in front of my face or like I emotionally connect with what's in front of my face right at that moment. And then when I leave, even like walking in my car, I'm like, wait a minute, that guy was full of money. That's not true. Or like, I don't believe that. Why was I nodding along? Sometimes I'll actually have like a post-it if I'm doing like a phone interview that says, stop nodding along or like stop smiling. Because I do, you want
比如，你如何让自己从他们那充满激情的、类似情感诱惑的东西中抽离出来，然后转动旋钮，把它变成你所呈现的真相？我的某种情感障碍之类的吧，虽然我不知道这算不算好事，但我会记住眼前发生的事情，或者我会跟当下那一刻眼前发生的事情产生情感上的连接。然后当我离开时，甚至在走向我的汽车时，我会想，等等，那家伙满嘴跑火车。那不是真的。或者，我不相信那个。我刚才为什么一直在点头？有时候，如果我在做电话采访，我实际上会在便签上写着：别再点头了，或者别再微笑了。因为我确实，你想要……
to connect. So much of this is about connection. But ultimately the responsibility when you get home is to say, what is real? What is the truth? And how can I accurately reflect that in a piece of writing or a video or whatever it is that we're doing. I wonder if you see that in the book also, I feel like I see it a little bit where you can tell when sometimes when Carol is talking about Moses or kind of implying the times that he saw Moses,
建立连接。这其中很大一部分都关乎连接。但最终，当你回到家时，责任就是去思考：什么是真实的？什么是真相？我该如何在文章、视频或我们正在做的任何事情中准确地反映这一点。我想知道你在书中是否也看到了这一点，我觉得我稍微能看到一点，你会发现有时当卡罗在谈论摩西，或者某种程度上暗示他见到摩西的那些时刻……
that he does find him very impressive and that he is falling under the spell a little bit. And maybe it's only the knowledge of the people that he's met whose lives were affected by him that pulls him back from that. He talked to us about having the same experience that you had where Moses is showing him, you know, through the windows, Long Island, he's saying, don't you believe there should be a road right there? And he's like, uh-huh, uh-huh. And then he walks, he's leaving. He's like, wait a minute,
他确实觉得摩西非常令人印象深刻，而且他自己也稍微有点被对方的魔力迷住了。也许只有当他了解到那些生活受到摩西影响的人们的境况时，这种知识才能把他从那种迷恋中拉回来。他跟我们聊过，说他也有过和你一样的经历：摩西指着窗外的长岛给他看，摩西说：“难道你不觉得那里应该修一条路吗？”而他则附和着：“嗯，对，嗯，对。”然后他走开，在离开的时候，他会想：“等一下……”
that's not a good place for a road. Like, and I wonder if it is only that, that ability to hold onto that compassion for the people he's talked to, who he does Believe have been wronged that helps him to pull back Do you ever feel like that where it's you kind of have to make the choice of who who is worth? Maintaining that that sympathy towards in your writing Yeah, and and usually those the ones that deserve that that remains right past the car I'd like you get home and they're like, oh, I still feel this way But you know people are intoxicating. People with power are incredibly intoxicating.
那根本不是修路的好地方。我在想，是不是只有这种能力——对那些他交谈过、并且他确信遭受了不公正对待的人保持同情——才能帮他抽离出来？你有没有过这种感觉，就是你某种程度上必须做出选择，在你的写作中，谁才值得去维持那种同情？是的，通常那些值得让这种同情心延续到汽车之外的人……比如你回到家，会觉得：“噢，我还是这种感觉。”但你知道，人是具有迷惑性的。有权势的人具有令人难以置信的迷惑性。
And so you get drawn up in that orbit. And I appreciated the building of him only if it was that much further for him to fall. But I appreciated all the physical descriptions of him swimming across the ocean. And I'm like, his booming voice, I'm like, his like booming voice. I'm like, this is a guy. Like he has got it.
所以你会被吸入那个轨道中。我很欣赏对他的身材的描写，哪怕只是为了让他将来跌得更惨。但我很欣赏所有关于他游过海洋的体形描写。我当时想，他那洪亮的嗓音，我当时想，他那洪亮的嗓音。我当时想，这家伙。就像他全盘掌控。
Like I did. And so I imagine when you're in his presence, you would feel that way too. Again, I feel that way all the time. I'm a girl from Florida, Georgia. Like I went to a state school. Two different states in one place. Yeah. I know.
就像我做的那样。所以我想象当你身处他的气场中时，你也会有那种感觉。再说一次，我一直都有这种感觉。我是一个来自佛罗里达、佐治亚的女孩。就像我上过一所州立大学。一个地方有两个不同的州。对。我知道。
It's amazing. You'll. I went to a state school. Two different states in one place, yeah. I know. It's amazing, you'll. But like, I'm not a New York City elite despite what the folks who read my work sometimes would have you believe.
太神奇了，你会。我上过一所州立大学。一个地方有两个不同的州，对。我知道。太神奇了，你会。但就像，尽管读我作品的人有时可能会让你产生那种印象，但我并不是什么纽约市精英。
So I'm constantly impressed by people and things. I went to visit this very fancy lawyer once and he invited me into his office across from Lincoln Center. And you went in and the whole building was floor to ceiling marble and gold. And I was just like, this is so fancy. And I said that, he's like, don't say that. Oh, okay, I will not. So I try to like temper some of my bumpkin tendencies, but generally like I am impressed by so much.
所以我经常对人和事感到印象深刻。我曾经去拜访过一位非常高档的律师，他邀请我去他在林肯中心对面办公室。你走进去，整栋建筑从地板到天花板都是大理石和黄金。我当时就想：这太高级了。然后我把这话说了出来，他说：别这么说。噢，好吧，那我不说了。所以我尽量克制我的一些乡巴佬本能，但总体来说，我对很多东西都印象深刻。
And I do think, thank God that we have that time so much to go home and recalibrate and say, wait a minute, like you do not have to be in this person's spell. I think the thing is, is that there are folks in my profession who never get that moment or never take that moment to say, pause, like, who am I serving with my journalism? You know, am I writing about the right thing? Am I writing this the right way? Am I questioning power or am I helping prop it up? Yeah.
我确实觉得，谢天谢地，我们有那么多时间回家重新校准，心想：等一下，你不需要沉浸在这个人的魔咒里。我觉得问题在于，我这一行里有些人从来没有得到过那个时刻，或者从不花时间去暂停一下，心想：我的新闻工作服务于谁？你知道的，我写的东西对头吗？我写这篇报道的方式对吗？我是在质疑权力，还是在为权力保驾护航？是的。
So you cover a conspiracy theory and a lot of that is to illuminate this world that is happening to people like me who don't buy into those conspiracy theories. But I get a sense of some of your work that you are trying to present the world as it is or as you report it to those believers to just kind of maybe move them off of their comfortable spot a little bit. And what are the methods to change people's minds when it comes to sort of, you know, moving them off things that they really believe in their soul? I don't know how to change people's minds. I think I know how to write and report for
所以你报道过阴谋论，其中很大一部分是为了阐明这个世界正在发生的事情，这些事情正发生在我这样不相信这些阴谋论的人身上。但从你的某些作品中，我感觉到你正试图向那些信徒呈现世界的本来面目，或者如你所报道的那样，只是为了稍微动摇一下他们那些感觉舒适的阵地。当涉及到让人们改变那些他们打心底里坚信的事情时，有什么方法可以做到这一点？我不知道该如何改变人们的想法。我想我知道如何为……写作和报道：
people who may wander or may dip a toe into a specific conspiracy theory, which everybody believes is a conspiracy theory. My favorite conversation at parties, which I don't go to very much anymore, is to ask what conspiracy theory do you believe in? And everybody, I have yet, I think, to meet one person who doesn't believe something that is probably not true. Lots of people believe that your cell phone is giving you ear cancer. Lots of people believe the Kennedy assassination, probably the most people. I've met some very reasonable people whose children play with my children who believe that we did not land on the moon.
那些可能会产生怀疑，或者偶尔会涉足某个特定阴谋论的人——每个人都相信某种阴谋论。我在派对上最喜欢的对话（虽然我现在不怎么去派对惹）就是问：你相信什么阴谋论？而且每个人，我想我至今还没遇到过一个不相信某种很可能是假的事物的人。很多人相信你的手机会让你得耳癌。很多人相信肯尼迪遇刺案，这可能是最多人相信的。我遇到过一些非常理智的人，他们的孩子和我的孩子一起玩，他们相信我们从未登上过月球。
So, I mean, there are, I just think that there's a lot of folks out there. How you change someone's mind if they already believe something, I think that's almost impossible. What I do think works, and this is only anecdotal, so maybe there'll be some research on it somewhere, but I don't know of it, but is reporting on the people behind a conspiracy theory. So either the people who are profiting from that conspiracy theory,
所以，我的意思是，有，我只是觉得外面有很多人。如果你想改变一个已经相信某事的人的想法，我认为这几乎是不可能的。但我确实认为管用的方法——这只是个人的经验之谈，所以也许某处会有关于它的研究，但我不知道——那就是报道阴谋论背后的那些人。也就是那些从阴谋论中获利的人，
the people who have created the conspiracy theory. So you get an idea of, if I just tell people that vaccines aren't causing autism, they can't believe that. If I report on research that shows vaccines don't cause autism, they don't believe that. But if I report on a man named Del Bigtree who lives in Austin, Texas,
或者是那些炮制阴谋论的人。这样你就能明白：如果我只是告诉人们疫苗不会导致自闭症，他们是不会相信的。如果我报道显示疫苗不会导致自闭症的研究，他们也不信。但如果我报道一个名叫德尔·比格特利（Del Bigtree）的男子，他住在德克萨斯州奥斯汀，
and he makes an exorbitant amount of money off of this anti-vax rhetoric, spreading this lie. And here's what he buys with that, right? Here's the house that he lives in with his wife. And here are the stories about this person who, you know, goes and travels all over the country to weaken vaccine laws. And here is him wearing a star of David, trying to liken himself to Jews during the
他通过这种反疫苗的言论、散布这种谎言赚取了巨额财富。这就是他用这些钱买的东西，对吧？这就是他和妻子住的房子。以下是关于这个人的故事，你知道的，他四处奔波，企图削弱疫苗法律。还有他戴着大卫之星的照片，试图把自己比作……期间的犹太人
Holocaust. Like here are all the things that can make you look at this man and say, I don't believe him. So that's something that I've found that I think is seems to be impactful. It's almost like you are you are vaccinating someone against that conspiracy theory with another conspiracy that is kind of a dead conspiracy. You know, it's not as damaging. You're like, there isn't some big conspiracy by the medical organization, the medical, whoever they are to lie to you. It's a conspiracy by this guy and other people who are making money off of these lies. You know, maybe that's effective because people are like, now I have a new thing to not like. You know, I don't know.
大屠杀。就像所有这些事情都能让你看着这个人然后说：我不相信他。所以这是我发现的一种似乎很有影响力的做法。这简直就像是用另一种相对“死掉的”阴谋来给某人接种疫苗，以此来抵抗那种阴谋论。你知道，这没那么具破坏性。你会觉得，医疗机构、医疗界——不管他们是谁——并没有什么针对你的巨大阴谋。这是一个由这家伙和其他从这些谎言中赚钱的人所搞出来的阴谋。你知道，也许这很有效，因为人们会觉得：现在我有了一个新的讨厌对象。你知道，我不知道。
It's not a conspiracy. It's a plan. You know, like it's a... That's right. I mean, that's sort of like, it's thing to not like, you know, I don't know. It's not a conspiracy, it's a plan, you know, like it's a. That's right, I mean, that's sort of like, it's a kind of like Occam's razor approach to like, why do you have to have these Byzantine turns and you know, like of who profits and who does this and why do this and when the simplest motive of a single man getting rich off of line,
这不是阴谋。这是一个计划。你知道，就像这是一个……没错。我的意思是，那有点像……讨厌的对象，你知道，我不知道。这不是阴谋，这是一个计划，你知道，就像是一个……没错，我的意思是，那有点像奥卡姆剃刀的方法，就是：为什么你必须拐弯抹角地去探究谁从中获利、谁做了这个、为什么要这么做，而当最简单的动机是一个单身汉靠说谎发财时，
it's a pretty good one to believe, and a pretty, you know, that's a foundational text in our history as humans, you know? So. Yeah, really easy story to find as a journalist. Yeah. The single dude getting rich off of a bunch of people who believe a lie.
这是一个挺好让人相信的理由，而且挺……你知道的，那是我们人类历史上的基础文本，你知道吗？所以。是的，作为记者，这是一个非常容易找到的故事。是的。一个单身汉靠着一群相信谎言的人发了财。
Yeah, that is interesting. And when I think about what, you know, Caro is doing here to change people's minds about this man, I think I'm trying to think of like where his interests lie and where what the best story is or whatever it is. It's like a lot of people who I know, you know, think about this book as the tale of urbanism and how cities are made. I really do think Caro, I mean, there's a reason
是的，这很有趣。当我想起卡罗在这里为了改变人们对这个男人的看法而做的事情时，我想我是在试着思考他的兴趣所在，以及最好的故事是什么，或者诸如此类的事情。这就像许多我认识的人，你知道，把这本书看作是关于城市规划以及城市是如何建成的故事。我真的觉得卡罗，我是说，这是有原因的。
why it's called the power broker and not the city builder, you know, or something like that. Like, I think he's really fascinated by the same kind of personal story and using that personal story of a person who has this sort of rapacious like desire for power. And he kind of uses that to unseat him as this holy saint of the builder of things versus necessarily, you know, like he definitely talks about the merits and the lack of merits
为什么它叫《权力的经纪人》而不是《城市建造者》，你知道的，诸如此类。我觉得他真正着迷的是那种关于个人的故事，并且利用这种个人故事——一个对权力有着贪婪欲望的人的故事——来打破他作为那种万能圣人、城市建造者的形象，而不一定非要去……（当然他确实讨论了）他建造的东西的好处和不足，
of the things that he built. But the foundation running through it is kind of that same foundation that you that you talk about when you talk about your anti-vax guy. It's like Moses didn't get rich, but Moses got rich with power and he's making a statement that this very base need of this man is the driving force for all of this stuff. And he definitely talks about all the things that he built.
但贯穿其中的基础，其实就是你谈论你的反疫苗大棒时所说的那种相同的基础。就像摩西并没有发财，但摩西用权力发了财，他在阐述这样一个观点：这个男人非常基础的需求才是这一切的驱动力。而且他确实谈到了他建造的所有东西。
But it seems like there's a parallel in that, in a way of constructing a story to change people's minds around the idea of the man and not just refuting it idea by idea. I think that's kind of fascinating. I think it's similar. I totally believe that people only care about stories about people.
但在某种程度上，这似乎有一个相似之处，即通过构建一个故事来改变人们对这个人的看法，而不仅仅是逐个驳斥观点。我觉得这挺迷人的。我觉得这很相似。我完全相信人们只关心关于人的故事。
Like, it's, I don't, everything else is just sort of boring. All a Hey Martha story is a, oh my gosh, this guy did this thing, can you believe it? Or, you know, you need a character. And without it, I think it's very, very difficult, which is why I sort of give the journalists at the time a little bit of a break, because it was hard to tell the story of Robert Moses at the time, right? Like how does an investigative journal, like what documents can prop up an idea of like this guy has too much power is like power hungry or power mad.
就像，我不觉得，其他一切都挺无聊的。所有的“哎呀玛莎”（Hey Martha）式的故事都是：哦天哪，这家伙做了这事，你敢信吗？或者，你知道，你需要一个角色。如果没有它，我觉得这会非常非常困难，这也是为什么我对当时记者们表示一点理解的原因，因为在当时很难讲好罗伯特·摩西的故事，对吧？一个调查记者怎么能——什么样的文件能够支撑这样一个观点：这家伙权力过大，或者说他权力欲狂、渴望权力？
And that's what's driving it. Like that's a very hard story to tell. You need like 1200 pages. And so it's just really difficult. Yeah. And you have to imagine, I wonder if, as someone who's a working journalist, if you see it this way too, that Carol has the benefit of talking to these people many years after the events have happened. And so there's no longer the same danger necessarily. And he did have trouble getting close to Moses Circle for a while, but people don't need to worry
而这正是驱动力所在。这真的是一个很难讲的故事。你需要大约1200页的篇幅。所以这真的很难。是的。而且你可以想象，我想作为一个职业记者，如果你也这么看的话，卡罗的优势在于他是在事件发生多年后才与这些人交谈的。因此，那种危险性已经不再那么大了。虽然他有一段时间确实很难接近摩西的圈子，但人们现在不需要太担心
quite as much about their livelihoods being ruined, their name being dragged through the press. And some of them might even be eager to now tell the things that they did back then in the shadows to get the credit for them or to share them. Does that do you ever feel like when you're interviewing people, do you ever wish like, I wish I could talk to you in the future when you'll phrase I've never said before but we say often you want to be first or last and either your first was Corey and it's a scoop and it's exclusive and and that's how you make it or
自己的生计被毁，或者名字被媒体肆意践踏。其中有些人甚至可能急于讲述当年他们在阴暗角落里做过的事情，以便从中分得功劳或与人分享。你有没有过这种感觉，当你采访别人时，你会不会希望：我真希望能在未来采访你，到那时你就会说出……我以前从未说过的话，但我们经常说，你想成为第一名或最后名。要么你是第一个接触到科里的人，这是一个独家重磅新闻，这就是你成功的方式，要么
You're you know with a pack of other reporters often Trying to all tell the same story, reaching out to the same sources. And even if it is exclusive, you're right. Like in the moment, people are very hesitant to talk to you, especially in this moment, right, where people distrust the press, the mainstream media is, you know,
你，你知道的，和一大群记者在一起，经常试图讲述同一个故事，联系相同的消息源。而且即使是独家报道，你说得对。比如在当时，人们非常不愿意跟你谈话，尤其是在这个时刻，对吧？在这个时刻，人们不信任媒体，主流媒体对50%的人来说
a dirty word for 50% of the population. It's really, really hard to do this job. I will say in the podcast that I did, it was an utter failure. I was trying to reach this person who did not want to talk to media, and she didn't. I couldn't talk to her. And not until a year after our podcast ended, did she reach back out to me? And she said, now I'm ready to talk. And that happens all the time. People who I'm working with on a story will, I do this thing with my subjects,
是一个贬义词。干这份工作真的、真的很难。我可以说，在我做的那个播客里，那是一次彻底的失败。我当时试图联系一个不想跟媒体对话的人，而她也确实没跟我谈。我联系不上她。直到我们的播客结束一年后，她才主动联系了我。她说：我现在准备好谈谈了。这种情况一直在发生。那些我在故事中合作过的人，我会对我的采访对象做一件事，
because some of them are vulnerable, conspiracy theorists or people who've been wrapped up in something like that. And so I'll do this thing where I read them like a Miranda writes, and I say, this is the story that I've got now. And let's talk about the worst thing that might happen to you if I publish this story, right? Like, what are some things that you're afraid of?
因为他们当中有些人很脆弱，比如阴谋论者或者被卷入类似事件的人。所以我经常会做一件事，我会像宣读米兰达警告那样向他们宣读一些东西，我会说：这就是我目前掌握的故事。让我们来谈谈，如果我发表了这个故事，你可能会遇到的最糟糕的事情是什么，对吧？比如，你害怕什么？
And sometimes at the end of this long talk, which can say, maybe jobs won't want to hire me, maybe my wife will get mad at me, maybe the police will come and want to arrest me, there are lots of things that might come from this, do you still want to go? And several people have told me, actually, nevermind. Like I've had whole stories ready to go
有时在这场冗长的谈话结束时，可能会有人说：也许工作单位不想雇佣我了，也许我妻子会生我的气，也许警察会来想逮捕我……这里面可能会有很多后果，你还想继续吗？有几个人曾对我说：其实，算了吧。我甚至准备好了完整的报道，
and people say I changed my mind. And then, but sometimes like with, for example, I did this story about this man who was at January 6 at the Capitol on January 6. And he told me his whole story and what brought him there. And he said, no. And then a year later, he said, you know what? I'm ready now. And so we went ahead and published.
但人们却说我改变主意了。然后，但有时候，比如我曾做过一篇关于1月6日出现在国会大厦的那个男人的报道。他告诉我他的整个故事以及是什么把他带到那里的。他说：不。然后一年后，他说：你知道吗？我现在准备好了。于是我们继续发表了。
And that's, you know, that's their story. That's their right. But I think that, like you said, with time, if you had the time to just get people to know you, cause I'm sure that if I say, I'm sure that Caro, I'm sure there were examples where Caro went to someone or maybe you can ask about him for me, but where he went to someone and they said no. And then he just kept on reporting and kept on reporting. And then
这就是，你知道的，那是他们的故事。那是他们的权利。但我认为，就像你说的，随着时间的推移，如果你有时间去让人了解你——因为我确信，如果我说，我确信卡罗……我确信有这样的例子，卡罗去找某个人，或者也许你可以替我向他打听，他去找某个人，对方说不。然后他继续报道，继续报道。然后
they came back to him and said, actually, I'll talk to you or he kept at it and, you know, kept on their doorstep. And they said, okay, come on in or whatever it is. But yeah, time is such a luxury. I can't imagine what you could do with it. Yeah, he really was able to go back multiple times to try people. And I mean, the ultimate version of that, as anyone has read the Lynda Johnson books knows, is he goes, well, I guess I'm gonna have to live
他们回到他身边说：其实，我会跟你聊聊的。或者他坚持不懈，你知道的，一直守在他们门口。然后他们说：好吧，请进，诸如此类。但是，是的，时间真是一种奢侈。我无法想象你能用它做些什么。是的，他确实能够多次回头去找那些人。我的意思是，任何读过林登·约翰逊传记的人都知道，终极版本的做法就是，他会说：好吧，看来我得
in the neighborhood that these people live in for three years and just let them know me as a neighbor before I can even talk to them, ask them any questions as a reporter. I saw the documentary and I was just like, this is insane. It's pretty amazing. And one of the things I love about the different volumes
在这群人居住的街区里住上三年，先让他们把我当成一个邻居来了解我，然后我才能作为记者去跟他们谈话、问他们任何问题。我看了那部纪录片，当时我就想：这太疯狂了。这真是太惊人了。关于LBJ传记的不同卷册，我最喜欢的一点是，
of the LBJ books is by the time, you know, the second LBJ book comes out, the first one has already been out. And so he's talking to them and they'll reference the fact that they read the first book. And surprisingly, it makes them more likely to talk to him, I think. I don't know why, but it just seems to.
到了第二本LBJ传记出版时，第一本已经问世了。所以他在跟这些人交谈时，他们会提到他们读过第一本。出乎意料的是，这让他们更有可能跟他交谈，我是这么觉得的。我不知道为什么，但事实好像就是如此。
And it's incredibly fascinating. But that is true. When you, like when I'll publish a story that's like sort of a beat story, and then re-reach out, that just happened to me actually, and then reach out again and say, I just wanted to let you know I published this story. It makes people understand that you care about the story,
这真的非常迷人。但这是真的。当你，比如当我发表了一篇例行报道，然后再次联系——这实际上刚刚发生在我身上——然后再次联系并说：我只是想让你知道我发表了这篇报道。这会让人们明白你在乎这个故事，
even if they don't necessarily agree with where you're coming at from or everything that you've written, it gives them a chance to see that you're invested and it matters in a way that you're not a fly-by-night reporter parachuting into somewhere and going to mess up the story that you care. And then, you know, everybody wants to tell their story. Everybody wants to talk and talk about their point of view and their lives, especially, you know,
即使他们不一定同意你的立场或你所写的一切，这也能让他们看到你投入了心力，这件事情很重要，你不是那种空降到某个地方、把故事搞砸就走的“快闪记者”，你是真正在乎的。然后，你知道的，每个人都想讲述自己的故事。每个人都想倾诉并谈论自己的观点和生活，特别是，你知道的，
as you get a little older, you probably want these things down for the record. So when you report on things, you report on, you know, extremists and people who, you know, who come back at you, or maybe not the people you actually report on, but their allies in some way. What is that like to be under threat
随着你年龄渐长，你大概会希望把这些事情记录在案。所以，当你报道某些事情时，你报道的是，你知道的，极端分子和那些，你知道的，会回击你的人，或者可能不是你实际报道的人，而是他们的某种盟友。被那些不喜欢你在报道中所说的话的人威胁，那是一种什么样的体验？我这人脸皮很薄。我非常敏感。我总是哭。众议院司法委员会的共和党人，就在几周前，我做了一篇关于社交媒体武器化的报道，这是一个由吉姆·乔丹（Jim Jordan）领导的、简直是扯淡的小委员会。我，我可以说是扯淡吧？我很抱歉。没关系。这是一个无拘无束的播客。你知道的，这书里就有。如果这个词在书里用过，我们就可以在播客里用。所以我想我们没问题。嗯，所以我报道了这个委员会，吉姆·乔丹的手下联系了我，简直是怒不可遏，并且……你怎么能，你知道的，你就是个笑话。
from people who do not like what you say in your stories? I have a very thin skin. I am very sensitive. I cry all the time. The Republicans on the House Judiciary Committee, just a couple weeks ago, I did this story on the weaponization of social media, this like bullshit subcommittee led by Jim Jordan. And I, I'm allowed to say bullshit. I'm sorry. It's okay. This is a free wheeling podcast. You know, it's, it's in the book. If it's a word, if the word is used in the book, we can use it on the podcast. So I think we're okay. Um, so I reported on this committee and Jim Jordan's, um, flack reached out to me and was just, I rate and, um, how could you, you know, you're a joke.
所以他们发了13、14条左右的内容，发了一串巨大的推文来攻击我，说我是多么糟糕。不出你所料，很多人因此对我很生气。所以总的来说，感觉很糟糕，而这还算是我得到的比较友好的回应之一。塔克·卡尔森（Tucker Carlson）的节目里曾专门播出关于我的片段，说我是所谓的“法西斯左翼的面孔”之类的话。这非常怪异、荒谬，且毫无事实根据。所以我无法对此做进一步的解释，但这确实滋生了大量的仇恨和敌意，而且你知道的，我和罗伯特·卡罗一样，只是个普通人。不，但就像我是个正常人一样。我有孩子。我有个丈夫，他不怎么上网，也不懂我在做什么，这太棒了。我强烈建议你也这么做。但这很难。这真的很悲哀。我觉得拥有超越这种报道的生活非常重要。
And so that they did this like 13, 14 something, this like huge tweet thread about me and how awful I am. And it will not surprise you to learn that lots of people got very angry at me about that. So generally it feels bad and that's sort of one of the nicest things responses that I've had. I've had Tucker Carlson segments on about me, about how I'm the quote face
所以当我合上笔记本电脑，和我的孩子们在一起，或者和街上那些觉得我很棒的邻居们在一起时，我不会觉得自己生活在这样一个世界里：在这个世界里，那些满嘴胡言乱语的人、靠谎言赚钱攻击他人的人，能够触及到我。我的意思是，罗伯特·卡罗曾讲过这样一个故事：他在档案馆做研究。当时正值外界开始流传他要写一本对罗伯特·摩西持严厉批评态度的书的时候。
of the fascist left and things of that. It's very weird and nonsensical and not based in fact. So I can't explain it any further than that, but it does, it breeds a lot of hatred and animosity and you know, I am much like Robert Caro, just a simple person. No, but like I'm a normal person. I have kids. I have a husband who doesn't go on the internet and like doesn't understand what I do, which is great. I highly recommend doing that. But it's hard. It's really sad. I think it's really important to have a life outside of, you know, this kind of reporting.
很长一段时间里，人们并不知道他的立场会是什么，但罗伯特·摩西察觉到了这一点，他弄清了真相。于是，那些与摩西结盟的人撤掉了地下室档案馆里的灯泡，好让卡罗无法工作，于是他只好自己带了一个灯泡去。我是那种极度害怕冲突的人，如果是我，我会想：
So when I close my laptop and I'm with my children or with my neighbors on my street who think I'm great, that it doesn't feel like I live in this world where, um, bullshit artists and people who make money lying about other people, like where they can get to me. I mean, there's a story that Robert Caro tells of doing his archive research. And this is about the time where it's starting to get out that he's gonna write a very critical book of Robert Moses.
好吧，就这样，我要撤了，因为有人会在黑暗中揍我一顿。那么，当有这么多的恶意针对那些不同意你观点的人向你袭来时，究竟是什么促使你继续冲进这个火坑的？好吧。你这么说，但在餐馆里我从来不把菜退回去。就像我，我讨厌抱怨。我不想让任何人都觉得我是个刻薄的人。
For a long time, people don't really know what his take is gonna be, but Robert Moses cottons onto it and they figures it out. And so these people who are allied with Moses, take away the light bulbs in the basement archives so that he can't do his work and so he just brings a light bulb instead. And I am so anti-confrontational that I'd be like,
如果我，你知道，现在说我对贝类过敏，我可能会死。请把它拿回去吧。我会安静地坐在那里，等回家吃花生酱果酱三明治时再处理。我只会吃一个花生酱果酱三明治，然后我会想：我就接受它吧，它其实挺好吃的，只是我不再饿了，谢谢。但某种程度上，我经常想到“通过一个人的敌人来判断这个人”。所以当有人试图，当你有一篇报道在为弱势群体、遭受伤害的人、或者根本没有机会讲述自己故事的人发声，而有权势的人却试图阻止你时，那种感觉是非常具有电击感的，我会有一种强烈的感受：你们怎么敢？这会让人充满活力，这是一种精神上的某种……这只是一种美丽、美丽的体验。即使你认为自己不喜欢与人对抗，但在那个时刻，我真的很喜欢它。当我准备打电话给一个不想跟我交谈的人时，我会产生一点点……我会有点飘飘然，
okay, that's it, I'm gonna be out because someone's gonna beat me up in the dark. So what makes you keep going into this fray when there's so much nastiness coming back at you for people who disagree with you. Okay. You say that, but like, I don't ever send things back in restaurants. Like I, I hate to complain. I don't want anyone to think I'm like a mean person.
而这就是他们要开口的时刻。这其中有非常非常有趣的东西，对吧？你知道，如果他们把你的灯泡拿走了，说明你做对了事。太棒了。非常感谢你让我知道我的工作得到了赞赏，我正走在正确的轨道上，你知道的，是时候继续前进了。最糟糕的事情是你被忽视了，对吧？如果没人关心你在做什么，那可能说明你并没有一个
If I, you know, say I'm allergic to shellfish now I might die. Please take it back. I'll just sit there quietly and deal with it later when I get home and eat a PB&J. I'll just eat a PB&J and then I'll be like, I'll just take it, it was delicious, I'm just not hungry anymore, thank you. But there's something, I think a lot about judge a man by his enemies. And so there is something when someone's trying to, when you have a story that's shining a light on vulnerable people or people who are being harmed or people that just don't have a chance
很好的故事。布兰迪，在成为记者之前，你是一名参考咨询馆员，对吧？千真万确的事实。我出自一个图书馆员世家。我妈妈是参考咨询馆员，我奶奶也是图书馆员，我妻子也是图书馆员，她去的也是你获得MLS（图书馆学硕士）学位的学校。所以我真的很想问你——我们已经从调查记者的角度听你谈过了罗伯特·卡罗的方法，但从你的参考咨询馆员的角度来看，他是如何寻找信息的？他是怎么做的？
to tell their story and there are people with power trying to get you to stop that, that is very electric in this way that I feel a lot like, how dare you? And it is energizing and it is a spiritual sort of, it's just a, it's a beautiful, beautiful thing. And even if you don't think that you like to be antagonistic, there is that moment where I really like it. And I get a little like, I get a little high when I'm about to call someone who doesn't want to talk to me and
作为一个图书馆员，作为一名参考咨询馆员，你对此有何感想？噢，我的天哪，这让我有点想哭。卡罗就是那种我们所有人都梦想着来到满是灰尘的书库里、怀揣着伟大构想的人。作为一名参考咨询馆员，你会成为那种搜寻工作中的合作伙伴，对吧？这不仅仅是“我在找这本确切的书”。事情不是那样运作的，对吧？你会说：“我在寻找所有这些东西。”然后，他们真的会进行研究，研究咨询馆员们会自己做研究，然后带给你：
this is the moment when they're gonna. There's something very, very fun about that, right? You know if they're taking the light bulbs away from you, you're doing something right. That's great. Thank you so much for making sure that I knew that my work has been appreciated and I'm on the right track and you know, time to keep going. The worst thing is if you're just ignored, right? If nobody cares about what you're doing, then that probably shows that you don't have a
“也许你会喜欢这个，也许这个能帮到忙。”它变成了这样一种伙伴关系。所以我绝对热爱这一点。当我们之前谈到……你知道的，走进布满灰尘的书库或类似的地方时，我脑子里想了很多。我花了那么多时间在纽约公共图书馆（NYPL）的特藏部翻阅、钻研并做那些工作。在翻阅这些书页、查阅这些旧纸箱时，有一种非常直观、重要且浪漫的体验，
very good story. Brandi, before you were a reporter, you were a reference librarian, correct? True, true fact. And I come from a line of librarians. My mom's a reference librarian, my mom's a reference librarian my grandmother's librarian My wife's a librarian and she went to the same school you went to to get her MLS And so I really wanted to ask you we've heard from the investigative reporter side of you about Robert Carroll's methods But what about from the reference librarian side of you how he goes about finding information what he does
那些你在文件柜里发现一封已经静静躺了40年的信件的时刻，以及那种“啊哈”的顿悟时刻，我们在如今这个世界里已经很难得到了。而图书馆员正是这个过程中非常重要的组成部分。所以，经历这一切，
How do you feel about that as a librarian as a reference librarian? Oh My god, it makes me teary a little bit. Like, Caro is the person who we all sort of dream about coming down into the dusty stacks, like with this big idea, and you become, as a reference librarian, you become a partner, right, in that search. It's not just, I'm looking for this exact book. It doesn't work like that, right? You say, I'm looking for all of these things. And then, they really do research librarians, they research on their own and they bring you,
并想象着一路上遇到的那些图书馆员，我经常会想到这一点。我有时会想，我母亲每当接到别人的研究咨询时，她都会全力以赴，并且对此感到非常兴奋，然后把她发现的所有事情都告诉我。通常会有这样一个时刻：比起最初向她提问的那个人，她自己
maybe you'll like this, maybe this will help. And it becomes this sort of partnership. So I absolutely love that. And I thought a lot about it when we were talking earlier about you know going down into the dusty stacks or whatever it is, and I spent so much time looking, pouring over, you know, special collections at NYPL and and doing that work and there's something just so visceral and important and romantic
对这个话题更感兴趣。她找到了他们寻找的信息，但她还有所有这些更多想提供给对方的信息，而对方其实并不真的需要。我就在想，是的，也许罗伯特·卡罗就是那种梦想中的客户，因为他走进来，图书馆员会说：“我们发现了这个。”而他会说：“对，对，把所有的东西都拿给我。任何我能看的东西，我都会看。”我知道我母亲渴望人们能像那样来到图书馆。
about flipping through these pages and looking through these old boxes and the moments where you find a letter that's been sitting in a filing cabinet for whatever, 40 years, and that moment of, aha, that we don't get so much in this world. And librarians are such an important part of that process. So very going through all of these things
我知道，他在一个地方做过演讲，我想是在纽约历史学会（New York Historical Society）或者类似的地方。当时我就想：噢，我想和纽约历史学会的图书馆员谈谈，我想听听那个故事。是的，我敢肯定那是一段神奇的时光。所以我们联系你并想和你聊聊的原因之一，是因为你发了这样一条推文，我很想剖析一下：
and imagining sort of the librarians along the way, I have thought about that often. It's something I wonder, my mother, when she gets a question from somebody to research, she really goes all out and she gets very excited about it and then tells me about all the things she found. And there's often a point where she is more interested
“我刚读完《权力的经纪人》，其核心主题是：男人都是巨大的巨婴。”你能为我拆解一下吗？你写下这句话时在想些什么？我当时在想，你知道的，每当罗伯特·摩西威胁要辞职时，我就想象自己灵魂出窍、穿越时空，不知怎么地进入了这些男人的体内，
in it at a certain point than the person who asked her the question in the beginning. Like she's got the information they were looking for, but she has all this more information that she wants to give them and they don't really need it. And I wonder if, yeah, maybe Robert Caro is the dream client because he comes in and the librarians will say, and we found this. And he would be like, yeah, yeah, bring me everything. Anything that I can look at, I would look at. I know my mother yearns for people to come like that to the library.
然后只想说：太酷了，走吧。去撬锁吧，朋友。没错。就像滚出大门一样。他根本不算什么。他什么都不是——我的意思是，他是，但实际上他并不是，对吧？没有你，世界也会运转得很好。没有你，这个办公室也会运转得很好。没有你，游泳队也一样运转得很好，我们会活下去的，快走吧。
I know, he did a talk at, I think the New York Historical Society or something. And I was like, oh, I wanna talk to the librarians at the New York Historical Society and I want that story. Yeah, I'm sure it was kind of a magical time. So one of the reasons why we got in touch and we wanted to talk to you is when you tweeted this thing that I'd love to interrogate,
而且，你知道的，我知道随着他后来积累了更多的权力和更多的责任与头衔，事情变得更加复杂了，但即便如此，我想这几乎就像辞职一样，你觉得：噢，我绝对做不到，这是我一辈子要做的工作。然后你辞职了，你会想：噢，我其实一直都可以这么做。但真的，我简直不敢相信他能把辞职挂在嘴边那么多次，
which is I just finished reading The Power Broker and the central theme is that men are huge babies. Can you unpack that for me? What were you thinking about when you wrote that? So I was thinking about, you know, every single time Robert Moses threatened to resign, I imagined myself leaving my body and going back in time and somehow being in the bodies of these men
却没有人真的顺着他的台阶答应他。就是，噢，这真的太让我恼火了。这把我逼疯了。真是个巨大的巨婴。我的意思是，我身边也有过这种男人——很抱歉，总是男人——他们会做这种事。我当时只想说：滚开，成熟一点吧。
and just being like, cool, Yes. Pick locks, friend. Yeah. Like out the door. You're, he's not anything. He's just, he's not, I mean, he is, but like, he's actually not, right? Like the world would be fine without you. This office would be fine without you. The swim team was fine without you and we will survive, get to going.
总之，是的，那就是……我觉得这就是当书中我的热情被最大程度点燃时的体验，那就是每一次面对那些辞职时，因为你只是希望自己能穿越时空，然后接管菲奥雷洛·拉瓜迪亚（Fiorello LaGuardia）的身体，然后说：这可是市长啊。你可是市长。你可是州长。你管辖着一座城市。拜托，清醒点吧。
And, you know, I know it got more complicated as he amassed more power and more responsibilities and job titles later on, but even then, I think it's almost like quitting a job, you feel like, oh, I could never do it, this is what I do forever, and then you quit, and you're like, oh, I could just do that the whole time. But yeah, I couldn't believe that he was able to offer his resignation so many times
而且，特别是在这一集中，我也总是觉得摩西是个大婴儿，但同时罗斯福也有那么多事情要处理，但他仍然像是在说：必须除掉摩西。我不能，我就是不能错过这个干掉他的机会。而这就好比是：你在这个时候本该处于更高的层面。你是美利坚合众国的总统。你为什么要在乎这个？还要试着去解决大萧条，就像……
and that nobody took him up on it. Just, oh, it just irked me so much. It drives me crazy. What a big baby. I mean, I've been around men like this and I'm sorry, it's always men, but who do this sort of thing. And I'm just like, get away, like grow up.
对，大萧条正在发生，欧洲看起来要爆发战争了。你可以把这个你以前不喜欢的、负责纽约地区公园的家伙忘掉。就像是，但他做不到。他就是无法……永远不要低估人们小心眼的程度。这太惊人了。
Anyway, so yeah, that was the, that was. I think that's my experience of like when, when my passions are like lit up the most in the book, is every one of those resignations, cause you just wish you could go back in time, and just like take over the body of Fiorello LaGuardia and say, These are like mayors. You're the mayor. You're the governor. You run a city. Like, come on, find it.
好吧，这太棒了。布兰迪，和你聊天太开心了。非常感谢你能来并成为读书俱乐部的一员。噢，天哪。这是我的绝对荣幸。我将和大家一起度过剩下的剧集。非常感谢你们。谢谢你加入我们。
Well, and especially in this episode too, it always strikes me that Moses is a huge baby, but also that Roosevelt has so much going on with him, and he's still like, gotta get rid of Moses. I cannot, I just can't miss this opportunity to take him out, and it's like, you should be on a higher level at this point. You're the president of the United States. Like, why do you care? Trying to fix the depression, like.
欢迎收看本月播客《拆解99%隐形：权力经纪人》。下个月，我们将带着第五部分“权力的爱”回归，下个月我们将回顾第25章和第26章。也就是我书中的第499页到第606页。嘿，听着，如果你厌倦了学习新知识，只想听一堆废话，为什么不去看看我的另一个播客《烂片屋》（The Flophouse）呢？
Yeah, the depression is going on, it looks like there's gonna be a war in Europe. Like, you could forget about this guy you used to not like who's in charge of the parks in the New York area. Like, it's, but he can't do it. He's just can't look good. Never underestimate people's ability to be petty. It's amazing.
我向你保证，你什么也学不到。如果你想读一个古希腊英雄历险的故事，为什么不去试试我为Dynamite创作的全新《大力神》漫画系列呢？这跟我们今天讨论的话题相比，甚至比《烂片屋》还要无关。我们的Discord上有许多精彩的讨论欢迎大家加入。链接在我们的网站上，或者访问 discord.gg/99pi。如果出于某种原因，你只是为了这些《权力的经纪人》的拆解节目才加入我们，而并没有
Well, this is great. It's been so much fun talking with you, Brandi. I really appreciate you coming on and being part of the book club. Oh my God. It's my absolute pleasure. I will be with y'all for remaining episodes. And thank you so much. Thank you for joining us.
收听常规节目《99%隐形》（99% Invisible），我真的极力敦促你去听听。我们的制作人之一拉什·马丹（Lash Madan）去了印度，发现了一个名为《寂静之塔》（Towers of Silence）的精彩故事，我只想让全世界的每个人都去听听。我们的制作人之一拉什·马丹去了印度，并报导了这个精彩的故事，名叫《寂静之塔》，我只想让全世界的所有人都去听一听。所以，如果你还没有听过所有不同集的《99%隐形》，现在就花点时间听一两集吧，我想你会喜欢的。这就是对《权力经纪人》的《99%隐形》拆解节目
On this month's episode of the 99% Invisible Breakdown of the Power Broker, next month, we'll be back with part five, The Love of Power, recovering chapters 25 and 26 next month. That's pages 499 through 606 in my book. And hey, look, if you're tired of learning things and just wanna hear a bunch of nonsense, why not check out my other podcast, The Flophouse?
在《99%无形》本月对《权力掮客》的深度解析节目中，下个月我们将带着第五部分“权力的热爱”回归，下个月将涵盖第25章和第26章。这对应我书中的第499到第606页。嘿，听着，如果你厌倦了学习新知识，只想听一堆废话，为什么不看看我的另一个播客《烂片屋》呢？
I promise you will learn nothing. And if you wanna read about an ancient Greek hero having adventures, why not try my new Hercules comic book series from Dynamite, even less related to what we're talking about today than The Flophouse is. There's a lot of great discussion going on in our Discord to join in. The link is on our website or go to discord.gg slash nine nine P I. And if for some reason you're just joining us for these power broker breakdowns and not
我向你保证，你什么也学不到。如果你想读一个古希腊英雄的冒险故事，为什么不试试我在Dynamite出的全新大力神赫拉克勒斯漫画系列呢？它甚至比《烂片屋》还要和我们今天讨论的话题无关。我们的Discord上有很多精彩的讨论，快来加入吧。链接在我们的网站上，或者访问 discord.gg 斜杠 nine nine P I。如果出于某种原因你只是为了这些权力掮客深度解析节目而加入，而不是
listening to the regular show, 99% invisible, I really urge you to check it out. One of our producers, Lash Madon went to India and found this amazing story called Towers of Silence that I just want everyone in the world to check it out. One of our producers, Lash Madan, went to India and filed this amazing story called Towers of Silence that I just want everyone in the world to check out. So if you don't listen to all the different 99% Invisible episodes already, take some time and listen to one or two of them now, and I think you'll like it. The 99% Invisible breakdown of The Power Broker
收听常规节目《99%无形》，我真的敦促你们去看一看。我们的制作人之一拉什·马登去了印度，发现了这个名为《寂静之塔》的精彩故事，我只想让世界上的每个人都去听听看。我们的制作人之一拉什·马登去印度采写了这个名为《寂静之塔》的精彩故事，我只想让全世界的人都去听听。所以，如果你还没有听过所有不同集的《99%无形》，现在就花点时间听一两个，我想你会喜欢的。《99%无形》对《权力掮客》的深度解析
is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by Comiti, music by Swan Rial, mixed by Dara Hirsch. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kirk Holstead is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Sarah Bake, Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Nina Potuck, and me, Roman Mars.
由 Isabel Angel 制作，Comiti 编辑，Swan Rial 配乐，Dara Hirsch 混音。《99% Invisible》的执行制片人是 Cathy Tu，高级编辑是 Delaney Hall，数字总监是 Kirk Holstead，团队其他成员包括 Sarah Bake、Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Gabriella Gladney、Martin Gonzalez、Christopher Johnson、Vivian Ley、Lashma Dawn、Jacob Maldonado Medina、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Nina Potuck，以及我，Roman Mars。
The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show on all the usual social media sites as well as your own discord server where we talk about the power broker Architecture movies music all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out the most these days You can find a link to the discord server as well as every past episode of 99 PI and 99 PI
他标志中那 99% 的部分由 Stefan Lawrence 创建。本系列的艺术作品由 Aaron Nestor 创作。我们属于 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族，现在总部位于潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及你自己的 Discord 服务器上找到这个节目，我们在那里讨论《权力经纪人》、建筑、电影、音乐以及各种好东西。这也是我这些天最常闲逛的地方。你可以找到通往 Discord 服务器的链接，以及 99 PI 和 99 PI 的每一期往期节目。
org N99pi.org. Sometimes when I interview people and they're Southern, my Southern accent comes out, you know, just to, you know, like build some affinity. Do you ever do that? Okay. Do I have a Southern accent? Yes, I do.
org N99pi.org。有时当我采访南方人时，我的南方口音就会冒出来，你知道的，只是为了，你知道的，建立一些亲近感。你也会这样做吗？好的。我有南方口音吗？是的，我有。
Have I maybe whipped it out a little sooner than, um, it would have naturally come. Potentially, possibly, perhaps. Would I do it again? Absolutely. And I bet when Robert Caro is going to Texas to get a Lyndon Johnson story, it's gonna take three years because there's no,
我是不是可能把它拿出来得有点早了，嗯，比它自然出现的时候要早。有可能，也许，或许。我还会再这样做吗？绝对会。我敢打赌，当罗伯特·卡罗去德克萨斯州采访林登·约翰逊的故事时，这需要三年的时间，因为没有，
his accent is unheightable. There's no mistaking that accent for exactly where he's from. I know, although we would find it endearing. It would be like, that would be a thing, right? That like you're sort of known for, that we would enjoy, bless his heart. Yeah, exactly, bless his heart indeed. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他的口音是无法掩饰的。毫无疑问，那种口音正表明了他来自哪里。我知道，尽管我们会觉得这很亲切。这就成了一回事，对吧？就像你因此而闻名，我们会喜欢的，真可怜。是的，确实如此，真可怜。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。